[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
shout out to the chat the crowd is
bringing the energy today miss amigos we
see you
we see the palacio de santonia we have
round nine ahead maybe the biggest round
the most pitiful pivotal moment we've
had so far in the 2022 feed a candidates
is in store for us today we know the
match-up we know what we're talking
about karwana napaneshi what will happen
but before we get to that of course we
look upon
the beautiful art the beautiful scenery
the beautiful battlefield that we know
as the royal game the game of kings
those 64 squares will play host for your
hosts to commentate on what the players
will bring us today grand master robert
hess grand master daniel naradiski
international master danny wrench boys
are you ready to bring it today i
thought you're going to hear the miss
amigos amigos
that was so inconsistent
my friends are you ready to bring it
today oh i certainly am round eight was
very exciting round nine might be even
better donya you're still happy you came
to madrid i am so happy that i came to
my dude it was my second day here we've
got some incredible matchups today i
can't wait well as robert said before we
talk about round nine we have to remind
you of what happened in round eight
report brought it he looked good he got
the dub robert yeah that jacket you
couldn't stop talking about it but
nobody stopped talking about his win
because that was a really nice one over
at yacht church of duda yana pomnashie
didn't come to the board planning to get
a win apparently donya listen we knew he
would play solidly we didn't anticipate
just how solidly he would play he really
tried to kill the game as quickly as
possible tried to start the second half
of the tournament without losing and hey
you succeeded today will tell if that
strategy was a success success in the
grand scheme of things yup well of
course we're going to talk about
nakamura caruana i bet you already know
what's in store for you a beautiful
highlight recap video but before we do
i'll mention quickly again farrugia
keeps fighting we know he has a bright
future he was unable uh to get his first
win versus team river job off and tame
over java also almost had chances in a
game that brought us a lot of fun and
drama but okay before we get in to the
drama that will be in store for us today
the drama was was on the board for hours
with nakamura and caron and then it was
drama off the board with with uh with
streams and just a reaction by the
players we got all kinds of stuff to
break down here in our pregame show but
before we unpack all of it we're going
to start things off like we do with this
beautiful recap video of the game of the
day from yesterday
hikaru nakamura is no stranger to big
viewership but his all-usa rematch
against fabiano carowana was still his
most viewed classical chess game of all
time
with excellent play hikaru had punished
carawan's enterprising choice of the
dilworth variation an opening adventure
hikaru had predicted and had prepared
for
yeah i mean i was just trying to play
normal um but the funny thing is i
actually thought fabiano might play this
so i spent like two hours last night
looking at this
all these crazy variations i'm in this
open spanish
victory soon seemed in his grasp and he
put his jacket back on in readiness for
resignation
but the hasty bishop to e1 allowed fabi
new life
suddenly his rook became dangerously
active and fabi perked up as hikaru took
his jacket back off
viewers poured in to watch the finish as
more than fifty thousand tuned in on
twitch.tv chess and far more than a
hundred thousand were watching on all
broadcasts
with minutes on his clock fabi missed a
final chance to invade with his rook and
hikara rearranged his minor pieces to
affect a blockade
as his remaining pawns began falling
caruana resigned
[Music]
it was dramatic thank you again to the
team bringing us those dramatic recaps
we're going to talk a lot about
obviously what this means for fabi he
has the biggest game of the day coming
up but how big was that for hikaru
nakamura dania to get that victory his
first in seven years versus his usa
rival it was huge and throughout the
tournament hikaru consistently talked
about being satisfied of the way he
played now there were some individual
results that obviously he wasn't too
satisfied with he lost round one he had
that frustrating game against nepal
where he had some chances but by and
large you could tell that he was snappy
he was sharp his preparation was
excellent and all of that paid off
yesterday that was an unbelievable game
and that kind of game will be analyzed
for many months to come there is so much
to unpack from that amazing display in
all three stages of the game by hikaru
yeah well it did it was amazing and
robert i wanna you sign up but as we
bring up the standings and just show
where that puts hikaru he's now only a
half a point behind fabiano karwana
still a point and a half behind yanupon
rishi so let's let's be realistic the
hype is real right it was it was a great
game robert but what does cecaro have to
do to really really cement that this is
now a three-horse race again yeah he
just needs to make sure this wasn't a
one-off victory yeah and he beat his
compatriot yesterday now his compatriot
needs to be his friend because he needs
uh fabiano's help to catch jian
napomishi but as dania said hikaru is
playing some excellent chess speaking of
how hikar has been playing let's bring
up who hikaru will be playing uh i'm
gonna go and reverse earn her now and
start with you robert looking at
hiccaro's remaining rounds his
head-to-head versus all the players
what about this stands out to you well i
look at the left most column and the
right most column i see two losses total
and against only one player that's the
term leader jan napomshi yeah and the
leftmost column we see 10 total
victories so 10 wins two losses and a
bunch of draws against this opposition
that bodes well for carl's chances any
game you want to circle there or any
stat you want to circle about what you
see about hikaru's back half chances
well i point out two things i think he's
got white against players that he really
does want to be white against and i'd
point out in particular his game against
sally raza faruja and his game in the
penultimate round against jkd yan
shistak duda both of those players have
been struggling and couple that with
icarus amazing preparation of the white
pieces i think there are a couple of
games that he is really hoping to win in
the second half yeah okay
well
makes makes sense we've we've got uh so
much to talk about of course with hikaru
whether he can keep it up uh in the back
half and keep this a three horse race
but let's move into previewing not just
icardo's game of course uh he does get
the black pieces versus him over java
but all of the round nine battles that
are coming our way uh robert why don't
we start right there as i said rajabov
nakamura hikaru has a good record but
tamora is white today yeah tamara has
the white pieces the first move
advantage he's been fighting very hard
throughout this event so it's not a game
that hikara can take lightly just
because of their previous
wins for hikaru and you know he has
never lost their job of today could be
the first time but with the form that
hikar is in he should try to make the
most of his chances i want to quickly go
through the others don you're weighing
in on varusha with the white piece is
still looking for that first candidate's
victory against report yeah that's going
to be an incredible game rapport with
the black pieces he always brings the
heat he has this tournament he won
yesterday's game and richard report
isn't just somebody who's going to say
yeah let me play really solid today try
to make that draw he is going to try to
build up that winning streak and ali
reza as you mentioned he is hungry for
that first victory i'm predicting a very
interesting tactical game
in uh perugia report dingley wren's
still looking for his mojo uh we don't
know what he's gonna do but he's got
duda on st on tap here what's he gonna
do against the number one player from
poland well we've been saying ever since
his first round loss to jana palmache
that dingley wren he needs to win his
games and he's had some good chances
he's had some massive advantages he
unfortunately spoiled those chances and
now he plays the player who's maybe
really most we saw junction up due to
space after he lost to richard report he
was just absolutely devastated and it
was heartbreaking to see but i don't
think dingle ren is going gonna lend him
any sympathy he's gonna try to punish
the guy while he's down okay
well i feel like we paid our dues to the
other three matchups we we circled
around it long enough it's time to make
a big circle around caruana and
napomnishi all eyes on the american of
course trailing uh the russian by a full
point what can he do in this game with
white who's feeling more pressure i'm
gonna just start with that question
de panma she
is a point ahead but is he gonna be
feeling pressure with black here against
caruana today well both of them are
going to be feeling tremendous pressure
there's no question about that but i
would argue that the real pressure is on
fabby because let's consider the
scenarios
let's say fabio wins the game for napo
that would be a very painful loss but he
would still be tied for first he'd still
be in a great situation in the
tournament now let's reverse that let's
say fabi loses with white
he nepo goes up to a two-point lead fabi
basically loses all of his chances for
first place so just objectively i would
argue that there is more at stake for
fabian the last thing i'd say he better
follow the advice yielded by jan's last
name napolishing means one who doesn't
remember fabi has to put yesterday's
game out of his mind focus on the bigger
picture of how well he's played this
tournament in a second we're going to
get the final thoughts that hikara
nakamura had on yesterday's game but i
just want to let you sound off again on
bobby's you know does he needs to have
short-term memory you know what what
what would you advise would you give to
your friend heading into this game
versus the pawn machine well i think
what dania said is true the pressure is
on fabi from a tournament perspective
but also over the board the players time
and time again they say having the white
piece is more difficult because you have
to prove that first move advantage yeah
and in previous games against yonder
palmishi we've seen bobby have the white
side the sicilian the white side of a
petrov and also played d4 and got a
grunfeld in the last candidates where he
had an advantage but let it slip against
yonder machine i like that you
kind of kind of dove into what bobby
might be thinking about the opening
obviously they do feel pressure as white
because they feel like they have to win
uh and what fabiano brings to the table
in terms of the opening might be the
story we're talking about because it
definitely was the story of yesterday's
game uh we saw hikaru nakamura give his
thoughts before yesterday's show ended
to dina bellancaya fabiano caruana also
gave his thoughts to dino we're going to
unpack that interview later on in the
day but after after the interview hikaru
joined his own stream as he often does
and here's what he had to say about his
surprise and thoughts about what his
rival from the states brought to the
table
yeah i mean i i think uh i i will say
however that i think today being being a
streamer helped me because i think
fabiano for whatever reason i think he
just assumed that i'm like just chilling
on the beach all day and i'm not
studying openings before this tournament
right because playing the open spanish i
mean is going into this whole line which
is very very sharp it's just
inexplicable honestly i mean it's just a
i just i don't understand the decision
by him at all
um because it's just it's it's insane it
isn't because because again like the
thing is like black can win in some of
these lines but if you're not super
precise you're just going to end up
losing the game because white has a very
clear-cut plan and black doesn't have a
plan and if white ever gets a blockade
it's just
it's just a disaster like in the game so
um i mean i i just thought fabiano i i
mean i just i don't know why he chose to
do this against me today basically
so
candid thoughts from michael nakamura on
his channel as he as he always gives
them and let both you just sound off
your agreement or disagreement or your
thoughts on what hicaro's takeaways were
about caruana's approach i mean i get
why he was surprised because bobby likes
solid play especially with the black
pieces
and i get why hikaru was fired up he
played an open royal opus he played the
kind of opening which has dubious vibes
at the same time
let's not overstate the case if fabi had
played e4 instead of c4 we might have
been having a completely different
conversation here so i like to focus on
individual moments
and as fabi himself revealed in his
interview he just overestimated his
position he actually thought he was
better after c4
but i get it i get it hikaru was fired
up i also think what contributed to that
was the fact that he lost round one so
he had a chip in the shoulder chip on
his shoulder coming in as well we will
get to fabi's thoughts later on in the
show today everyone robert your thoughts
on hikaru nakamura's opinion there yeah
we were asking each other that question
yesterday is who is gonna a long string
of opening theory go into favor and the
type of position that resulted was one
assaykara said where he could play for a
win without much risk and he played in
exceptionally strong games so you just
have to give credit where it's due i
think that fabiano's camp will regret
the decision but it's mainly because
excuse me hikaru played so darn well
yeah and shout out to hikaru for giving
us rights to use that clip from his
channel we do appreciate it they are
bringing commentary daily over there as
well and uh we appreciate all the
channels covering this incredible event
wherever they are across the world the
ch the chess world has its eyes on you
or people have their eyes on the chess
world i don't know it sounded like a
hamilton thing to say so i said it but
all right right now i need to let people
know what i'm going to say about who's
going to win the games today head on
over to chess.com events use the command
guess and get it done before 10 moves
have been played for your chance to be a
part of all the prizes i'm going to
start right at the top you know i'm
going to predict it i believe it's going
to happen i believe we are going to have
nothing but fire and drama in madrid for
the rest of this week i think fabiano is
going to show up and get the win with
the white pieces today i really do and
uh hey danny okay i mean
okay i really do i think we're gonna
have a draw here again
uh with farouja and report i know what
you're thinking um i jinx all kinds of
results i don't even know what i'm doing
um
i actually think that we're gonna get a
draw here as well i think that rajab is
going to be super solid and hold this
one and i think dingley wren though
unfortunately is going to take advantage
of a struggling duda and finally get his
first win at the candidates for the
for the first time in a long time yeah i
know there's money at stake and people
are voting to win some cash prizes yeah
but i think there's a little bit of a
hikaru bias i saw the results once you
made your vote and a really ridiculously
high percentage of people said a car is
going to win with the black pieces i
could i could go back to that and look
at it i see now oh wow yeah that was uh
a lot of people predicting hikaru
nakamura when hikaro bias itis is
something that the chess.com community
uh can have at times apparently but okay
i predicted a draw i'm in the minority
apparently all right but as we said you
can cast your vote to win cash prizes
you can uh cast your vote for that guy
to get the dub with the black pieces
like so many people seem to be doing go
to go.chess.com candidates-guest premium
memberships bragging rights against your
friends against me on social media if
you can prove that you outvoted me
throughout the event um maybe i'll give
you a diamond membership or maybe i'll
just block you on twitter i don't know
what i'm going to do i'm a wild card
that guy has
been a card at times in his career the
things that he was criticized for for at
many different times maybe playing too
quickly losing his focus being a player
who's streaky that hasn't been the yawn
to palm rishi here in madrid and
actually i'm noticing the outfit
fabiano wearing a blue shirt he's
wearing white shirt throughout most of
this tournament janupamshi sticking to
the same suit hikaru nakamura we saw him
before wearing the same jacket as
yesterday so i think superstition is
abound in the playing hall i love that
and by the way i thank you for not
letting me be the first person to
comment on the players outfits go ahead
guys no are you superstition to bounce
i'm doing laundry rebounds in the plane
we're doing laundry uh every night so
that um so that that shirt that yon is
wearing that looks fresh can continue to
smell fresh
hey maybe he's doing like i don't know
the steve jobs he's got the same looking
shirt 15 times over yeah he's got it
it's actually quite possible i actually
do have a bunch like the same t-shirt so
yeah yeah sam all right
well uh what will happen today we see
that we have the cameras
on these two players this is this is the
match-up that we will catch every single
moment of not to say that the other the
other chess games of course won't get
our attention
very often instruction and excitement
come from the other games but we we're
going to focus on that one yeah who's
next to dingley wren
um
somebody's next to dingley wren you're
looking at us like we're supposed to
know who that is
he's we're in a new york new york wow
brooklyn short robert's so happy right
now i know i know the answer to the
question where's brooklyn at
where's brooklyn at shout out right now
uh you got a yankees it's yankees right
no no it's the new york college league
the logo looked very much like a new
york yankees logo yeah that seems like a
lawsuit yeah i was going to say does
anyone want to
contact steinbrenner about that because
uh we've got these are usually the
special guests who are there to make
their first moves by the way uh of
course that's a tradition in chess you
get celebrities
uh
local people just all kinds of all kinds
of people with with special interests
get to come make the first match it's a
funny story about that i don't know if i
have time to tell it really quickly go
ahead but uh sam shankly told me the
stories we see
the dignitary execute his first move and
a handshake there from fabi but
vishyanan was giving a special
appearance with one of those dignitaries
um and
they were supposed to play a couple of
moves of a chess game as an exhibition
the this dignitary did not play any
chess so on move one he took his knight
from b1 and put it on e4
but being the class act that he is vishy
didn't want to make him look bad so he
took his b8 knight and put it on e5
that's so great
that is so great um
well we uh we now see the face of that
young gentleman who'll be making the
first move
uh pretty pretty exciting there and uh
one thing that we noticed when we were
looking at the board between fabio
carwana and yonder pomnishi was that
yan's knights were facing to the side
bobby's knights facing forward we know
that all players in addition to having
superstition about what they wear
whether things are going well or poorly
might cause them to keep the same
clothes on or change
all players tend to have superstitions
about how they set up their knights
uh
shout out to xqc apparently from
bonchest not sure where xqc is in the
wide world of the twitch interwebs but
if he's here welcome
well e4 played by five under carwana and
i was saying oh they thought that dude
looked like suc i'm sorry that was funny
okay because he didn't at all oh like
not in the slightest no like not at all
that wouldn't occur to me you know my
wildest dreams not to pile onto this
chatter yeah but
i think we should go shame yourself
chatter
all right okay we would catch that
trough wow that's actually really
big news for
everybody at home because
the world's leading expert in the petrov
might be bob johnson
he has used that with great success over
a large number of years now but yonder
palmicide going
right back to his trusted weapon well i
was gonna say fabiano was arguably the
world leading expert in the petrov for
the last decade or so but yonder palm
rishi just played in a world
championship where we know he brought a
lot of preparation in the petrov uh
potentially
the potential to use it for both sides
really depending on how things would go
with magnus so
uh we're gonna we are going to have a
theoretical battle in store for us in
that game today donya we absolutely will
and i'm seeing the bigger picture here
yesterday four out of four games started
one e4 today three out of four games
started with one e4 so that's kind of a
transition from some of the previous
super tournaments that we've seen up in
the top right
uh
berlin
but at least it's an anti-berlin at
least it's not an end you're talking
about top right i look at the top left
for a second and report that's important
again thinking on the problem by the way
he did this yesterday too we we um we
had a moment we were caught up um
uh on some other storyline and yesterday
of course for those who were here early
we even had some tactical difficulties
shout out again to the team for rallying
so quickly but report did the same thing
yesterday he thought for quite a bit
before playing his first move versus
duda and there he goes is that a okay
that's not a scandy he it makes you
think it's an error right whenever we
see that we go what's going on is the
relay not coming through but no john
bartholomew was holding his breath there
for a second
which bond did he push
well the day we see a scandinavian sorry
go ahead no no that would be fascinating
i wouldn't put a pass report but i i'm
still looking at the bottom left-hand
side of the screen because
when yon napomshi beat richard report a
couple rounds ago that was in a pet drop
a long theoretical line when hikaru
nakamura played against yon napomnishi
that was another kind of long
theoretical line in the pacific where
jan played quickly and made a huge
mistake yeah he got away with it but he
was clearly a ton worse in that game so
fabiano may be saying you know jan feels
comfortable he's going to win in this
patch off maybe he shouldn't feel so
comfortable because as we keep talking
about
there may be no bigger expert in the
petrol from both colors than popular
caruana yeah
i'm i'm with you on all the things you
said sorry lack of response coming
quickly because i was i was really
listening to you and that's not saying
i'm not always listening to but i was
really thinking about it and i
i uh
well we're going to find out we're going
to find out what line this goes down
yeah and i want to make a point that's
probably primitive uh but nonetheless
jan at his core is a sicilian player he
grew up a night or player he was
basically a sicilian player for the vast
majority of his chess career so i still
think that in the eyes of some players
they're challenging him not only because
they're e4 players but also because they
still feel that jan
isn't really at his core a petshop
player now i'm not suggesting that he
doesn't know the theory that he doesn't
deeply understand the ideas but i think
there's something to be said about
players choosing openings
based on this idea that somebody might
not be quite as comfortable with one
opening as with another and jan he just
spent a little bit time and played queen
e7 i'm just trying to get a read of the
situation we don't often see yon
napomshi down on the clock it is only
moved ten they both spent approximately
two minutes but we know how quickly jan
plays so the fact that he kind of
looked at fabi looked at the board
played queen to d7 and as don you're
saying is this the type of position that
yon napan rishi can thrive in well it
has to be yes because otherwise he would
have played against magnus carlsen and
other people it's so it's possible and
he has proven that he can do well but
look at how quickly fabiano's playing
yeah i mean if we look at the current
game position
there's a lot for young to figure out
this is
already i think a very very fascinating
situation to look at
yeah knight h4 is on the board which
threatens to win the bishop here by the
way what what i was about to look at
real quick bringing us here i just
wanted to clarify where this game was
different than
the report
because when the queen comes to b3
there's obviously those ideas of taking
b7 i know it wasn't the exact line but i
guess for my own peaking my own chess
player curiosity i just the analysis
board right now just going through the
opening quickly of what happened in
yonda pomneshi's game the last time he
was playing black he played a petrov
here in this very line against richard
report and i just wanted to make sure we
note where the theory is different it
was right here with the okay so queen b3
played
rookie one was played by carl okay so
queen b3 was played by report
in a game that obviously should have
maybe been a force draw report
ultimately took a dubious approach and
lost favi plays differently than rapport
with rookie one which i think is worthy
of us noting right so fabiano
the petrov expert that he is does not go
for what richard did which means that
going back to that game
we see that rook to e1 was played
instead
then the queen comes to b3 so we will
not get that crazy rook crazy queen trap
sacrifice line
and now on knight h4 yawn is on the
clock and i guess if we go back to our
basics bishop f5 was planted bishop g4
because you need to protect this knight
on e4 white was threatening to win a
pawn here so black protects it and so
the queen now takes advantage of the
fact that the bishop has developed and
that leaves the b7 pawn under attack you
see us in many different types of
positions in slav positions and all
sorts of others where the bishop
develops but it leaves a pawn behind so
queen d7 and then knight h4 by fabiano
and it's clear that jan napomneshi
was not expecting this this feels like
it might be a novelty we'll get
verification on that but knight h-word
just simply attacking the bishop and is
taking yon out of his book
we're getting confirmation in real time
that it might as well be a novelty very
few games in the database so uh and also
with the note that karwana the last time
he played this position played knight to
c3 and after knight takes c3 bishop f5
queen f5
this was a game from the warsaw uh grand
chess tour
event and so this was against a non so
fabiano playing a novelty on the board
as early as move 11 against yonder
palmishi
and uh he's already going into a bit of
a think here danya yeah i think the big
question there's two big questions first
of all is jan going to drop his bishop
back to e6 which is sort of the standard
reaction now you might say well wait a
second isn't that blunder blunder upon
the important thing is that black often
sacrifices a pawn on e4
and it's only good if white's pieces are
discombobulated here they are very
discombobulated so i don't think my
intuition tells me that fabi is not
going to take twice on e4 in the event
of bishop b6 robert am i making sense
here is that a reasonable assumption
yeah bishop e6
bishop takes takes rook takes e4 it just
feels wrong to put your pieces yeah b5
is even a move here that's always nasty
you don't play this line to go into this
position not at all but then the
question is why did you play knight
bishop e6 what is he going to do so i
think you know with the bishop going
back to e6 the knight on h4 you think oh
let's bring the knight back into play
but you're not gonna go knight f3 just
yet you're nice not under attack it's
okay there for the time being he may
play knight move like knight c3 just to
challenge that 94 with a knight rather
than a bishop and then the big question
always is can black ever get away with
f5 or must black
trade knights on c3 so there are two
move cans one was knight c3 the other is
actually queen to c2 because queen to c2
instead of knight to c3 it preemptively
gets out of any pins on the you know e6
to b3 diagonal there and you're
attacking this 94 for real i don't think
that black in many positions can lead
the knight there that long without
protecting it so the move f5 is the big
question mark and this reminds us of the
game between yon chistop duda and hikaru
nakamura where you have pawns on d5 and
f5 that square between the e5 square is
one that white would love to sink a
knight into i love that you know it's
funny the more we see what's happening
right fabiano has chosen to surprise his
opponent in an opening that fabiano
feels
pretty empowered to do so right he's
like i know this stuff dania made the
excellent point that if yonda palmer she
truly is a more dynamic sicilian player
at his heart the earlier you get someone
like that uncomfortable in a position
that you know better 9h4 objectively may
not be anything special at all and we
saw bobby's willingness to play risky
moves against janupamnishi when he was
black with this knight chief iv move he
came up with in their italian right
italian or any type of learner i don't
remember uh
and it looked like an italian but now
i'm
well very similar
it's been a long couple weeks here in
madrid uh but anyway i'm i'm looking at
this thinking like this this could be
the early signs of something that puts
yon under pressure
i mean he's already taking time we know
that's not something that nepo does just
you know casually for kicks and giggles
yeah and i i would just point out that
we talked a little bit about this
yesterday there's been i think a subtle
shift in the last few years where
players now they don't always choose new
opening moves because they think it
gives them a big objective advantage
they really are often playing moves like
knight h4
because they feel that they know the
ensuing positions better it's not that
there isn't an equalizing approach
it's just that that equalizing approach
might be really really hard to find
makes sense by the and nepo has
definitely never faced knight h4 the
last time he faced this position by the
way he was against magnus carlsen
himself uh not during the world
championship but last year magnus had
this position and chose to play the move
that as we said fabiano did against
vishy and non knight to c3 so he this is
quite likely very original territory and
given the way john's reacting he might
be seeing this position for the first
time i was about to say i'm taking this
a step further you said he's never
played against before i don't know if
he's ever seen it just because
he looks super uncomfortable and i was
just mentioning earlier that yonder
palmici always has more time than his
opponent it's a given right now he
doesn't he is caught by surprise and not
just because oh he didn't expect
probably not to play in this game like
hikara nakamura was talking about it's
like oh i didn't think fagan would play
the open spanish but not that he doesn't
know it right right this is catching
somebody by surprise and in a position
that it seems that he's like completely
unsure what to do
so that's a big problem because this
bishop 105 is under attack i think his
instinct and pretty much every strong
chessboard instinct is to move the
bishop rather than let it be captured
and bishop e6 is the logical square to
move that piece up taking on c4 you can
always think about including d take c4
but it's not really what black wants
here because if you take that pawn on c4
you lose your control of the e4 knight
and now with the bishop 195 under threat
it just feels like you're about to be
pushed back and that might even be a
potentially losing move so i think that
bishop e6 just to keep the stability of
the knight for now but there's the
questions come afterwards right we're
just talking about queen c2 and honestly
as i think about it if black is going to
play f5 that carries a ton of positional
risk well i was just going to say let's
let's expand upon that point and then we
will back up and check on the other
games everybody but i want to expand on
that point because dania
robert literally took the words out of
my mouth i was going to say when you
face a surprise it's one thing right
sometimes you face a surprise but the
position
doesn't have any huge you know strategic
questions but when you face a surprise
and you're immediately faced with a
structural decision like f5 and the
consequences of making such a move where
the pawn will never go backward we
immediately are in a very committal
structure what does that do to your
emotional and mental state when your
opponent is forcing you to make a
decision in a position that you don't
have as much experience as they do yeah
and you weren't necessarily expecting to
make a decision of this level of
commitment positional commitment um and
and what would exacerbate it even
further is if there are lines within
this general variation where you're not
supposed to play a fight right that is
very likely that such a line exists and
so what nepa might be thinking is well
wait a second in this other line that
i'm remembering i'm not supposed to and
he doesn't really remember anything
because he's one who doesn't remember
but assuming you remember something you
might say wait a minute in this other
line i'm not supposed to play f5 is this
an exception to the rule and that might
be adding to his level of discomfort
because i know some people might be
wondering why hasn't he played the
supernatural bishop e6 yet well you're
facing a move you've never seen before
that might require you to play an idea
which is bad in other positions it's not
something that you do fast but
on that note he plays bishop e6 yeah and
he took a good 10 minutes on that move
i'm curious to see how quickly fabiano
responds yeah that this is going to be
super revealing because obviously fabi
wants to show that he came to the board
bobby feeling fresh looking fresh in
that new blue shirt
um
we actually want to bring our attention
to something because given the the level
of energy yon just put there and making
us wonder
will this be the first time we see yon
at the board for more than just a couple
hours uh
let's let's
let's bring everyone's attention to a
stat that uh the team worked hard to
bring
to the show today which is that if you
look at the total number of moves
played by all of the players in this
tournament yonda pomnishi is
significantly leading the way meaning
not only is he leading the tournament
with a score of six points he's played
the least amount of moves to get there
and that why that seems like okay that's
an odd stat to bring to the table robert
talk about how actually significant you
think that is as far as the potential
energy level that yon still has maybe
over the rest of the field first of all
that should be shocking to most because
when you win games we saw how hikaru
nakamura beat fabian of karwana that was
a six hour battle we saw how five in a
car want to beat timor rajav that was a
six hour battle so over the last two
rounds yonda ponchi has only played four
total hours of chess while five in a car
one has tripled that 12 hours and they
haven't had a rest day since after round
six so in round seven and eight the last
two games over the last two days fabiano
has been at the board that doesn't
include preparation it doesn't include
the stress of thinking about chess he
said 12 hours the board to four hours
for yon it's it's significant and the
moves itself danya is one thing by the
way look at rajab up at 456 leading the
way with total moves but
how much will that weigh on fabiano you
think especially if he doesn't get the w
here that he's just at some point the
exhaustion catching up with you
yeah there's no question about it i
think that played a huge role in jan
jan's decision yesterday to make that
quick draw yeah i mean we like to
analyze stuff and delve deeply into
decisions but sometimes the reason that
somebody does something like that is as
simple as you woke up you had a headache
and you were exhausted right right these
flares are human they're susceptible to
the same instincts and random
you know human feelings that we all are
and the likelihood that you do feel
exhausted in the morning and that you do
feel like you're not in the mood to play
a game increases
when you play more chess moves that's
just a simple fact so it's hard to say
how fabulous feeling right now well he's
feeling
probably good about his prep at the very
least noticed that he answered robert's
question almost like he heard his friend
upstairs here in the palacio de centonia
he said i'm going to play queensy 2 very
quickly actually robert uh yawn back on
the clock even though he is not back at
the board uh both players absent
while the big chairs look upon shout out
to the big chairs all right we back up
for the first time today and we'll
revert our attention to
well any of the other four games in
progress robert i'm going to let you
choose our flavor well i was looking at
yonder palm she's clock he's down about
11 minutes i'd love to take care
nakamura's clock he's down even more
time so rajab has caught hikaru by
surprise
and hikaru was up a ton of time
yesterday against fabiano caruana he was
in his element today this doesn't appear
to be the case
sure
yeah and obviously i
gave you a chance to pick your flavor
you obviously made the right choice
because that's definitely the game that
we should go to not just because
of what you highlighted that hikaru
might indeed be caught off surprise but
because
heading into round nine everybody
remember hikaru is in third place clear
third place right now and would love to
find a way to get a victory even even if
it comes with black versus for java yeah
and if we go back a little bit to move
six this is sort of the first important
moment as far as i know when the
antibiotic first became popular and when
i say anti berlin what i mean is move
forward d3 white doesn't allow black to
capture the pawn on e4
when this first started being contested
in top level games i feel like most
people played it with d6
then hikaru came along and started
pushing the pawn to d5 very early
technically this is upon sacrifice
nobody really takes it or in some
positions it's upon sacrifice bishop
takes e6 and knight takes c5 here black
can take with the queen actually on d5
uh which is also a popular line
but what he call really pioneered was
move eight a5 i mean that's a move
imagine showing this to someone like
copa blanca or steinitz i mean not only
do you not go a6 and chase the bishop
you move that pawn to a5 weakening the
the b5 square and robert you can help me
out with this a little bit there are
many ideas uh intrinsic to this move
you're preventing b4 uh you're expanding
on the queen side and that can be really
really helpful in some situations after
bishop takes c6b takes c6 the fact that
the a6 square is now defended by the
rook uh essentially renders bishop a6
unstoppable so it's one of those typical
modern chess moves icaru has played it
religiously in both blitz games and
classical games so
he knew he knew for a fact that rajaba
would prepare for this but he really
really believes in his knowledge of this
line and yet it seems like timor might
have found something new yeah i wonder
what the move was what do you think it
was robert let's move a4 obviously
that's where he started thinking and
that's where hikaru spent quite a lot of
time on a4 so if we go back before the
move a4
before
not possible thanks to that a5 move by
icaru and then we try to think what else
was there available to white right so a4
is obviously not a forced move but what
else in this position has been played
before and then you see that a4 this
position in general is quite rare so i
think the queen on c2 maybe that was the
move that um
probably first caught him off guard
because often in these positions the
queen can go to e2 as well but yeah now
we're just in rarish territory like you
said where hikaru he has some experience
but there aren't too many total games
it's interesting because though unlike
the
rare ish territory to steal your term
between caruana and naponnashi
this is almost almost feels like one
that while the move order itself may be
unique or new the structure hasn't
changed significantly enough to assume
that that either player really feeling
uncomfortable right i mean you already
highlighted that when you play a5 you
weaken b5 a4 is a move that
strategically just kind of doubles down
on that idea so of course you know
for for heavyweight boxers of this level
the footwork really matters i'm not
saying it's not important that the
movers change but more than likely
hikaru and tamora are looking at
positions that they've kind of seen
before yeah i mean from a purely
conceptual standpoint it may appear that
white is positionally better because
white's c3 pawn
controls important square on d4 and if
the black knight reappears on c6 then
the pawn restricts the knight black on
the other hand doesn't have the same
amount of control over the d5 square
the logistical issue for white is that
it's actually just hard to get a knight
to d5 and black can defend that square
in other ways black can go rook f8 to d8
black can develop his light squad bishop
to e6 so black's got the resources to
defend the key central squares
and i'm a little bit worried about a
repetition of moves here because
the only move played here is knight a7
back to c6 and timur might not have
anything better than going back to b5
but let's not mention that
that would be
the second most exciting draw in chess
behind the berlin draw
so
i will say though that
dinosaur is a good one you know the c3
pawn that will always limit the scope of
knight and c6 upon three squares away
from knight takes control of it and the
knight on d2 is coming at the c4 so
that's going to be an aggressive knight
while the knight on c6 is relegated to
defense so i do think that white should
be slightly better without tremendous
risk so if rajab who's played the most
game excuse most moves they've all
played the same amount of games these
are the most moves in this tournament
that if he's willing to put in more
effort he may just put his knight on c4
keep the game going right because his
position is very solid that said
if we see knight c6 he has that option
to just bring the bishop back but hikaru
may make a different move himself yeah
well the car was thinking about perhaps
a different move to play the knight to
c6 well you could say objectively a draw
with black never really a bad result at
this level i don't think a car who came
to the table today wanting an early
repetition for a draw either so uh
yeah i think i was
i think he was reaching for a pawn not
the knight i think that this is cicara's
pawn fingers just so you know let me let
me educate you a little bit on his car
reform mr
this slight angle here
is is a piece this like straight down
straight down can we get it i don't
think it's danny you're actually like
he's gonna play knight c6 and then
you're gonna be put you know he was he
was especially b6 this was it he was
about to shove the beep on you want to
bet
what was that knight he said but i said
i believe i watched bad yes
yeah i do want him
okay turns out i'm not as much of a
world-leading expert on the kara
nakamura body language as i once thought
um
even the greatest make mistakes you're
forgiven i i i thought
it was gonna be b6 but no hickory piece
i guess he's asking for job off like hey
do you want to let me get some rest
bank uh
bank a little bit of time before i hit
the rest day i don't know i mean
i'll be surprised if you want to
remember
i would be surprised and you know java
hasn't repeated the position yet
hikaru's move is very logical knight to
c6 the bishop going back to e2 also is
actually a useful thing for white
because if you put your knight on c4 if
you just think about this right yeah the
knight let's say we put the knight in c4
oh yeah
roger played to b3 he's gonna bring his
other knight to c4 uh-huh i think
okay so
raj is saying look i didn't come to
repeat moves and hikaro
probably secretly okay with that too
despite the fact that he sort of led on
the invitation of the repetition with
his last two moves i think he might soon
want that early draw yeah it's not that
his position is bad objectively speaking
but where are you going to put your
bishop a7 is one square but if you go
bishop a7 now i can go bishop back to b5
you don't have knight to a7 your a5 pawn
is kind of hanging in many different
variations and the bishop on c1 no
longer is hemmed in there the knight
moved out of its way so the bishop can
go out to a square like g5 this actually
already looks very tricky and i would be
concerned about that but if you go
bishop d or b6
my knight f
comes to d2 and then it goes up to c4
and i can secure the bishop pair at an
early stage in the game and not really
going out of my way to do so i'm playing
very natural moves so
i think if hikar was given the choice
between just ending the game as a draw
without any effort and now having to
play a slightly worse position i think
he takes that early draw
yeah and i mean
if after bishop b6 knight fd2
black plays bishop b6 and says no
problem let me eliminate any knight that
comes to c4 well
giving away the light skirt bishop here
is not something black should do lightly
the light squares are really weak that
bishop on c4 is a monster
no question that white is significantly
better in a position like this so
already hika higara has to deal with
very concrete threats and concrete ideas
and it still seems like timur
is well within his preparation
okay yeah well hicaro may have forgotten
his preparation but he didn't forget his
coffee we saw him taking a sip there or
at least chris didn't forget his coffee
so that's always important um all right
we have a couple other games we need to
check in on so let's back this thing out
here
in the uh the chess.com studio the
remote studio we set up in the third
level of the palacio de santonia the
players are downstairs in the main hall
and uh so many fans around the world
watching thanks for tuning in this is
round nine it has just begun for the
2022 fe-day candidates and uh
if your first time this is your first
time viewing hit the follow button
so you are alerted for the rest of this
week when this historic event decides
who's ultimately going to play for the
world champs championship title versus
magnus carlson so all right
let's go over to yeah i was just going
to say before i know we're going to go
to a different game but look at the
bottom left of our screen look at the
amount of time that yana pomshi
continues to spend yup and look at how
little time fabiano caruana is spending
yon brought his knight out to a6 which
threatened a little knight hop to b4 yep
i'm just playing a3 said no no square
for you
the truth is there's
bobby's pulling a hikaru here right he's
used enough time to physically move the
pieces and that's it right
especially given that he's hardly been
at the board so it takes like what five
seconds to come back five seconds to sit
down you make your move so like he's uh
he's clearly pulling on something from
home we'll see uh
what that spells for the middle game
that they're about to get in that petrov
opening
but i want to head over to foruja report
because that game is also
looking looking weird funny unique
whatever you want to call it it's uh
so it's a bit of a funny looking
position at least as far as first meets
the eye and i doubt it's theory
notice again report took time before
playing his first move um and then he
said yesterday guys that he didn't bring
any prep to the table today he took time
before playing his first move and maybe
he did the same thing where he just
didn't bring any prep to the table and
he's just winging it as they say if it
ain't broke don't fix it if it worked
yesterday
you know do the same thing again and he
did playing a berlin now
the key difference between the hikaru
game in this game is that in the hikaru
game two more played the move c3 and
that move is aimed against knight c6 to
d4 which forces
the trait of knights and it really sort
of clears the king's side and if white
is not careful
uh the king could get caught in the
crossfire so i'm not exactly sure what
the main conceptual differences are
between the line with knight d4 and the
line without knight before robert maybe
you could help me out a little bit what
i do know is that as of late c3 has
overtaken castles in popularity but this
line is still of course totally viable
yeah because as this moves c3 we just
stop right here white is already after
bishop b6 even white is already castled
has a very solid center um has you know
ideas maybe in the future to play for f2
to f4 if you can get away with it but of
course the bishop's sitting there on b6
it's pinning the pawn but black also
isn't particularly unhappy typically the
side with less space wants trades to
happen and in most of the spanish
positions and this was an anti berlin
black has a little bit less space
because white moves first so trading off
a set of knights can
be very useful for the rest of black's
pieces
we had a similar
type of game when hikaru nakamura was
white versus the opponent he's playing
today came over java but wasn't the
exact line but we're going to pull it up
in a second here but c6 now we're
definitely in different territory
uh that game had an early d4 on the
board but this this knight d4 maneuver
right in in different versions of a
spanish where black puts the knight on
d4 is something we see
and
despite the loss of time as robert so
eloquently put as i struggle to get that
word out of my mouth uh with less
space you want less pieces and so this
is kind of easy for black to play with
that knight on c6 gone you get this plan
that we're seeing c6 and d6
so
solid for the center you open up the
bishop
and it is for ruja who's on the clock
now
about how he wants to approach this
middle game i'm gonna i'm gonna pull up
that
ikaru game versus uh rajab
from round two just because i wanna on
the analysis board we're now seeing the
position where hikaru nakamura was white
against teamwork
and indeed it was this was the
difference so it was knight bd2 rather
than castles as the improvement and or
not improvement just a different line
but we saw the same type of idea and
that was what i wanted to note however
this move order allowed an early d4 with
this knight supporting the e4 pawn right
so that's one difference between what
hikaru did versus the type of position
we now see for ruja playing as white
versus richard report so
apologies if people don't like recalling
back to the games i'm just i'm in a
studious mood today guys i don't know
what it is i keep seeing these games and
the chess player and me wants to go
i saw this position earlier this week
and what is the difference in backing up
we see a move order difference johnny
let me ask like obviously this is this
is a much sharper approach and it led to
an advantage for nakamura versus for
java compare this position to the one we
now see for ruja playing as white your
thoughts on how how aggressive white is
going to be for d4 in this line versus
what hikaru did yeah i mean i'll start
by saying there is no better way to gain
a
deeper conceptual understanding of
certain positions particularly ones that
uh feature openings you don't play yeah
then to then to compare games and to ask
yourself okay how does one move impact
the position over another movie so coach
daniel approves of what i'm doing oh
absolutely great yes yes you're safe
so
let's test the move d4 in this move
order so after c3 bishop b6 okay i think
this is the position where
with the knight on d2 hikaru played d4
so what happens if white plays d4 right
now i think the chief difference as you
indicated is that the e4 pawn is
undefended but that doesn't mean black
should play e takes d4 he still he
definitely shouldn't do that here
because of e5 what black can do is
simply castle and with the knight on d2
that would blunder upon to d take c5 as
it stands black plays knight takes c4
you might say well isn't that knight
can't that knight be targeted by like
queen d5 or something
uh not really if queen d5 happens black
can play knight takes f2 and the
possibility of c7 c6 is going to lead to
massive material losses so the main
difference is that knight d2
preemptively defends the e4 pawn and
prevents black from further developing
this is a more positional approach and
in this approach white's knight actually
comes out to a3 rather than d2
robert anything to add to that mike drop
mike job we now really understand the
difference between
this anti-berlin spanish that ferrugia
has versus the anti-berlin spanish that
nakamura had against for java so it's a
positional one right robert we see the
knight maybe taking a different path to
c4 maybe you slow jammed this one right
jamie fox style slow jams rather than
being aggressive here we actually slowly
prepare to keep our solid structure and
play for a move like f4 exactly so the
knight on d2
is
kind of ironically because we usually
like our pieces in the center it's less
flexible because when you're not in d2
you're not playing d4 you actually lose
your defense of the d4 square so knight
a3 clearly that knight wants to go to c4
but one of the things we should note is
that if that bishop is no longer on b6
black is going to try to play pawn to b5
which would fork the minor pieces so at
some point as is typical in many royal
lopez spanish positions the bishop on a4
has to retreat either to b3 or to c2 so
it's going to take some time before
white is able to strike but knight c4 in
a bishop retreat that's part of
perugia's plans but one question i'm
having and it's one that we keep getting
back to
is this the type of position that faruja
wants we could have said yesterday the
type of position that he got against for
jabba maybe you know is not that
aggressive not that tactical but he
played a great game from the white side
in fact he was pushing an edge until
near the very end he almost pushed it
off the edge he will against for java
but yeah
yeah so i don't have an answer to the
question i mean is this the type of
position perugia wants
i don't know what faruga wants anymore
right not to say uh you know any of us
really understand what went into his
preparation coming into madrid or his
thoughts on some different openings it's
been a topic of conversation partly
because the star has so many eyes on him
and he and it hasn't gone his way partly
because the type of openings he played
undeniably so weren't his weren't his
favorite positions right we saw them go
wrong got got blown off the board quite
literally on the black side of that
sharp knight or versus napalm machine
and then never quite had a feel for the
catalan so anyway remains to be seen
whether ferugia is going to be
comfortable in this game or whether he's
going to go into the think tank as we've
seen him do but we have one more game to
check in and i'm the reason i'm pushing
up so long is because
i want to get back to car juan and nepal
boys i want to get back there in a hurry
but i want to make sure we do what's
right and check in on all four games so
let's go see what the number one player
from china has on the board versus the
top player from poland riveting position
riveting position sarcasm
oh yeah sarcasm sometimes when you say
that that's what all mirror does
we see a 24 minute lead on the clock for
dingle wren control of the open d file
black has the c file which is not as
impressive because they're knight on c3
but otherwise we have even material and
dingle red went back to the english he
did that against alareza ferrugia so
he's using that as his
opening of choice but it doesn't seem to
be all that much right now we'll quickly
back up and run through the opening as
dingley wren returns to his short chair
there it was a stair off on the by the
chairs there for a minute uh we had an
english catalan neo type of weird system
it's actually literally called a
neocatalan because you've delayed the
advance of the d-pawn but otherwise the
ideas are very similar for white
everyone and that you played c4 to try
to open up the long diagonal for that
beast of a bishop on g2
stop me when you see something you want
to talk about dania or hess otherwise
i'm rolling through
we get d4 we get this
the stare down that will occur
hmm so he took on c5 first and then
played bishop f4 i wonder what would
have happened if he had switched the
move order and played bishop f4 first
i don't know the answer to that i'm just
exploring
bishop d6 and maybe if you delay dc if
you play bishop takes d6 queen takes d6
and then rook fd1
and then try to
force black to be the one to resolve
the central tension so if black plays c
takes d4 here
then that gives white an extra tempo i
think compared to the game in fact i
think you almost get the exact same
position
with an extra tempo here and if black
castles
uh white could use this extra tempo to
start a sudden attack against the king
the idea of rook takes d7 makes possible
as you're indicating knight g5 bishop
takes g2 doesn't work due to rook takes
d7 and that looks pretty bad for black
wow
so maybe that was a tiny bit more
promising
this is not an extensive analysis by any
means but instead he took on c5
and it looks like his fledgling
initiative kind of evaporated before it
began
yeah it just seems like one of those
positions where move order can be very
consequential if black allows white to
seize the initiative
and we have a position where now the
black king is safe look at daily wren
putting all of his pieces on the d file
so he wants control
of that file as i said before the knight
on c3 blocks the queen and rook for
black on the c file so it just seems
like bl black is going to have a little
bit of hard time proving that the queen
and rook placement are quite as good as
white's triple stack on the d-file
camera went all black there because that
angle wasn't quite as good as this one
so we switched away as every once in a
while a player an arbiter even a
cameraman usually the camera uh men and
women are
are more conscious of this because they
that's their job but every once in a
while
you see someone's uh backside where you
just didn't want to
welcome to uh
to chess cinematography it was farouza
who blocked it there you go uh all right
well i want to just point out that you
you could have gone for your idea here
donya but
the rook c8 is the only change i just
want to show that
the weird looking kind of discovered
mating mating net happening here was
possible oh you know what's interesting
danny so the reason that g5
isn't effective isn't as effective here
is because of knight c5
and if you compare the position with and
without rook a to c8 if the rook is on
a8 in this very position i think that
white can play so knight c5 bishop takes
b7
um or maybe the engine is indicating
knight c to e4 oh and oh okay
clearly illustrates the absence of
rookie c8 as you're saying means the
queen's undefended so black can't take
that knight with the c5 knight that's
actually
super important because then if you take
with this knight you can actually double
down on that idea by taking this knight
because there's another threat here
which is rook d7 in some weird positions
right because the knight is pinned and
there's
i mean you can take and then and then
play it but this is a
i love it when danya brings super high
level insights here because
it seems and you were being very polite
as you always are when potentially
suggesting improvements over super gm's
from china that's one of the things that
people know about you
but i think you might be right i think
that that move order feels like it was a
little more challenging and i
i definitely think there were other
options here for duda he didn't have to
take
right
yeah it's a very accommodating move you
see that the rook is staring at the
queen and you just let it up and then
let the second one come black and try to
castle first and you know allow white to
take on c5 in which case the queen takes
back but the very least you don't have
two rooks staring down the d-file okay
well time will tell if dingley wren is
able to get anything out of the opening
um whether he should have played
daniel's move or not we'll come back and
find out but we've got to head back
to the game of the day no matter what
happens in this game it really will be
viewed as the game of the day because
it's the one
currently for all the marvels coming
into this round again if you missed the
memo yonda pomnishi is the clear
tournament leader now a full point ahead
of the field and the field is
represented by his opponent fabiano
caruana
with the best chance of catching him
should probably win this game we have a
tied
situation atop the standings and look at
the current moment of this game here so
we just left a couple moves back where
queen c2 uh move 12 was the choice
knight a6 first and the point of knight
a6 is that it threatens knight to b4 and
while we've been talking about bishop
takes e4 as an idea if white were to
take on e4 right away and black takes
back you see the evaluation is huge in
black's favor because if you take with
the queen on e4 down goes that c4 pawn
right away if you take with a rook on e4
you're gonna have this problem with the
knight on a6 coming to b4 either first
or bring a rook to e8 and then a knight
to b4 as daniel was indicating earlier
white's pieces are just all over the
place they're you know they're not some
of them are still in their initial
positions yeah right those are not moved
on the queen side on the king side
there's a knight on the rim which is
looking particularly dim so
i was wondering if you're gonna do it
robert's bringing it today everyone he
just made a rhyme and he tried to get
away with it and i caught him i tried to
keep going yeah that's right but you did
not sir okay so a3 stops knight b4 right
black's one plan of putting his knight
on the rim and then f5 comes so white
was about ready to take on e4 and black
says no but look at how this game
continued a trade on d5
then after the pawn takes back which
makes perfect sense the knight comes to
c3 and black doesn't really want to take
on c3 it may look like you do because
then white takes back with his b pawn
and that pawn on c3 now can become a
target but that f5 pawn is actually a
problem right so if you play a move like
rook a to c8 and you're just like okay
i'll go for this pawn white just quickly
continues development bishop to d2 the
rook can go to e2 and the next one e1
you can put a work on the b file as well
if you want to aim towards b7 and the
knight on east a6 the bishop on e6 both
kind of loose pieces awkward squares so
this would actually be a terrible
position for black
yeah and the knight could go to e5 as
well
which is yeah of course the classic idea
with that square being as weak as it is
and so nepo
based on what robert explains he wants
to keep that knight on e4 at all costs
because as long as the knight is on e4
not only does that yield
active play but it patches up
it hides it puts a band-aid over a lot
of the positional issues that face
black's situation and so after rook ac8
an incredibly committal decision by fabi
who continues to play fast f2 f3 get out
of my house e4 night yeah this is this
is
i'm just going to be bold and say this
has to still be prepped right he's still
playing so fast so there's no way
you are not looking at a prepared
fabiano caruana versus a caught off
guard at the very least yonda pawn
machine we haven't seen this type of
position of focus yawn someone who wears
his emotions on his sleeve everyone
right if you've been watching the
candidates from madrid you've seen
you've actually you haven't even seen
that much of jan at the board because
when he's winning he likes to walk
around
he's just a very emotive player he likes
to go make facial expressions behind
players backs that he's observing right
i mean jokes aside that's actually jan
jan is uh
you kind of know how he feels by what
he's doing and i'm not saying jan is
worried necessarily yet but he clearly
knows he has an uphill battle here
against his uh super booked up opponent
and there's something important to point
out about this move f3 the knight on h4
is a bit stranded over there so the
knight doesn't have any safe squares to
go to if it gets attacked it will have
to be defended so knight takes c3 for
black because the knight's undertake
pawn takes c3 and now maybe looking at
the knight h4 let me play bishop to e7
and this looks like a problem for white
because you typically do not want to
make a move like g3 just to defend the
night you can't bring your queen over to
f2 because c3 becomes loose and there
are other problems there so g3 is played
and you're like well let me take that
knight bishop h4 gh4 white's pawn
structure looks like rapport against the
palm street that looks bad but look at
the evaluation of our going up and the
reason why is the control over the board
that e5 square wasn't available just for
the knight now that bishop's gone the
rook can be planted there or as you're
pointing bishop f4 bishop e5 coming your
way so white actually controls most of
the board despite having the ugly
looking isolated pawns on the king side
there's no attack so we don't like
having double pawns because it opens
files against the king here but just
nothing to attack with and on the other
side white has really well positioned
pieces this would be a fascinating
structure to get on the board i couldn't
i can't wait to hear how dania naradiski
breaks down this one if we get it you
could put the bishop on e5 use the g
file this actually one of those really
funny looking down your very modern prep
type of positions right how many
principles are being broken here for
white yeah and and but i would say on a
more general note that this is the
reason why i always like to say that
pawn structure is overrated because pawn
structure is i think the most visually
arresting element of the position when
you look at a position the first thing
that jumps out at you is generally the
pawn structures especially when it's
really really bad or when it looks bad
but just because it's the first thing
you see doesn't mean it's the most
important thing or even an important
thing because in this case it pales in
comparison as robert explained two
blacks terrible minor pieces look at
that knight on a6 zero prospect bishop
on e6 zero prospect and speaking of pawn
structure black might actually be the
one with the worst pawn structure yes
there are less pawn islands but there
are more weak squares and all of those
squares are accessible two white species
in particular the squares along the e
file the dark squares the e5 square and
the g file where eventually white could
get a rook so
this position is terrible for black
despite the pawn structure seemingly
being totally in his favor
i almost asked you to shush your mouth
when you're talking to me about pawn
structure being overrated
and then you realize that he's not me
and then i realized i would respectfully
let you finish pawn structure is very
important
did i say it wasn't important
but okay i think obviously in terms of
the dynamic factors of a position you're
absolutely right right you've got the
bishop hair you've got dark squares and
you've got ways that frankly these
double pawns become double trouble for
black if this pawn advances up the board
h5 and h6 combine the combining the
ideas you already talked about with
pressure on the g file those pawns are
not a uh a weakness but but rather an
asset so okay we don't know whether that
structure will happen but i think it is
a super important point that those types
of ideas have to be being considered by
yon because bishop e7
now that the pawn has gone to f3 that
has to be on his mind right i mean
there's a there's a trap knight over
there and
and oh man i i think at the very least
we know we're gonna get what we paid for
here right this is fabiano's situation
uh that he he has to play for a win we
said it coming in he's bringing prep
young's got a hold with black at the
very least maybe even get lucky if his
opponent overpresses but we're going to
be entertained regardless yeah i'm just
working through variations here because
you can start with bishop e7 as well if
you want to switch the move order um but
then white still yeah well can go g3 but
also as an additional option in some of
these positions yeah because the
knight's hanging so you could even take
f5 right and do something like that i
don't know if i would want to take on f5
it feels like it allows a lot of
liquidation but it definitely is
available to fabiano and that's what jan
is trying to work out because when
you're in your opponent's preparation
you're worried am i going to make a move
that gives like the extra opportunity
that i'm going to regret or should i
just trade knights and figure it out
from there but no matter what his
decision is you can tell that he is
immensely uncomfortable he is spending a
lot of time and
got to tell the arbiter tell the army of
time to go to the bathroom
um
he was just having a lot of tea there so
i get it it's true he's got to go and
but he also has to start going on the
board not in that way but in the point
in the way that he needs to start making
money now you not only get kicked out of
the term you get arrested
okay that
all right right on that cue we're gonna
say that while fabiano clearly brought
great preparation to the board today uh
and he has his opponent feeling under
pressure yesterday perhaps in hindsight
uh the preparation that fabiano brought
uh actually was was right in nakamura's
wheelhouse it's it's again it's a big
discussion uh that we've been talking
about and one of the only other
interviews we haven't gotten to see yet
uh was fabiano's with dina bell and kaya
after the game
what did you think about this uh 21
bishop g5 bishop g5 c4 is still possible
and
yeah knight g3 i didn't think would be
very good yeah he carves at e4 and so c4
i thought in ig5 and i saw like a forced
draw there and i kind of got ambitious
and i played c4 i thought that i would
be better
but yeah it was very difficult to play
after that
and
missed h4 and after that it was very
unpleasant
it quickly went to
i think he could have finished this game
like
two two or three hours ago but
he gave me some hope which was
torture in the end because um i don't
know if i ever had to draw but
um
i guess he missed h3 and after that it's
like
i mean if he doesn't allow h3 it's just
winning i think very easily and after h3
it's like very very close to to being
okay for black
um i don't know maybe it even was okay
was h5 your candidate after h4
yeah i just didn't like queen g5 take
take g6 knight c6 like yahara mentioned
and i didn't see how to play this
position
um
i thought the knight was going getting
to f6 or
capturing all my pawns b4 and d5 is
falling
so i was considering that but i didn't
see how to play it
and i started to get low on time so i i
kind of took a slightly panicky decision
which um
i was hoping at some point some
resources would
would appear but it just kept getting
worse and worse
well again even though uh he caller got
the better of that game it's clear that
they both
they both were going very very deep in
that position it also cleared us that we
should be careful before we get too
excited about what we think was a missed
opportunity as both hikaru and fabi now
for those of you who saw uh each each of
their perspective they both knew that
there was something more than meets the
eye there yeah that's c4 we're talking
to chat you know they're saying you
engine wars out here you see that what
the engine evaluation is for five
seconds you think you know what's up
yeah and what honestly happened and it
happens to a lot of strong players is if
you prepare an opening and this is not
for fabiano nikaru but advice for a lot
of people is that if you play an opening
that you didn't check leave the computer
on overnight for it but you just look at
the first line and press the spacebar
that's what we call it right express the
space bar together warriors right yeah
and then you just see okay this was a
missed opportunity that's a mistake that
can be easily made because their engines
are stronger than ours yeah and they've
left them on for longer so that gives
the engine the time to accrue the depth
necessary to find those holes that the
weaker engines and especially engines
that aren't put on
left on for a long time they won't find
those
ins and outs of the position
speaking of finding uh finding holes can
nepo find any in fabiano's prep today
that's going to be the big question or
will he get in big trouble
donya um there's a big hole on the board
on e5 which is the positional concern
you have if you're black
but
what else is he in such deep thought
about he's now more than 40 minutes
behind or close to it
yes i mean when you look at the engine
bishop e7 might look like a very natural
move and you might just be asking why
isn't he just playing this move but
think about it from another perspective
and that leaves the 994 hanging we
pointed out knight takes f5 desperado
move which essentially wins upon after
bishop b7 g3 okay you have to figure out
whether you're
sacking the knight on e4 and just
leaving it there and trying to go after
white's king that's an incredibly hard
thing to do a move like bishop f6
i mean
yeah exactly
and even with network things for 40
minutes or you know
40 minutes like a crazy idea by the way
black is like coveted did you just come
up with that i mean the point is just
that you have two pawns for the piece
and white's king is really really weak
but white is under no obligation to take
the knight why could also consider the
move bishop e3 here just say hey i am
going to make you move that knight from
before at all costs
and
black can refrain from taking on c3 but
what i'm trying to say is that all of
this is really really complicated and
when you're facing your opponent's prep
and you're down 40 minutes you start
experiencing this incredibly
demoralizing sensation that no matter
what you play you're gonna be caught in
your opponent's prep
you have this feeling of hopelessness
that my opponent has he sees everything
as i like to say sometimes when i'm
tilted um he's factored everything in
and
i don't know what to do
and then nepo's stumped there also could
be this element of remember how
janupamshi beat richard report
report decided to play on to test his
opponent's preparation that line we were
just looking at uh g3 bishop f6
pawn takes e4
and you could throw in bishop d4 check
first um and now just if we pause here
white has a number of options there's
bishop e3 potentially i know that you
can take and play d4 but that looks
really complicated uh but you could also
just move your king let's say king h1
this is where i want to really pause f
takes e4 now freeze
black has two pawns for a piece white's
king doesn't look that unsafe right the
king is in the corner the rook's on an
open f file but it's one of these
positions where again at first i think
it's at zeros and now it's gone up to
point six and we don't have the super
computers that these players do and
that's the concern for yonder pump she's
like uh i'm working through the tactics
at the board and this guy looked at it
with his tip-top engine and it says that
white is probably better or even if
white isn't better let's say black is
better and it's just kind of a risky
decision jan doesn't know that for sure
right and he knows that fabi does in
fact know that for sure right so as
you're saying
donya when you get into this situation
you just start believing your opponent
and you stop believing in yourself but
there are moments where in fact you
should believe your opponent and rich
report can tell you that better than
anybody well and
jan might decide he does believe in
these positions because he just played
bishop e7 which means what you see on
the analysis board to your right
is certainly at least possible uh
because
that was the first week of the variation
fabi comes back and she pauses for a
moment and plays g3 omg and i i can
guarantee you nepo looking at it from a
distance is like ugh uh he's still or
he's still in his presence prep you
missed an opportunity there danny
omg threes or snaps i was i i was
holding back i know later i i already
dropped at home jesus snaps um yesterday
and it was in one of the highlight
videos so when i heard whenever i hear
myself saying my dumb things i get a
little self-conscious and you know
normally i don't support it but omg the
reasons we got the move in there omg
freezer snaps wow that is a pun after my
own heart and i will remember that um
but seriously uh fabi quickly plays it
now he's using his opponent's clock
against him which again i want to
actually draw attention to that for the
young viewers or the tournament
improvers hashtag chess punks out there
all those of you watching this is a
really good example of what it takes to
win at the highest level because even
though fabi clearly in his prep
he's going to work hard on his
opponent's time too often i almost
remember when i had young students and
they first learned i'm allowed to walk
around
it's like suddenly the wheels the gloves
are off it's like i don't have to focus
at all and while i'm in the tournament
room my dad can't even yell at me about
it because you got to be quiet in here
right i mean like the jokes aside this
is like the environment and when you
when you see someone start maturing
where they recognize the advantage of
working hard on their opponent's time so
that when it's your move you can move as
quickly as possible and get them back on
the clock that's
the practical aspects that go into
winning chess at 2800 level start with
situations like this with actions like
that working hard remembering your prep
focusing on your opponent's time yeah
and i mean mikko bavanic who was uh
one of the world champions and an
incredibly
disciplined player he was really one of
the first world champions who really
advocated
wholeheartedly for the importance of
exercising and doing all of these things
that surround chess
to maximize your chances so
babinec advocated for almost never
getting up from the board and he was
pretty extreme like he hated blitz he
was a disciplinarian but what he was
saying is during your turn you're
focusing on concrete calculation during
your opponent's turn you're focusing on
making conceptual more general
observations about the position that's
the kind of division of labor that he
was advocating and i can guarantee you
that fabby isn't just sitting there
twiddling his thumbs and you know
thinking how awesome he is for this deep
preparation he's remembering his files
he's remembering the ideas he's
recalculating variations he's doing a
lot of indispensable work as you said on
his opponent's turn yeah we don't know
how much further his preparation goes so
he might be nearing a point where it's
like now i gotta just calculate on my
own hikara nakamura yesterday against
fabiano they both were in their
preparation for a while but then we saw
them both slow down and so you don't
want to have to slow down right in the
moment as you're saying you want to make
sure that your framework is the right
one you don't want to be caught by
surprise and then freaking out because
your opponent did something that you
really didn't expect at all so yeah uh
jan he needs more tea he does he more
right now he might be like i wish i
could have taken the blue pill not the
red pill i don't want to go down this
rabbit hole with fabiano i uh is there a
way to back this thing up
might be too late he's uh
he's all in now on has f what has
probably prepared
you know he's just as clueless as we are
he's like we're going to figure it out
together
i've never seen yanapomshi in this much
relative time trouble yeah i i we've
been commentating so many years on so
many of his games and the story line has
always been there are moments he just
plays too quickly
why does he have so much time remaining
on his clock when he could have used it
to avoid that careless error and
obviously we've seen him win many games
and in this tournament he's played the
least amount of moves to have the
highest score so he's
he's a baller right yana hamashi just
goes out there and dominates sometimes
but i really have never seen him out
prepared to this extent and just this
far behind on the clock
it's crazy and that's one of the dangers
of playing an opening that's relatively
narrow
like the petrov because white's got a
lot of different options that you have
to be prepared for and within those
options the lines are
relatively forcing so you're essentially
forced to repeat stuff that you've
played before
and you only play such an opening if you
really really believe in your knowledge
of it but there's a downside someone
like mbl he's experienced this before
with the openings that he plays
exclusively like the night or
and the grunfeld so maybe nepo should
call him up and
you know he'll express his sympathies
maybe maybe nepal will have a chance to
do that after the game we're gonna have
a chance to continue to look at all four
games
in progress after our first very quick
break but before we take it to that
first break
i want to remind everybody that uh
chesskid.com our scholastic extension
site continues to provide relief efforts
for ukraine to have an event a special
event coming up with ana music the
ukrainian voice of chess kid is who she
really is go.just.com chess kid ukraine
if you want to be involved in the event
uh you can also check out cheskit's
youtube channel they also have their own
streams make sure you check out and
throw your support into this event we
are going to throw ourselves into a
quick break so that when we come back we
can bring the energy just like that guy
is going to need to do for the first
time in several games he's really got to
bring the energy today we'll see if he's
up to the task yonda pandashi trying to
think about what to do against fabiano
caronas prep
we are going to take this one out one of
the live shots there from a chess club
here in madrid chess continues to thrive
in madrid miss amigos don't go anywhere
our coverage of round nine for the 2022
feda candidates returns in a few
[Music]
it took some good fortune but dingley
wren arrives at the candidates with some
very legitimate reasons to think he can
secure a bid to challenge for the world
title for the
it took some time
a visa issue originally kept ding out of
the last opportunity to qualify but when
a spot opened ding was next man up based
upon his hot streak of late
the timing couldn't be better for ding
an entertaining and unpredictable player
ding enters the candidates rated higher
than any player in the field
the chat went nuts they love their man
dingley run we said this is an engine
move humans don't find it and he found
king one i am absolutely stunned once
again this is such a difficult move
the strongest player in china's history
ding is the only player from that
country to earn a 2800 rating
launched by an undefeated streak across
100 straight classical games ding has
sat amongst the world's top 5 for the
past 5 years
once out of the tournament completely
deng now aims to bring china into a
world chess championship match for the
first time in his native lands history
i figure it's time for me to really
blend in you know dress like a local
i don't
i obviously wear jackets all the time
okay
so
we're ready for the candidates madridian
visits the chess board
on a daily basis i hear kind of
pay tribute
to queen isabella herself this is just
i hear that uh
this is
this is a statue of queen isabella
herself
yeah
we are here at the 2022 candidates
tournament in madrid spain and we have
our man on the inside danny ranch has
been with the players a lot going to the
players meetings and he's here to tell
us about some special requests that a
few of the players made danny what have
they been talking about yeah well
obviously we want to and always ask the
players and get them in the spirit of
the city right the uh the place that
they're playing from so a couple of
actually kind of unique ones that have
been that have been thrown out there and
i'm going to try to represent these as
well as i can defeat a okay but the
first one was
a lot of bonus requests if you play and
win with the spanish on either side make
sense right that makes sense um
there was a uh a suggestion you know
that that anytime you move the queen you
you drop a dab for queen isabella yeah
yeah she's the one that made the queen
power makes sense okay um but then the
players were unanimous on one in
particular which was that every two
hours into every round they'll have now
a required siesta well we'll see if any
of these rules are implemented for the
tournament uh especially if somebody
plays the spanish they got some money
coming their way yeah doesn't seem
likely but uh i don't even want to know
which players made these requests but
i've got a couple ideas in my mind yeah
well you know and uh if and anything
that gets the players to play something
more than the berlin right the most
exciting draw in the world now that we
have some money on the line perhaps we
see some exciting some exciting spanish
games so i'm i'm actually excited about
that one there you go you need some alex
honold on us
yeah
the alex honold of chess folks climbing
without a rope oh wait i can do it
i don't know why i'm doing this but i
feel like a little kid when i get around
big things slowly checking our insurance
chest parkour
oh did you catch that on camera can you
tell he's a dad of a teenager
always move like a night guys i think
i'm gonna go ahead a siesta over there
with the uh seems like the thing to do
with the locals you do you baby girl
yeah yeah okay i'll see you guys in a
couple hours
yeah
it's been a long day dan you deserve it
buddy
you deserve it
go ahead and throw that down and
just
buckle up buddy
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
shout out to our team if you are somehow
still not following our our social
accounts whether it's twitter instagram
tick tock you are missing out because we
have a talented group of people who are
just doing crazy hilarious stuff on a
date i mean honestly you that's not even
the funniest thing we've done or most
creative things we've done for for this
event and uh we might be putting
together like a quick reel of all the
highlights robert but you have a
favorite is it the chairs one or any
other favorites i don't know i just feel
like they're all the gift that keeps on
giving so i i don't need to choose
favorites to have a good time danny dude
my favorite video not that you asked
you sometimes go odd couple on me and
attack me in a way and i go what did i
do
but you know it's not sincere oh of
course i know that i think i think the
car will poke in the the looking for the
pineapple pocono that's the best that
might be the best one that they've done
but go ahead well i i wasn't even gonna
say one from this tournament there was
a video of spenny doing his impressions
yeah yeah that was the funniest thing
i've ever watched like i may have
watched that like 100 times who would
have thought that i would have found an
impression though i know well yours are
pretty good a good caspar up there but
we've got some good games to get back
into ladies and gentlemen thank you for
being with us this is round nine
of the feed eight candidates from madrid
the palacio de santonia
this is where we are the players are
throwing down and for the first time
fabi is
putting his head down so we're going to
go back to that game because it really
is the game of the round it might be the
game that ultimately decides who's going
to win this event for those of you
who don't know yonder palmer she beats
by a point but he is black and right now
seems to be facing some prep but fabi
thinking about this one robert yeah and
jan did not go for that peace sacrifice
for a couple pawns and some pressure
against the white king he trusted
he could have had this but we didn't so
simple yeah you know he was looking at
it but he didn't believe in it or he
believed in fabi's prep which is
completely understandable so he goes
knight to d6 now the issue for black is
both bishops are on the e file
and they're both loose so like a move
like queen to e2 right now
seems to cause black some serious
problems the bishop on e6 and then
behind it the bishop on e7 so if you
bring a piece to defend it you're the
king to f7 that just oh looks wrong even
if it's
maybe it somehow works but i don't know
about that and the other way to defend
it would be knight back from a6 to c7
which is bringing it towards the center
but already i'm trying to figure out
tactics like i mean look at this move
knight takes d5
oh
wow look at you take with this one you
take on e6
and you win a pawn at the end of it
and
if you take with the bishop here you
you win that guy so that's
true you know what's funny is i wonder
if one of the reasons favi is thinking
here guys is because he
what happens sometimes when your
opponent plays the first move that makes
you think and you were deeply prepared
usually that move wasn't on the top of
your radar because you know it wasn't
the best right so that gives you some
confidence but then you want to make
sure you don't let the advantage peter
out right donya so he might be wanting
to go for some lines like that but he
doesn't want to get tricked into some
sort of like yeah i'm up a pawn but it's
an end game that i can't win because he
wants to win and cash in on his prep
right he doesn't want to let yon slip
off the hook here yeah the worst thing
is when you have incredible prep and
then you burn all of it by playing one
inaccurate move yeah but i'll say one
other thing which is that uh
nepo is probably the one who's most
uncomfortable because you're in a
catch-22 situation when you're in your
opponent's prep if you're making a move
and your opponent is responding
instantly you're uncomfortable but at
least you know that you're going down
the main line or one of the main lines
of the prep you make a move and your
opponent starts thinking and then you're
like oh no i caught my opponent off
guard i threw him off his prep finally
but what must that mean that must be my
move is probably a mistake
and in this case i think it is quite
inaccurate compared to bishop f6 i think
queen e2 looks like the principal move
and fabi could be as we speak evaluating
the end game that robert uh so
expertly indicated with queen e2 knight
c7 knight takes d5 essentially leading
by force to a trade of queens where
white cashes in white wins a pawn but
black does activate his knights and the
d4 pawn is in the resulting end game
quite weak so that must be accurately
evaluated but i think it's worth going
for okay
let's go back and analyze it because i'm
with you i think that it's hard to find
a move that
is more concrete i mean if we just break
it down on the most fundamental levels
the e file was blocked we talked about
if that knight moves guys what happens
access to weaknesses the e-file is open
the most principle thing to do is to
slide the queen over target these weak
bishops
taking h4 still really off the agenda
well actually here you can take here
because at the end you went to peace
through the fact that both the knight
and the bishop are hanging so so now
it's really off the agenda so you have
to defend you can't get these pieces out
of the way
knight to c7 seems like the most logical
way to do it and here comes knight d5 so
i'm just i'm just showing how logical it
is that what we're analyzing almost like
i feel like i have to defend myself is
probably a good line that we need to be
aware of and so the question is is this
going to be
an isolated palm that's blockaded or
ultimately become a strength right
something that uh
has some some power to convert on this
one colors oh look at that you want you
want more of that yes yeah what else do
you want
you like that i'm like a baby you like
that i like the blue do you like the
blue i commented i always use the blue
okay
it's so sleek
there you go but
dan got a new trick this obviously looks
good for white the very least right it's
a position where fabi is not risking
anything and can press for a win but
those knights blocking the d file as
we've been highlighting the d4 pawn is
isolated and is blocked it's more of a
liability than too much of an asset is
it you know an extra pawn but it's not
going anywhere so i mean jan is a tough
choice himself though because this is a
tough choice from fabiano from the
perspective of is this going to allow me
to win the game but for yan if we just
go back to the move queen e2 which
you know has a direct threat he could
play king f7 it seems ridiculous but at
least it doesn't cost him a pawn
immediately yeah
it also protects the bishops by the way
i like the green i don't know why
yeah it's the sort of the edgiest
somehow but yeah if you're king of seven
like if white had f4 already thrown in
or if the knight could get from g2 to f4
and one move yeah then we wouldn't even
be having this conversation the thing is
if white plays knight g2 here well what
about e5 that's another square we would
love to land on of course but but we'd
settle for f4 the problem is with this
extra tempo the black has you can play
bishop f6
and if you stubbornly respond to knight
f4 not only is d4 hanging as you're
indicating but even perhaps more
importantly black can put a rook on e8
and protect with everything that he's
got the bishop on e6 create an x-ray
against white's queen and that renders
knight takes d5 impossible as well so as
robert is saying you know as awkward as
this looks
king f7 does hold on and jan should
invest some serious thought into it if
fabby plays queenie too
okay well
what's interesting is that
mr carwana is on the clock so he's
going to try to use the time advantage
that his preparation earned him right he
didn't really have to think about a
single thing until this moment
so we're we're thinking queenie 2 makes
the most sense are there any other moves
in the position that
that's what i'm asking is fabi just you
know
deep down the rabbit hole that is queen
e2 confident that that's where the edge
is or are there other moves we haven't
even considered yet here
um
grandmaster has i guess one other move
with a similar concept is queen a4
you're just trying to take advantage of
the fact that these bishops are
not easy to keep defended so that's
actually really cool just to show that
if you take you probably just lose right
or okay you can oh bishop h4 rookie six
and two-minute yeah yeah we talked about
that line earlier so i guess you have to
king f7 but this looks really bad
because i take on a6
get rid of your knight double your pawns
and point knight on c5 oh man and look
at that bishop on e6 it's not very happy
that is a beast of a pony versus a dud
of a bishop here
there's a funny line here if you play
bishop takes h4 now i think white plays
rook takes c6 and you say gotcha rook
takes c5
or no i guess that's not the line you
can you can play bishop v7 that must be
it right or bishop f6 even
so what should white do after bishop
takes h4 do you simply play gh and go
for
total domination over the dark squares
bishop about four etc this is this is
strategically completely lost
yeah
well okay so
queen a4 that's such a cool move
and the bishop is overloading e6 as well
so even if you defend the bishop on e7
once i trade queens d5 then falls with
more pieces on the board
and that both gotten up again
depot's gotten up queen air force we
just looked at takes and takes is really
really ugly and also knight c7 no longer
fun here because knight c5 hits the
bishop and you've got
this right here
but it can be agonizing sometimes when
there are two incredibly tempting moves
yep and they're kind of similar
conceptually both of them go after the
bishops in one way or another and you're
sitting there thinking i don't want to
ruin my prep i want to find the best
move
but you really have no idea which one
you should choose so
fabby should make a decision efficiently
but you can totally understand
why he's investing all this time
one other option is this move rook c6 to
avoid trading queens but then the rook
is pinned to the queen so if you take
here and you try to capture back white
can actually just trade on d7 and then
win the whole piece at the end of the
line tanks tanks there's all kinds of
crazy crazy stuff that could occur on
something like this
with bishop takes h4
and then you take
but even at the end of a line like this
actually you get the rook to e7 and the
bishop to f4 note how helpful this pawn
on f3 is keeping that knight out of e4
this kind of position actually is one of
those obscure bishop positions that favi
might like kind of like the one he took
on against chamber over jabov so
so all right well there's
apparently as we said apparently there
are a couple of different options here
for fabiano um
which is why he's thinking it's not just
queen e2 not a foregone conclusion that
that's the only way to try to press for
an edge you know i'm here racking my
brain which of those two positions would
i rather play and i'm not sure yeah and
fabiano he's calculating not just to the
the point that we stopped at he's going
much further and that's what these top
players do because at this point he's
already spent 16 plus minutes he sees
that he has two very viable options both
of them
give white an advantage that's not the
question
and sometimes the position with the
bigger
advantage according to the computer
evaluation actually doesn't give you the
best winning chances because you look at
the position you're like you know what i
actually wouldn't mind defending that
from the black side it looks better for
white but not that bad whereas the
position that may not have as big of a
lead according to computers it's like
that looks like a miserable defense and
fabian just had that yesterday where the
computers for the most part were like oh
this is a better for white but not by
that much and he's like no that end game
looked just losing right when the knight
went to c6 after the potential queen
trade with pawn to h5 the engines backed
it up but
humans we have emotions and we're like
nope not doing that thing
all right well while fabi thinks it's
time for us to do a different thing
julie do the thing we're gonna back up
take a bird's-eye view of all four games
in progress and the first thing that i
view is that hikaru nakamura is down
almost an hour on the clock
in this line that you said it's kind of
his pet line in this in this a5
uh
anti-berlin sort of situation but rajaba
clearly has brought something to the
table that is making hikaru
uncomfortable or he wouldn't be using
that much on the clock let's let's go
over there and i think he's
uncomfortable because he's losing a pawn
partially bishop takes c6 is played and
a
five is potentially falling here
and i think one important detail to
mention early you might say wait a
minute i can play bc and after knight
takes a5 i can just recover the pawn of
bishop takes f2 check it's very
important not to just stop there because
if you keep the line going after white
recaptures on f2 i'm not exactly sure
with what let's say rook takes f2 rook
takes a5 white has this outside password
you can play b4 and then a5 and even
with the queens on the board it's quite
clear the black's position i mean it
sucks it's terrible yeah rook has to
move this pawn is going to cement itself
on this this is
this is a past pawn that is very very
strong uh
not red
green that's a great protective pass
pawn and the bishop goes to e3 to c5 all
that good stuff so
i think what java might be saying here
is there more than one streamer in this
competition let's not forget the java
during the pandemic he streamed quite a
lot himself so uh
is this a youtuber's twitch battle
uh we could call that i guess so um
rajab not really an active streamer
anymore oh i didn't know that i don't
follow streamers very closely
anisha is going to tweet something about
this mark my words he's listening to the
commentary
he's going to see a fertile opportunity
to jump into this debate does anish does
a niche post things on social media i
didn't know i guess he doesn't yeah i
don't know why i thought that i had a
dream that he posted on twitter once or
twice but yeah um
hikar took the net f3 first that's a
so uh i mean he's
just going to take back i mean what
we've been talking about g takes f3
and if pawn takes e6 knight takes a5 i
think hikaru is not going to play bishop
takes f2 check because that gives white
a free hand it just seems like way too
easy of a position to play with his b4
a5 stuff yep so i think that what carson
do is he's gonna be like all right i'm
down upon
that's clear but let me drum up some
counter play against the white king now
that you took on f3 with the pawn
right that leaves some squares behind
the h3 square i'd love to get my queen
in there maybe eventually move my knight
and play pawn to f5 just to
open up the f-file and try to put
pressure against white's position i
think that
white is objectively better
but there's a lot of fun to be had from
a car's perspective yeah
can i ask the following question what
about after bishop takes f3 i know this
looks wrong what if bishop takes b7
what exactly is the reputation
ah it's
it's knight g4
on a force forcing a perpetual yeah uh
you're threatening queen h4
mate and so if you take you actually
just go for it anyway
no no better than
taking the knight which ends the game
you know what this looks like right it's
a lot like
uh report napomnishi a little bit of a
uh perpetual check around the king and
that would be a short draw
in this case for hikaru nakamura
you know what's funny you could take all
of black's pieces away after queen g4
and it would still be a draw yeah yeah
except the queen yeah it's an important
mechanism to know right because that
happens in many positions where someone
is attacking and may give up some
material to expose the enemy king and
they're that queen g4 queen f3 yeah
situation is one that's really important
for people to remember is there any
other move for white i mean if you take
the rook i actually wanted to show this
queen h4 okay and after h3 the queen g3
oh look at that that is something you
don't see every day
but if you do you might be seeing it in
puzzle rush or something because that's
that's a pretty fun one bishop takes a a
queen h4
and the game is over because the bishop
is pinning the f2 pawn
h3 the only the only way to deal with me
is is to play h3 and then queen to g3 so
that's why you need the knight you need
the knight to force h3 then you don't
need the knight anymore the bishop
you can't take this guy
can't take this guy
so
where'd it go robert someone woke up on
the right side of the bed today
on the left side eight is weak
left you prefer the left side okay good
to know i didn't see there was a
preference it's just where i ended up
okay
well we all know you move a lot in your
sleep um always waking waking me up you
know when bobby reads us bedtime stories
first of all i'm actually a very steady
sleeper okay i'm just i'm i stay put
but today i guess may i wrestle with the
pillows
we are pretty compatible when we when we
sleep together in the same room
we share we shared a hotel room at the
uh at the sloan sports analytics
conference
many times but you know sometimes you
sleep in the same room as someone and
like they just like their breathing's
different throws you off i've i've slept
well next to you you always fall asleep
first of course
the last time we were watching nicks
versus sons
i fell asleep during my own son's game
and they came back and won this
incredible game danny i've forgotten how
the suns did this year why are we why
are we doing this who won the nba
championship oh i also forgot okay now i
remember all right
it's okay
all right you sound danny chucky over
here bishop takes the bishop takes
that's where he's been played i think
akara would at this point given how well
prepared rajab is in this game clearly
and also up almost an hour on the clock
hicaro would welcome bishop takes b7 big
time and probably be okay with the draw
as black so rajab of likely going for
the line that um
that robert was giving with or johnny
was giving with gf3 and you both were
doesn't matter takes takes shake and
bake over here and uh
so what's what's it called move in this
type of spot then queen e6 to make sure
he doesn't drop another pawn and to aim
towards the king side at the same time
and he's gonna follow up with a natural
set of moves knight h5 maybe f5 at some
point what he really doesn't want to do
is just to restore the material equality
for the sake of doing so right bishop
takes up two we were just talking about
a bunch of times he's not looking for
that because people often think i need
to have the same material then i'm even
but by position hikaru is actually just
getting crushed so he has more chances
to
mix it up here and to give himself a
good opportunity to play not just for
equality but for more by leaving himself
in the hole without the material i just
saw roger close his eyes and
i can't tell if it's because he's tired
which he very well could be after that
incredible
uh battle he had with farouja yesterday
but i i saw a facial expression that
made me think he's considering the draw
it definitely is yeah he for sure is but
i've heard that when you close your eyes
it almost seems that like nothing's
changed at all
um what trouble seems no that's not that
significant yeah thank you danny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
um oh dingley red and duda have
definitely progressed a little bit
not sure they progress enough to pull us
back to that board fabiano still on the
clock after knight d6
so just
really trying to make sure that he gives
himself the best possible winning
chances and i'm sure that should
probably go on to win and if we did
happen to have an interview i'm sure he
would say that was exactly what this was
because i i think that he knows both
queen e2 and queen a4 leave him with an
advantage but he doesn't want an
advantage that's you know symbolic as
they say right but not concrete what do
you think he's choosing both of you we
have to choose what do you think what
move do you think he's gonna play
i think the longer he thinks the more
likely we're going to see queen a4 okay
so now i'm supposed to say we need to
just say whatever grenade park
i know agree and danny wrench don't
usually
you know go together go together but i i
agree with danny reynolds his eyes have
been focused towards the center but that
just could be down the line right it's
not like often times when when he's
looking down the e5 like wait a second
in even a queen a4 can i make it work
but he look at his i mean look where
he's looking well it's like my old my
first coach uh shared that old soviet
trick when you make a threat on the
queen side you very intently focus on a
dutch protocol on the h1 square
it's the equivalent of a no-look pass
yeah right yeah
the only way to juke your opponent in
chess there is no like i'm going to this
square no
there's no there's no juice and then the
full effect when your opponent misses
the tactic you're looking over at the
king side as you played before you ever
have that where like you know you
blundered and you just have to get away
from the board because of the belief
that you could psychically let your
opponent know that you've lettered so
you just removed yourself from the
situation and that was the top of the
conversation when vishwanathan anand
blundered against shakur and mamajara
yeah just uh last month
or earlier this month he just blunted on
the spot losing the game and he resigned
yeah he just and shaq didn't even know
why yeah right mommy's like i didn't
know that he blundered until he resigned
and then i was confused and i realized
it happened so you're right that when
you blunder you should just
head on out of there
get away from the board and uh don't let
your opponent have any clues that you're
that you're upset or even what you're
looking at um
all right
where do what where do we want to go
what do we want to look at now um i
think peru should report i guess
a little bit about let's do it a little
bit of fire a little bit of fight over
there
again a uh
a slow structure compared to the
early d4 type of advance you see in some
of these lines
but
ferruccia going all in for robert's plan
which was to get the king out of the way
so we can advance the f4 idea the more i
look at this more i'm like why did why
did the bishop come to g4
it feels like that bishop is going to
regret its position here soon
right
yeah it definitely feels like a
misplaced piece for multiple reasons
right even if a knight lands an e3 you
don't really want the bishop on g4 so
i'm not sure
yeah that bishop's like me at my middle
school dance like just kind of tossed
around
sort of awkward
i don't know
i don't know why thanks
you're welcome
yeah i put
i put a thought into people's minds no
business pudding but yeah f4 is going to
be really dangerous and i guess the big
question is whether white should start
with a4 ah just to slow down the attack
yeah actually that's probably the
strongest move to play here a4 would
slow down b5 just to show the line
obviously if b5 comes anyway you take
take and i think you can take a5 right
so even with the rook being unprotected
looks like you can
so if a4 officially slows down your
opponent's counter play now you can get
back to whether it's f4
bishop g5 as robert pointed out 93 also
not so easy to deal with you don't want
to give up the bishop pair but if you
move it away does the pony pop into f5
yeah that's what they say about pony
popping
i i would say two things here one white
has gained an advantage in a few moves
that's very surprising to see but two
the players don't know that the eval bar
is right next to the a5 pawn right they
don't know exactly how much better for
for white only they look more carefully
they're super strong players so they
recognize that white has gained a little
something but for alireza it's not like
he's looking at this and saying oh this
is plus one better i think we should
always remind people of that that the
players they have a great sense of the
dynamics of the position but they may
think as we're just talking about in the
fabiano game against john the palm
shield is better for me but does this
give me the best chance to win the game
right so for alareza this move a4 for
white which stops black's pawn in its
tracks that pawn clearly would like to
go either to b5 and the next one to a4
uh is that necessary is it giving black
time to castle and make sure that the
rest of the board is taken care of so
this is a really important question
about how much time does alireza have or
is allowing black to castle quickly and
then deal with f4 is that just enough
for report to
maintain the status quo and not be that
much worse
one thing i do want to point out is that
even though it is aldi reza on the clock
now this is one of the first games we've
seen where he's been up on the clock
as they head to the hour mark in quite a
while right ali reza has been
um
slower than he usually is i guess just
the direct way to put it in this
tournament he's gone into several long
things and it's left people wondering
what was going on in his head but here
not the case he has an edge
on on time
and uh we'll see how he used it if
castles comes you you can still play f4
which is fun thing to point out if this
pawn comes to f4 and that bishop doesn't
do anything there's a threat of f5
and that bishop is going to run out of
squares on h3 and g4 so that's another
reason i when i first came to the board
and looked at bishop g4 i was like
what's going on with what's the goal
here because if f4 comes you just you
got you got to run back to safety
unless you're going to take i mean let's
look at that line right if
if a5 a4
required f4
ef i like that
bishop f4 this just looks this looks
terrible bishop g5 i mean this is why
this looks horrible for report
it really does i mean you can't really
allow it for in this version
yeah but
one question is
if white doesn't play a4
what is the big dot like i guess it also
makes sense to play for from the
perspective of
waiting for black to commit because f4
seems to be even stronger after black's
castled king side
so a4 has no downside i mean it's
prophylactic you're preventing queen
type and
black has no good way to continue
improving maybe moving the bishop away
from g4 i don't know yeah like robert
said go ahead robert raleigh reza
doesn't know that maybe he gets too
excited
i was just gonna say as dynasty move the
bishop from g4 to a4 made bishop e6 you
just scurry back and acknowledge that
bishop g4 was a bad idea to begin with
white can still play f4 but now the
bishop's not in any danger of getting
trapped the bishop is on the right side
of a potential pawn five chain so
there is that
that you know knight d7 for example is
possible here because f5 no longer traps
the bishop you trade in yes white is
better we know that it's going to be the
case but this position is also very
locked up all eight pawns for you know
each side on the board um
it's not that clear how to win the game
from here and that can make people
nervous
okay
all right
i don't think ferruja looks too nervous
right now he should looks looks like
he's
feeling the rhythm they both got
distracted by someone entering the room
a little loudly there
but uh let's back up
see where the other positions stand has
fabian caruana moved yet he has and he
moved queen a4
nice thank you
um
and uh you too sir a couple of danny's
over here outguessing a robert
i'm guessing
you slam dunked it not just in the other
team but on your team
sorry old habits die hard all right
queen a4 played yon napomnishi is back
at the board and we're going to go to
there because this is the line we were
wondering what would we see fabiano
answers the question both queen e2
and queen a4
seem to offer an edge
according to both our
our assessment and calculation along
with that the the evil bar over there on
the left
but
we'll have to speculate there's no way
we're going to go as deep as fabiano
just did right we know uh how uh how
deeply he probably just calculated this
position but let's try to look a little
bit here if we can try to predict what
other moves are there besides what we
looked at yeah we looked at rook c6 and
i have to say it's an extremely awkward
move i was about to say i think go ahead
there's a good chance that jan is not
really seriously considering rook c6
yeah he may ultimately play it he's a
great player but it's just such an
unnatural move for players because
you're sort of walking into a new pin it
doesn't stop bishop takes a6 unless you
play bishop takes h4 as we were
discussing earlier and even the
resulting position where if all goes
according to plan after gh rook a6 queen
trade
the d5 pawn is loose the rook on e1 is
well positioned the rook on a6 is super
awkwardly situated over there it's
actually not that helpful until the
knight moves out the way and the rook
maybe swings to the king side and this
move just seems so good but yeah when
you put the bishop here yes you're not
threatening to take but
there's so many awkward things about
black's position
that this really feels like one that
could get away i mean just look at you
put the king here you put a bishop on e5
eventually the g file becomes an issue
g7 is a problem this is an end game that
into its own pawns
okay dania so if that's not the line not
rook c6 what else do you think john
might be trying i'll tell you in a sec i
think bishop f6 might be the likeliest
but what this situation reminds me of a
little bit is the situation after he
carves h4 completely different position
not position wise but in the sense that
there was an option which led to a
certain position that's extremely hard
for a human to evaluate accurately yeah
i'm talking in yesterday's context the
position after knight c6 both hikaru and
fabi thought that it was overwhelming
for white the engine looks past
uh you know stuff that humans would
consider to be a deal breaker
so i feel like jan might consider that
hanging him a deal breaker and he has to
see bishop takes h4 to me the move
bishop f6 looks natural because after
the queen trade queen d7 you can start
with bishop takes d4 actually
um i don't think anything changes
and after king g2 you play bishop to hd7
and the position after knight takes d5
is
quite hard to evaluate but apparently is
very very bad for black there's a fourth
threat on e7
and the bishop from c1 is coming out to
f4 with tempo
so despite
appearances black's position is actually
really really dangerous that's funny i
love how you said despite appearances
because structurally all things are
equal no nobody's lost material yet but
yeah go ahead robert this is really
really awkward for that d file
yeah i just i need to put a rook on d1
or a bishop on d2 and a rogue on d8
to completely fill it up but it just
looks like a position where uh black
could blunder a piece at any moment that
f5 pawn is one that's gone a little bit
too far for your liking but i agree with
you donya that bishop
danny can you make the bishop on d7
green please go ahead robert
it's christmas
it's christmas time sorry right that's
not what i was looking at
it was only song time uh but in all
seriousness i mean bishop website is a
move that jan has to consider because
you're down zero material here and a lot
of the positions we've talked about
there's a possibility that black goes
down a pawn with activity here black
seems to have activity and is equal in
terms of material but the the pieces are
really awkwardly placed and white is
already 397 as we've been highlighting
and bishop four and all sorts of things
so young has a really difficult choice
when you have the
engine to back you up and it just says
it's not that bad for you
you still might not even feel confident
in your choices because
pretty much every move leaves black at
least slightly worse so just having the
number there doesn't tell the full story
and even if you have the number it
doesn't tell you which direction to go
to
will that be the last time we see yon in
that shirt that he whether he has 10 of
them at home or whether he's just been
doing laundry every day we've seen him
in that shirt
because he's uh he's a superstitious guy
he doesn't want to change anything when
things are going his way we get it and
things have been going his way let's
bring up the standings and remind
everybody of what exactly has been
happening here in madrid if you missed
it yonda pandashi is currently a full
point ahead of the field on plus four
that's pretty bananas uh at this point
given how many rounds are still left
four wins and four draws have gotten him
a full point lead but the only guy who
could catch him in a single round
faces off with the white pieces
right now so
clear your schedule as we said it's a
monday some of you are working around
the world some of you you know are never
really working right working hard or
hardly working hey mac and uh got that
monitor or phone on the background right
listening in right now i'm in your ear
but you can't actually see our paces
that's that there's a let's be honest
there's a few of you out there that
qualify in that you're listening
uh but you're not watching so stick with
us
if this game gets wild and fabio garwana
wins to bring this thing to a dead tie
what a story we are going to have here
in the last few rounds from madrid so
all right um
there we go chat kent penn these three
doing commentary together are awesome i
love the show and camaraderie well well
i love you
giving me positive affection bringing up
my intimacy issues now go away go away
with the positive love throwing a wrench
into the commentary there's the there we
go
i love that nyc
that's like relatable on so many
different levels you can dodge a wrench
you can dodge a ball apparently but you
can't uh
dodge a wrench oh i agree with that one
yeah i know that i agree now someone
said yeah
you don't know what they're paid no your
business can we get that person a
diamond membership
robert hasn't given out yeah that wow
chat keep going yeah let's get more of
that yeah get more comments like that
we're going to get away from featured
chat now and get back to the game and
bishop we have fisher six on the board
let's go to there
let's go to that board bishop six i
think we might get that exact line that
we just talked about danny can you do me
a very quick favor just go back before
bishop six okay what does the eval bar
say point four go to bishop or point
three point four it's gonna settle you
know with a depth but that's going up to
1.3 1.4 so bishop f6 isn't an accuracy
but we were just highlighting how it's
such a natural move you keep material
even and you're you know that five is
out of prep but you're still worried
that he's in the ballpark of his
preparation sacrificing a pawn in any
situation might get out of hand and he
decides to try to keep material even but
we can see how white's pieces are just
free-flowing
yeah i
don't know i mean i think we'll get the
line you calculated so i'll just play
this way it doesn't matter which move
order you do
because i think you get bishop takes d4
and king g2
in either case so
what do you think john obviously sees
this right here c8 i think he he says to
himself okay rook ce8 now bishop f4
looks really really natural and my guess
is that jan found something here that he
is okay with i mean maybe it's just
knight d6 to c8 or there's knight a6 to
c5 which leads to ridiculous
complications robert i wait i take it by
the way you made eye contact that
this is the move the no just doesn't
look so bad for black
everybody yeah
look at this this is that is it there's
so many weak squares and loose pieces
and bad alignment of pieces here
and about but it's funny if you take it
black can take on d3 and actually black
is
right back in it is that's what yawn has
calculated we keep the d file full and
most importantly
hey can we get a couple more pieces on
the d-file here clean up on aisle nine
yeah clean up on aisle nine yes
but i think what white needs to
make use of here is that black has this
knight and d6 hanging so whether
sometimes you can like throw in a check
here on e7 because the king goes to the
corner it might be a knight g6 at the
right moment
right and rook a to d1 but that's also
what i want is i've closed the e file
now let me go rook a to d1
and i protected my bishop
is better than black's pieces every
piece pound for pound is on either a
better square or has
more power it this is
crazy
how how
how deeply fabi has already calculated
bishop f6 before he played queen of four
we're going to find out right now he's
either double checking variations or not
sure where to go i have just one last
thing to add not about the position but
about the clock jana is 58 minutes
uh he's made less than half of the moves
until time control the first time
controls after move 40. now if you gave
this time situation alexander griftrick
you'd be like are you sure i have 58
minutes and not 5 minutes or 8 minutes
why do i have double digit minutes after
18 moves but giving it to someone who is
not used to getting into the time
pressure like jan he's already going to
start getting antsy and that might
further
negatively impact his emotional state
right now he knows he's worse and he's
got a lot less time than he's used to
having so his situation
is very unenviable here from every
perspective
well it's a good it's a good point uh to
bring up now because john might get in
time pressure in this game and it's been
a talking point throughout this entire
event so many of the players have
weighed in on the lack of increment
versus the traditional increment time
control uh yonda panmashi who is going
to be playing uh in time pressure in
this game potentially gave his thoughts
on the subject to our own dina bell and
kaya yesterday
yeah i had quite some practice uh in
dubai
uh with this time control but
frankly speaking in dubai it was
i mean uh i can't say it was like really
unfortunate but i believe the last
tournament i played with with a similar
time control without any increment until
like 61 i would say it was like 2011 or
2012 so i
didn't really feel like i'm used to this
and there are like a few similar
tournaments like for example in norway
they have these two hours
for 14 moves and then just
some small increments so it's basically
you finish your classical game and you
start you know second re you know rapid
game just inside uh inside this one game
or repeat or bleeds but yeah okay then
the time travel comes it's very you know
very new feeling because yeah you
always can let's say
use all your time and then you still
have like 30 seconds to figure out what
to do next and here the time management
comes to you know to to a next level
which is
i mean it's just more or less the same
because basically the time remains the
same yeah the time limit two hours but
i believe here people just not used to
it
you know it's an interesting talking
point we haven't gotten into because
we're talking about the candidates like
this is the first high-level feeding
event where they removed increment we
forgot dubai had the same time control
but robert it really wasn't as much of a
factor there as jan said we just didn't
get the same
we weren't talking about it nearly as
much why why was that because yana
pomshi plays so darn quickly
he's almost never down on time yeah and
so it has been very surprising to see
him caught in popular preparation but
right now the clock is evening up and
that could be difficult for
fabiano that might not be good news for
him because while he still knows he has
a good position
maybe he's losing some of that
confidence that he built up when jan was
deep in the think tank and now he's
trying to figure out all right i should
be better where is that advantage and if
i take the wrong path am i letting it
slip completely
jan saying that other tournaments have
this too he just said he feels confident
in this do you think it's because he's
just inherently such a fast player or he
just you know generally was never really
into the increment thing to begin with
yeah i mean he's also a
extremely habitual and amazingly strong
blitz player yeah i think that
contributes as well because most online
blitz is played without increment three
plus zero and if it is within increment
it's only a two second increment so
you know jan jan is generally fine with
it and if it hurts anybody it probably
hurts his opponents more um more than
him yeah he kind of said that i mean his
interview was like yeah i don't got a
problem with this like you know i don't
know
i'm good with this you know
you know
everything is caspara
well fairly bobby doesn't know what to
do again it feels easy for us
sitting here
on these very comfortable chairs by the
way plenty of these are excellent chairs
i have to compliment excellent chairs
yeah i i complained after our our long
sofa boy session during the world champs
championship with me and bobby and
robert over there it was
it's tough i mean i'm still i'm still
recovering like literally i have
sciatica issues from that event i'm not
kidding don't you hate it when
there's a couch and it looks really
plush and leather and then you sit on it
and it's as hard as like it's like just
i mean we were we were massaging each
other it was like hey i got the massage
gun
what what gift did i get everybody then
in the event tell them you got a massage
i got everybody a massage gun at the end
of the event the fly me fly by the fly
be fly be i i don't necessarily
recommend the bra okay i won't say that
again
i know a lot more about massage guns now
than i used to i'm very into them
they're they're very good for you i have
the thera gun now it's much more
powerful motor can really really crank
it up and dig into these old hips
i'll tell you that much massage guns for
the record
if you're into sponsoring anything with
my company reach out chess.com just.com
all right here we go let's back up and
look at all four boards here the
beautifulchest.com events portal
bringing them to you live what do we got
here well in the top left it looks like
alariza did not play a4 himself and
allowed report to do it okay and then in
the top right we see that hikaru he
brought his queen up to e6 and rojava
declined that possibly to make a quick
draw he says let's fight and now the
onus is back on hikaru nakamura who is
fresh off that victory yesterday yeah
queen to e6 played i i kind of want to
go back to i know we've spent a lot of
time in these two games but to be fair
fabiano caruana and yana
are the
the two players leading the way and only
that guy right now maybe has a chance to
catch him hikara nakamura of course
there's still other rounds left someone
could always catch fire but that's why
we're focused here and roger wants more
fight here donya but what's he going to
do about the queen coming to h3 well i
think the queen
is likely going to come to h3 at some
point now hikaru could start with a move
knight f6 to h5 and that's a
multi-purpose move the knight is
potentially heading for f4 there's a
bishop on c1 that guards that square f7
f5
is another idea to consider but if you
play it too quickly there's queen c4 and
that would force a queen trade now in
response to this i think timur would
play king h1
and one great illustration of how
concrete these top players are i think a
lot of players would get really scared
they'd see queen h3 they'd see the storm
clouds gathered around white's king and
they'd say ah let me take that draw
what timur is saying is hey you don't
have a single infiltration square those
pawns on the king side might look ugly
and this has been a theme today but the
f2 and h2 pawns are combining to defend
g3 bishop defends f4 a lot of the king
side squares are off limits or jabba has
decided that that pass pawn on a4 is
going to make its presence felt while
black's initiative on the king side is
most likely temporary and i think he's
right
okay and i want to show
a tactic that doesn't quite work out
though it's kind of nice queen h3 here
and after knight takes c6 bishop takes
f2 like one of these fun moves you're
removing the guard of the g3 square so
you take with the rook you immediately
lose the game because check can i win
your queen thank you very much but if
you take with the queen i still have
knight g3 check and it's important not
to take the knight on g3 you may think i
get two pieces for the rook but this is
another drawing mechanism that everybody
should learn is that when you can keep
checking like this in the diagonal and
then on the rank you've white is no
choice but to no no no you have another
i think you should repeat a couple more
times
i i was really trying to show everyone
well it's my job to move the pieces
while you guys drop the knowledge lay
off of me i i appreciate it
and after knight g3 check it's important
not just to take the knight because you
can king g1 actually leaves white well
ahead because once you get the rook now
i really get two minor pieces for white
for the rook for black and a couple
pawns so this would just be completely
losing for black
well said
they're well moved if i don't
all right yeah you did a great job there
okay so no that is that is a good line
queen h3
but but dania already highlighted that
if not queen h3 and you try to bring
more pieces into the attack with f5 too
soon well now we get the queens off in a
different way and white is super happy
to not have won another pawn because
with the queen's off you can kiss any
mating chances goodbye and white is just
up a pawn white's winning here yeah so
you you dropped the mic basically after
your line you really i think described
the tension well done that black wants
to get all this stuff but raja is
quote-unquote gambling saying you know
what i'm not afraid of that stuff and i
believe in the end this extra pawn will
be the story of the game and you said
you think he's right
yeah look at hikaru he's been grabbing
his head and part of the reason was he
could play bishop takes f2 check our
bishop takes f2 at many different
moments but we keep highlighting how he
doesn't want this position material
equality does not mean the position is
even white's pawn structure is better
over there on the queen side black as
these double isolated pawns white has a
passer and you know i think
it's very natural play for white right
this that a5 pawn is just there to stay
unless it goes up to a6 and maybe a7
yeah or what a8 right
two queens are better than one yeah no
but seriously this is
this is looking tough for nakamura and
just
what a ride we've had here in madrid
right you had fabiano garwana ironically
for talking about the the three-way
excuse me between these three players
fabiano beats for jabba loses to
nakamura nakamura beats garwana
now
is not losing but is right now looking
at a little bit of trouble against for
jabba this is um
a trifecta of of uh players just beating
the tar out of each other well i mean i
i said this yesterday i feel like some
people really underestimate to what
extent the statement that everybody can
beat everybody else at this tournament
really is true they really can yeah
nobody qualifies for the candidates
unless they are top of the line and
unless they're capable of beating any
individual player on any given basis now
hikaru has never lost the timur
in in all of their
long and illustrious chess careers
playing each other
and he smells blood right now you know
timur isn't someone who goes for dubious
positions he's declined two very clear
opportunities to draw the game i think
he senses that he's quite close to
achieving a decisive advantage here i
don't think it's too much extreme to
talk about that which would be achieving
his first win in classical chess
in all classical chess
not just against
icarus game
since 2019
early 2019.
and hikaru in part may have a little bit
of a target on his back because they
know how popular he is so if they beat
him hey that looks pretty i mean
everyone's mad at the person who beats
akaru yeah that's like they earn respect
so i think the players
right they don't just live in a bubble
they're like beating a car that might be
uh something that we really want it kind
of gives extra motivation roger's like
now i launched my streaming career
yeah as a channel on youtube there
aren't really any other chess streamers
on youtube though i mean there's not
really any chess
anish geary
we're trying to find ways to troll a
niche gear he actually complimented our
our show the other day so he's so you
respond to compliments with bully
behavior
let's bring up our bird's eye
check out the other for three games
still going here we've got we're back to
the candy store
blueberry
apple sour apple i love sour apple candy
i know it's amazing
that's here for sour apple flavored
anything i'm curious what you're coming
where you're going to come up with for
the lower right oh we've got raspberry
on the lower left and i've already said
this one before well it's couple of them
it can either be
just like blackberry or like chocolate
but you could also say it's that weird
flavor when you mix dr pepper and root
beer together and you're a psycho kid at
circle k filling up a thirst buster and
it makes a color that's unnatural for
any amount of chemicals coming together
clean out your car with that stuff i'll
tell you that much
sounds like a man who's done it before
yeah you okay danny i'm doing great i'm
having a great time honestly i hope
everyone else is too because this is
what it's all about the players are
delivering on the board we're having a
blast
and uh and all right we have a lot at
stake in madrid we say it in the
highlight video the uh the hype video
every day this is the most important
tournament in chess the world
championship match
is maybe the most important event right
but as far as a tournament goes which is
more than two people this is it and i
see both of you guys leaning in are you
seeing what i'm seeing i'm seeing what
you're seeing
ollie raise a farouza took on
e5 and he's better
what by the way uh fabi also took on d7
but hasn't taken on d5 yet let's go to
alireza's game because it's going
quickly and
could we see farruga get his first
victory
in madrid it's a little early to say
that but this position has just been odd
for report from the very beginning yeah
it's a problem when you don't have a
strong
opening repertoire you can find yourself
in trouble in every single game
especially against these types of
players and what farrugia is currently
taking advantage of is that that black
king sits on e8 so if we just go back to
before the knight took on e5
ferruccio could have backed his knight
up we talked earlier about knight e3
that still looks very nice for white you
should have an advantage in this
position with the semi-open f-file but
frozen wants more he doesn't want to
give black time to fix the pieces finish
the development of castle he says let me
keep going forward d4 if you take twice
on d4 black is up a pawn in this
position and i thought it was e5 but
really no no e5 is one of the move
cannons for sure but maybe there's
something else there you could start
with h3 you could also keep going for
the attack with bishop d2
what oh you're just gonna stop me from
castling you're also threatening bishop
c3 okay
uh-oh that actually looks
highly problematic for report
bishop d2 is super strong you're
threatening bishop c3 the king will then
never have anywhere to go to safety
whether you stay in the center or try to
get castled it won't matter anymore and
you're also threatening bishop b4 donya
and you're sacking three puns because
queen takes b2 as a second pun now
you're going to play rook c1
and you're sagging a third pawn is your
queen side
well that's not the right question to
ask
the question to ask is where's black's
king gonna go is you can play for
instance h3
chase that bishop off of
g4
and then you can probably trap the queen
you can prevent black from castling
nope yeah but even after this i mean
imagine evaluation playing this position
is playing this looks
atrocious this looks like it's going to
be checkmate of five moves let alone the
fact that black's queen is in trouble
and you can go after it with bishop b1
so this just seems so wild like
black is up three pawns
but look at the king position i don't
really see richard
going for this
no i mean and if he doesn't go for this
what does he go for that's the question
then you go wait oh is the queen she is
she's running out of squares goes to a3
the only thing left oh my god
now she'll be four it should be four
oh you're going to find brook f2 or
something so rook f3 to prepare bishop
c3
oh that's nasty or bishop a3 yeah rook
f3 is nasty because you just want bishop
c3 and the only place the queen go is
back to the third rank and then the
bishop removes itself and that queen's
in trouble
[Music]
so what report needs to do is either
take everything and hope that he's
enough material to offset the fact that
his king is being hunted or after
he just needs to move his queen away
somewhere like
queen h5 i guess just to make h3 less
possible and after d takes c5 just get
the king out of there and castle i think
he's gonna do this
but this looks bad as well just down the
pawn yeah bishop f4 bishop d6 i was
going to say even bishop e3 bishop
looks
spice you know
man this went wrong for the report
i mean this was an anti berlin this is
supposed to be one of the most solid
openings in chess
but we knew it was going to be a you
know one of the awkward move orders it
started with this knight d4 line i mean
again this was
at this point actually no at this point
they had repeated the game between
nakamura or java from earlier in the
tournament hikaru played knight bd2 in
that line perugia castled but we get a
similar idea where you kicked the bishop
back
and rather than hikaru's more aggressive
approach to go for d4 early
ferocious slope plays the maneuvering as
robert highlighted at the time the
structural plan of keeping these two
together is to play for f4 and by the
way we do see the bishop capture on d4 i
i i did want to go back to that three
pawn sack line anyway even if he didn't
because part of me was like smelling uh
whatever smelling a rat there i was like
is that really the case but okay the
computer said white had compensation
anyway ferruccio goes super aggressive
with f4
and that's what got us to this position
where everybody on e5
makes way for a d4 fork
and uh
well black is facing a big forking
problem here bishop g king in the center
was a really big inaccuracy bishop g4 by
report yeah i didn't like it when it was
i'm like what why why would you want
your bishop on g4
you gained this single tempo on the
queen but everything about the bishop
spot there is
is not ideal and you've improved the
queen because when you play f4 you often
want the queen coming to g3 or h4 so
that was a big mistake and look at this
i mean i'm very curious if how long aloe
vera is going to take after queen takes
d4 because black does not have another
move
if you move your queen away
right you're just admitting that your
position is terrible your king's never
going to find safety you're pretty much
lost so he has to take the material and
he took on d4 and now will ali reza find
this bishop d2 to c3 maneuver i think
you will
i mean i think the key is to avoid the
temptation of e5
what was so wrong with e5 i played it so
i'm defending it but the knight gets i
guess the knight comes in and you just
know and black can actually castle in
some of these positions queen side as
crazy as that sounds
i think that's actually kind of key
because i was thinking i was just
visualizing this right you know how i
like to
draw on some long diagonals on a
chessboard i just assumed that that was
what the compensation was but you're
saying that castle's long is actually
quite the possibility here
and that is
this is an amazing position yeah well
this is a report position and a
ferocious position we kind of knew right
we had this one circled last night when
we all went home everybody we're
obviously talking about the big games
carwana and upon rishi but we talked
about this one as like
don't be surprised if that's a decisive
result for one of the players it's you
know what those bishops remind me of on
c2 and c1 when you've castled queenside
it's like i was reading about uh y2k
when the year 2000 happened and there
were widespread predictions that it
would just mess up all the technology
and there were companies that were
founded on the basis of
all of the code getting messed up and
the date the new date messing everything
up and of course nothing happened it's
like those two bishops i've got all the
machinery ready you're going to castle
short i'm going to tear you apart whoop
then i'm castling queenside
you guys are too young to remember the
panic of y2k i remember that
i was like a 15 year old kid but
everyone had you super nervous it was it
was scary
i mean we were you you weren't even born
i was five years i wasn't even poor i
don't know i know how old you are what
do you think of you you could be 15 you
could be 25. i have no idea yeah i mean
he tied your shoes this morning i mean i
tied you like shoes and i i tucked in
your your shirt
comfortable chair
all right um
well
farouza is thinking robert you asked
that question you said i'm going to be
curious to see how long for russia will
take before responding this shows it
might be two things one that he just
went forward intuitively believing that
there was compensation and we're not
saying he's wrong but he hasn't actually
worked it out yet it is his type of
position though right so he's been able
to get a position with that is better
for him but also is full of light full
of tactics not just a position where
you're just maneuvering pieces and
you're trying to find squares but
you have to resist the temptation to
make a move like e5 or move like bishop
g5 to create an immediate threat because
this position isn't about just a one
move
idea it's about trying to get after that
black king and by putting your bishop on
c3 that's going to call cause black a
million different problems and the king
is never going to find true shelter
all right
well we still have a lot of things ahead
here we we don't know what's in store we
do know that karwana
and naposhi is delivering with fabiano
whether he gets the victory that brings
this thing to a tie or not he's
certainly getting the pressure and all
that he could hope for with the prep
that he brought to the table that that
is a position that is looking scary for
the tournament leader we're going to
take a very quick break but before we do
we're uh
whoa wait a second
what happens to this second
white arm share after the candidates
is it shipped back to usa or can i buy
it with discount to give it a second
life and hauling
if you if you want
the chair unniche i'll give it i'll sign
it for you do you want that someone
someone let a niche know he can have the
chair window i actually don't know i
think we probably rented these um shout
out to the team who set up the studio
but i'll buy it for you and we'll ship
it to you if you really as long as you
promise to use it on stream
right that's a fun little bit imagine
the honor of sitting on a chair that has
been sat on by danny wrench come on all
right we'll uh we'll send it to you
niche but um you know it is comfy i'm
not kidding so all right also not
kidding that we have a very exciting
event going on it's the women's speed
chess championship valentina gonina
takes on ellie potts next in the next
round this should be this should be a
fun one both of these players super
exciting aggressive styles that will be
an interesting match on tuesday june
28th 5am pacific time
so uh so go to there watch that match
the wscc is really just starting there's
plenty more great matches ahead you're
going to want to tune into that you're
going to want to keep tuning in here to
our coverage of round nine of the 2022
feeder candidates from madrid will ali
reza faruga get his first victory here
in his candidate's debut
we might find that out today but we'll
definitely find out if he gets it or not
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
you know you can watch top chess events
right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com
[Music]
[Music]
what's the best thing for you in madrid
you have found here
well everything first of all people but
it was since my childhood that i have
discovered that people are great here
and
in general i love spain okay thank you
very much
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
miss amigos
we're back
round nine from the 2022 feed a
candidates continues to roll on here
robert hess daniel naredinsky
helping us bring it to you live and
we're going to dive right back in here
to our bird's eye view where
uh fabiano seems to have real chances
which may mean real opportunities for
yon's lead to disappear
he has to be very careful here
and uh
he's got to be worried he might already
be almost a little too late it's looking
harder and harder to find good moves
that don't blunder something tactically
farousha by the way plays
slightly different than what we were
looking at with bishop d2 but
bishop e3 and queen f2
uh
it's going to be a wild position over
there it already is a wild one but i was
saying during the break that report he's
you know he thrives in the chaos he's an
agent of chaos he's a joker a lot like a
lot like the joker he uh
some men just want to see the world burn
as they say he just wants to see every
chess board burn exactly that's exactly
what he wants literally richard report
wants to bring fire on board like no
other sometimes he might bite off more
than he can chew though potentially
against ferruga
yeah so the interesting thing is during
the break bishop e3 was played
now conceptually the idea is very
similar to bishop d2 he's trying to get
the bishop onto the long diagonal with
tempo so for instance if black castle's
king side
in this position then white's going to
play bishop d4 and i think that might be
whoa
that was a very weird way of moving did
he play but should be six yeah he did he
brought the bishop back
which actually looks
ah so after bishop d4 he wants to play
queen b4 and then i think richard's
point is that if bishop takes f6 happens
that's a lot less scary than it looks
because white runs out of fuel right
i'll have to get that you know for
everybody to be able to see but yes it's
a situation where definitely white is
down two pawns and if you start
getting pieces just to get one pawn back
that wouldn't be ideal for your
attacking chances
bishop
d4 will likely be on the board
queen goes to safety to one of these
squares
i'm not sure which one maybe four
friends leave before seems like the most
logical
a lot logical and you
the thing is you want to keep this
bishop this bishop is
is a beast right the dark squares are a
problem but the concrete way to regain a
little bit of material and to bust
things open is also bishop takes f6 so
but the problem is if we just finish
this variation i know we want to of
course go to our leaders game but after
bishop takes politics queen takes up six
here that you just slide your rook to g8
and with the queen coming back to e7
yeah white doesn't really have
tremendous firepower aimed at the black
king
there was a lot of inertia there was a
potential right for white to get an
attack but if the best you can do is
give up two pawns just to get one back
while trading pieces that's not what you
want you can see that black has an
advantage in this analysis position yep
this isn't bug house where you're like
hey give me a pawn give me knights give
me give me pieces you can't do that here
despite all the holes the optics of the
position are maybe not the concrete
uh reality so um can you imagine if
report gets a second win in a row well
then we'd really be talking about it
being a multiple horse race again
because that would put report at five
points which
is given that he still has head-to-head
shots against both carwana and upon
rishi would not have him out of the mix
either so
too early to say i mean this game could
go either way verusa could still you
know this is a a seven result position
of both players playing for wins and
losses these two guys i mean desperately
want the points so uh yeah look at that
i mean
with with four points coming in
a victory here
and opportunities to face all three of
the guys ahead of him in the standings
nakamura karwana and upon mishi report
would sort of control his own destiny
almost improbable to think you know it
would be very hard
but not out of not out of the question
so
all right let's let's back up and head
back over to the bird's eye view we want
to give a quick snapshot of
the other games just to make sure we
know where they stand
hikaru did play knight h5 in that game
but uh
it's kind of a similar scenario as to
where we left it we have again almost
given almost no attention to dingley
wren young chris of duda and i say that
just
knowing that we're probably not gonna
head over there right now it's an
interesting game an interesting fight
but there's too much too much life on
the other games that affect the
standings at a higher level for us to
ignore it so i think we i think we need
to go back over again to the featured
matchup of the day
check back in with the tactics and
evaluate yawn on the clock
yeah he continues to slide into
time pressure so this is the position
that we anticipated with the major
threat being a fork
on e7 with the secondary issue being the
possibility of bishop f4
quickly developing and targeting black's
loose pieces on the d file
this looks so so unpleasant
i i think part of the reason we weren't
in a rush to get back here i mean to be
fair is like we spent so much time
analyzing that we were kind of
anticipating that this would be on the
board and it is and we were anticipating
that it would be tough for black
and it seems to be tough for yon so um
we can dive in and play a little guess
the move see what he'll do but the
reality is this is this looks very shaky
so
uh
rook e8 rook cd8 that is yeah you have
to move this rook by the way because
this for coming to e8 actually doesn't
solve the problem right so got to get
that rook knight e7 check
and a big problem for black is we talked
about king hh's bishop f4 and this you
know there's so many issues in the d
file maybe even a fork on g6 at some
point sacrificing one piece to you know
get the rook but
king f7 bishop f4 they're just being
concrete about it it looks like that
knight can't be captured but after you
take it white just takes on d6 rook
takes e1 rook takes e1 rookie 8 covering
the open file on the e7 square if we
just pause for a second like okay
nothing's happened but look at that f5
pawn that's a problem that's hanging and
so you could trade on e8 or you can keep
up the momentum with bishop c4 check and
after the king goes to f6
it just feels like there's something
here if we
oh
what's up oh my god what an idea rook
takes the eight bishop takes the eight
and bishop b7 check oh come on wow
forcing the king onto a forkable square
winning back your material these pieces
drop off again probably just this is not
even an obstacle bishop ending uh where
white would even maybe have some chances
this is a pretty
straightforward ending and by the way
fabiano that's the perch we see it again
he's uh he's got the arch back leaning
in so that tactic if we just go through
it just a little more slowly king f7
bishop f4 right
seeing that bishop e7 check is the
winning move at the end of that sequence
is like impossible from the live
position right once you go down this
path right even rookie 7 takes takes
here rook takes e1 like just the fact
that you have to play rookie eight and
the f5 pawn might fall yeah it feels
like there's some possibilities for
white but then once you get here i think
fabiano would quickly see this tactic
with bishop e7 check but what a tactic
it is yeah it's actually it's logical
given the theme of the position too
right and where the knight has been like
you would be looking for something like
this and rookie 8 is 100 forced by the
way i mean no other move
stops rookie 7. wait a second after
bishop e7 check can black decline
the temporary sacrifice what about king
e5 where's the crusher here it could be
f i feel like i'm gonna mate you
oh my goodness
there's gotta be something here okay
this is this is f4 king e4 and i don't
see the mate
it's bishop f8
king f6 bishop takes g7 check i mean
this is oh it's the same like beautiful
except
different squares
same idea but you win two pawns better
than one so that would be even worse
uh
oh my gosh
what's funny is like you said robert
there's no way fabi has already
calculated all that but he doesn't have
to right
he only has to calculate even before he
went into this end game he's probably
already looked at positions like this
right this is where you just kind of get
the sense that your opponent is hanging
by a thread
but if you don't calculate it whatever
that is 15 moves deep
after these trades in rook e8 i mean
that seems like a draw it could be a
position where black's about to
stabilize and hold the game so i think
there have been other ways to maybe win
the f5 pawn right i mean
well b2 is hanging in every room well i
would argue that bishop f4 instead of 97
check is another tempting candidate mode
right
that could be the the
and it's probably not bad actually no
it's just good and in fact it's a way
more
like if you were playing bullet chess
it's a way more intuitive way to play
you just develop you continue the
initiative 97 is concrete and we know
that fabiano he can calculate
really really deep variations
when we had him in studio after he beat
timothy he was talking about all sorts
of different lines he was flown out
lines that me robert and the engine were
coming up with
right and he was right so that's what
he's doing right now because he could
have just played bishop f4 in two
seconds knowing it's a good move right
but he's i think looking for a knockout
in 97 check it just
puts that king in uncomfortable
territory for black and so if he can
keep his variation keep those wheels uh
turning and go all the way down the line
to see bishop e7 checking bishop f8 that
is
possible for fob down to c it just is
very very difficult
yes
i'm just i was briefly distracted by
something we'll get to it in a moment
uh but bishop
when we look at this knight c5 line
let's remember what doesn't work here
because
it wasn't bishop takes d6 right yeah
black could take d3 and it was awkward i
guess it was back to the 97 idea
right and after king of seven maybe
d6 or retreat your bishop because all of
black's piece the d file is dirty
got to clean it up but here's the thing
after rook takes e1 sorry after rook
takes e7
bishop takes
d6 or takes her a crook takes rook
rookie 8
you still have this bishop c4 check i do
and rook d1 but now rook d1 is
incredibly strong oh even better because
black's position totally collapses yeah
this this bishop has to protect the
knight
and if you move the bishop to kind of
try to keep it protecting the knight we
can
now go after the bishop
so okay this is
this is a position that is hanging by a
thread and what a what a great game plan
this would have proven to be right if
this goes down as fabiano winning on
command so to speak right i mean again
yes it wasn't
you know the pure sense of winning on
command at the end of a tournament last
round but pretty darn close to it right
there is
there is no game you know more critical
than trying to win against the person
you're chasing and if his prep proves to
have gotten him in this position and
then his accurate style very technical
calculates deeply puts the game away
then the people are getting what they
want in terms of drama right yondu
palmishi fans hey not so thrilled about
that but i think a lot of people are
wanting to see as as much of a mess as
possible in madrid and for fabiano it
definitely feels like this could be the
last game of tournament it isn't even if
he draws this game somebody else could
beat yanukong machine that's obviously
possible but for fabian on his own
chances he's looking at this game he
circulates i have to win it because
jon's a full point ahead of me and it's
possible but unlikely just
mathematically speaking for fabinho to
leapfrog him so he's looking at this he
knows this is his moment and
donya made the point that bishop f4 just
leaves white with a better position so
he has two different styles of choices
here one is much more concrete you have
to see through the treacherous waters
and all those variations to make sure
you're not losing your advantage but the
other
move bishop f4 it kind of pushes the
throws the ball back in yan's core like
are you gonna find the right defense and
i'm just gonna be better without really
much risk of losing that advantage
yeah and i think that his decision
really does hinge
on whether or not he will see
bishop e7 check and uh
you know because without it without that
additional tinder into the fire though
the fire
could extinguishes yeah
you said tinder i didn't know where
you're going no i said hinges on he
wants to swipe right on this position
that's where he's going
yeah so fabi doesn't have much time to
bumble around here i mean oh gosh
what you just named he did all the
dating apps
i'm not going to take this down to the
road though when i say something funny
you guys are supposed to laugh that's
how this commentary works
oh man oh wow
shout out to 25 gifted subs from the
psych doctor
and speaking of uh subs if fabiano wins
this we might have to update our sub
emote right now when you see it it is
the face of yonda pomneshi because he is
the tournament leader but if fabiano
wins this and they're tied i think we'll
refresh the subface because at that
point we're basically maybe changing
each round we'll rotate as long as
they're tied in first but uh
whoever's leading the tournament will be
the smiling face you see upon
subscribing to the chess channel during
the canada it's just a fun little touch
and we do appreciate everyone's support
um
we're not putting your face as the sub
either right now maybe later tanya maybe
later
i mean okay i've learned to be
thoroughly disappointed
[Laughter]
big moment here big huge moment and fabi
is it wants to be really
sure because like you said robert if you
don't go for 97 unless you know you have
unless it's in the back you know what i
mean not necessarily but you don't need
to take it down a forcing line unless
you're converting when moves like bishop
before
make your opponent's life so difficult
right so bobby's going to try to put it
away and if he can't we'll probably see
bishop before i'll just put it this way
i hope this is succinct that 97 check is
a bad move unless you've calculated that
entire variation right bishop f4 is
purely a good move without having to
calculate all that kind of stuff right
so i think that fabiano
he knows that 97 check is there
but he needs to find the right moment
for it
both players have 19 moves to make
before reaching time control remember
that you have to get to move 40 in order
to get more time added back on the clock
so uh nothing too serious yet but given
the lack of increment we've been saying
this a lot the time scrambles are very
real i think we're about to see
a real move here on the board no more
pretending or talking bobby had that
body language shift that suggested he
was about to make a move jan has that
head tilt as he enters
that suggests he uh
he's looking up the board i feel like he
is looking towards the e7 square
i think he has to be right i mean he's
got to be wondering we'll probably go
for it or not
quick reminder everybody these are the
two tournament leaders we have so many
new viewers coming in all the time we
constantly want to reset remind you
what's at stake
just another reason not to go anywhere
especially before you hit the follow
button if bobby wins this game we have
two players dead locked at the top of
the standings for the 2022 feta
candidates
give it to the people give it the fun
the hype jan doesn't want any of it he's
like i understand that i know i'm the
bad guy right now but i like it that way
right i'd like to be the bad guy and
just take everyone's hope away in this
tournament
just you know throw some billy eyelash
lyrics while you're at it yeah
been the bad guy
by the way bad guy is a song that a
niche gear he really likes speaking of
which if you wanna i'm gonna out him
anish geary is a closet billy eilish fan
um actually maybe public now yeah
everyone should be public of their
fandom but he okay i'll put it this way
he's like he like sent me videos like
hey have you seen this new song you've
seen this song so that's the that's
that's thinking of revealing dms like
it's we're just leaking he deserves it
after what he did to you yeah that's
true he did tweeting my dm the only
thing i've seen on billy eilish is i
love the show hot ones because you know
i'm a huge spicy food fanatic yeah
that's one of my favorite shows
and you basically eat a progression of
wings with sauces that get hotter and
hotter so where's your mind today yeah
talk about dating apps
it's nice
i don't know where you're going with
anything hey i didn't
mean it that way i mean get your mind
out of the gutter
i love it and she had an appearance on
that show
she was struggling with some of the
some of the top sauces but it was it was
great everyone does normally i mean you
should if you have normal taste buds it
would be a dream for me to appear on
that show set it up danny come on all
right hit up sean evans we have some
time no action in the two games that are
that are uh
impacting the standings
the most that being of course carwana
and upon rishi and then hikaru's game
with her job up on the right as i say
that roger does move king h1
so i thought maybe we would
pay off the the debt of going to check
on the game we haven't looked at for a
long time i feel like we should give
dingley wren and young chris of duda a
bit of a shout out at least make sure we
keep our eye on how that one is
progressing should something crazy
happen we'll have a little bit of
context as to how it got there so let's
head over there
the pieces are being traded
i i would like to say that maybe it's
dwindling out but the truth is there's a
there's a lot of awkwardness about this
position right white structure not super
healthy but pound for pound maybe every
one of white's pieces better than the
black counterparts besides this bishop
so i mean this knight is very good the
rook is obviously much more active but
how do you deal with defending this
right you got to keep an eye on this
weird position well as i learned from
famous effing legend
godakovsky as i was a teammate in
previous world team and olympiads
that these positions are never just a
draw that a lot of times the players
assume that there's not much material
remaining it's just equal but no look at
some of the problems in black's position
the b5 square right once that rook
slides to d4 the bishop can come into b5
for example and that b6 pawn becomes a
target the a4 pawn is actually quite
easy for white to keep defending so even
if black is able to go after b2 somehow
like a rook c8 or c2 eventually which
isn't easy because the knight on e5 is
so strong yeah putting pressure on f7
that it's
easier for white to go after black's
pawns than it is for black to go after
whites and that may seem
to be not the case because black's
already putting pressure on e4 and a4
but as soon as wipe has rook d4 pawn f3
bishop b5 i'm starting to like white's
position i can occur completely and i
think this is another example of a
situation
in which your visual sort of optically
white's got this damaged pawn structure
but i think the more important
consideration here is white's superior
piece placement right and to piggyback
off of what robert said about kamsky a
question i like to ask myself is would
magnus carlsen offer a draw in such a
position and
the answer is obviously not and i think
magnus would take white here any day of
the week including today's monday right
yeah including monday
well unfortunately for jkd fans this is
another day of the week where you're
seeing
not not a not necessarily a frustrated
jkd but just body language not
i think he knows this is tough for him
he's looking a little dejected a little
bit and
that guy started out so solidly in fact
even had early winning chances in a
couple of the games he had
um
maybe round one the most the most
winning chances he's got in the
tournament so far when he had the white
pieces versus richard report
but he's struggling right now right and
this is one of those rising stars like
all the rest of farouja guy coming up
but this is his first candidates
and the experience you run up against
against guys like dingley wren
can kind of can kind of put you
into some tough spots he doesn't just
doesn't look very happy yeah he just
doesn't it just doesn't i'm sorry i was
dancing around and he just he looks like
he's struggling yeah and he lost that
game of rapport and of course after a
loss you're especially emotional but at
the board right now
he doesn't look like he wants to be
there and that's not saying that he
doesn't care about the kids it's because
he cares so much and he's not doing well
yeah but he just i don't know something
about the way
he's
appeared in the body
kind of looks like i felt this morning
before i slammed that red bull huh and
then we went live and boarded i come
alive got that niacin vitamin b i'm all
jacked up sorry go ahead
you're scaring me
but uh yeah you know you feel for him
right and maybe it's just
a rough tournament and yeah it's not
like his position is that bad but the
problem is you
look at this position you've seen like
the next five moves it seems like white
just gets to improve and black has to
wait and see what exact plan dingley
red's gonna go for it
yeah the more we look at the more we
realize like it's like hard to find a
good movie for black like white's plan
is clear if you but if you move this
night are there already tactics right
because you'd love to move that knight
to kick this night
okay he just played d8 okay that makes
the most sense possible because it
prevents the clear plan of white
coordinating to protect
a4 but
there is the issue that this move might
be susceptible to knight c6 at some
point
and of course a rook could also land on
c6 so white probably should start with
f3 and my guess is ding if you play f3
though black gets the second ring uh
great yes it doesn't work
yep sorry i had to do it sorry john
that's an important that's actually
quite important um and if bishop b3
then you use the c6 square for the rook
i believe bishop a4 b6 and a great
example of the eval bar kind of giving
something resembling equality but this
position looks unbelievably nasty to me
100 out of 100 grandmasters say they
would play this position on the white
side yeah
man
but what about the 101st what about the
fifth dentist sorry all right let's back
this thing up bird's eye view
see where things are at i know that uh
if we have action in rajab of nakamura
which again we do a couple of moves oh
and look at that bishop of four instead
of knight e7 from fabio caruana so he
decides to do what you said robert pass
the the ball to yawn go ahead this is i
probably shouldn't take up any time
saying this but speaking of the 101st
dentist there's an old trident gum
commercial
where
essentially the catchphrase is nine out
of ten dentists like it so they show a
panel of dentists and they're pressing
the green button approve approve of
proof then they get to the 10th dentist
and he's about to press the green button
but then a bug is flying around his face
another dentist kills the bug his head
falls down on the red button i remember
that commercial that was
grandmaster who doesn't prefer the
position for daily brand got hit in the
face and and
blacked out i guess so that's right
that's the lesson there everybody uh not
endorsing violence in any way okay let's
let's go back to caruana and upon richie
this is the game for all the marbles
we got to continue to watch that super
closely
uh bishop of four was played so fabiano
either didn't see the end of that 97
check line we're not going to begrudge
him or just feels like this is such a
tough position that i want to
i want to keep yawn in it
but what about round two 97 check here
is still available so he's done nothing
wrong the question is will he play this
move knight to e7 and now bishop to f1
we looked at this position a little
while ago it's a real problem for jan
because he moves his knight from d6
because his kings on f7 there's not just
bishop c4 check but the f5 pawn is also
hanging in many different positions so
we're kind of i can't bring a checkmate
in
oh absolutely now as soon as c4 comes
available i got to come back right
knight d5 oh destructive yeah wow this
is how we are we are we
are
oh yeah
mommy mommy
yo
is bird the word
here we go again of your references
you know what fabi might get be
attracted to though instead of bishop f1
i can't take my eyes off of bishop b1
for whatever reason trying to get to a2
and it's not so easy for black to
generate a move
wow that's actually so still if i take
here
you're bishop rook's not protected so
right bishop to check and this almost
transposes to the bishop
oh you just take it okay
but after king f6 bishop takes d6
rookie one rookie one we've gotten that
same position
or or have we yeah we have because you
can play i think rook d1 oh no you
haven't because there's rookie two check
if you play rook d1 it's not exactly the
same may not matter maybe you play rook
d1 anyway because what what does this
check due to the idea that we talked
about yeah no this is still very bad
but i feel like this kind of move is
very much in fabie style he likes these
sort of creative approaches
and i don't exactly see what black can
do after bishop b1 it's probably some
sort of computer defense
well the problem is if 97 is is so
concrete and it seems like the forcing
thing but he's he didn't go for it the
first time he's about to be dead equal
on the clock
before he could go forward a second time
and you you wonder it's like we say the
longer someone thinks the more they
might be out thinking themselves
and if he's seeing ghosts or just
doesn't see the knockout blow
does he let it slip and not play 97
check here i guess he can also play
bishop f1 right now without knight d7
to leave that option for the next move
but apparently that's inaccurate for
some reason
but but it is still the human thing to
do you're right because you still have
97 the knight is still under fire
by the way you actually are back to
threatening rook d1 in a lot of that
positions
because of the the stacked d file here
this looks
incredibly unpleasant for black the one
good thing for yon just in general that
b2 pawn is loose and the knight on c5
even if the knight of d6 moves the
knight in c5 covers the b7 pawn so often
times you take a b2 pawn you immediately
lose the black pawn behind it here you
can get away with grabbing that pawn not
right away right no of course of course
in the future yeah
yeah knight f7 for instance
and despite appearances yeah if knight
e7 check and knight takes f5 then
exactly what robert said becomes
critical but she takes b2 is the saving
grace for black
and that's what's tricky that's what's
got bobby thinking right we're here
analyzing
edutaining
she's down on time also but now but but
you know this is super hard right bobby
out of prep when yon probably first
played that knight d6 move right which
he knew he would be better but he was no
longer recalling whatever he cooked up
at home
with his second vladimir chuchu love so
he's on his own and he doesn't have the
benefit of
the email bar or my helpful analysis
right
he's look at his eyes right he's clearly
looking at the e7 square because
really you can take on e8 first in some
of these variations but i don't see why
you would ever want to do that so
that's the only other move that doesn't
involve bishop f1 but his eyes keep
looking forward rather than
retrieving the f1 and he's gonna have to
put the bishop there somewhere but you
know the way he's been looking it feels
like he is spotting knight to e7 check
and that makes it very likely that he's
going to play it
well it's funny because you say he keeps
looking forward now i'm thinking and you
said you never played rookie eight but
because you said never do it obviously
you know dan has to do it okay he goes
for it i was gonna say
the one
idea we keep talking about is the d file
just to finish that thought and if you
trade rooks then you could have put a
rook on d1 and you wouldn't have had to
deal with rook takes e1 right so okay
bobby does go for what seems to be the
best but that wasn't out of the question
um
all right john about to respond
instantly
likes that he's finally up on clock for
the first time in the game and wants to
keep it that way and now i'm very
curious where fabio will go with his
bishop bishop b1 or bishop f1
a glance
a patented jan napomnishi stare at his
opponent raise his eyebrows scratch his
right temple and then look back at the
board i wonder if we can get a gif of
how many times jan has done that in the
tournament i think i've seen at least a
dozen on camera wow you move he looks up
lifts eyebrows
right that's the patented yawn move
now i won't be able to unsee it
i've just been starting to wonder
is there bishop takes f5 as well
in this position
yeah
i mean i have three pieces aiming at the
f5 pawn
i lost count there were so many pieces
staring at that pawn
but i guess you can take your knight
take with the knight on on d6 so it's no
longer hanging and after
the h knight takes i was gonna say
this is what can we just stop and just
appreciate this position for a second
freak is going on here look at this it's
so nutty
the problem is in the lines you said a
lot of 96 ah
that's that's key yeah so that's uh
i thought you were just stealing a pawn
but you had other devious ideas but if
you take on f5 first
what if you play
you gotta take an e1 because
your bishop and knight d6 check yeah
both of them but you take on e1
okay and you can't take on b2 i don't
think is a bishop d6
oh and rook's coming into e7 this is
really really rough
what a
what an
option i mean there's so many different
tactics here that's the thing about this
position right
is even in
the lines you grab a pawn
and black grabs on back oh we got the
even material again but the position's
not even and the king safety is really
important and black's king on f7 it's in
a vulnerable spot whether bobby takes an
f5 right now with his bishop whether he
retreats his bishop to b1 like donya
pointed out or to f1
it's not going to be easy for yon to
continue here because there's still so
many tactics
yeah this is an exceedingly complicated
position with tons of candidate moves
and tons of things to calculate because
if a move like bishop takes f5 works
you want to go for it because it is the
most forcing
of all of white's options so you want to
start by calculating it you know the
typical advice of starting with the most
forcing move whether it's a capture or a
check
and only if it doesn't work
uh do you start searching for the more
open-ended options so i can almost
guarantee you that that is exactly what
fabi is calculating he already had a
move in mind when he gave a check on e7
but having actually reached this
position your vision of the position is
more clear oh wow the knight is trapped
there by the way
the rook's hanging and the rook's
hanging
so he's going to want to double check
and recalculate stuff
to defend
check
yeah the king is in trouble king f6 just
knight takes g7 king g6 i'm gonna go g4
and just you might get mated up on g6 at
some point
so wild
geez
there's so much to work through here and
that's what as donna is saying it's why
fabiano he went 97 check and there's no
real going back from that decision but
that's why he's spending time after he's
already played a pretty committal move
so
well the initial move we looked at in
this position is probably still the best
just put the bishop back on if one
exposed the default but that's a
hard move to play if you feel you
already see a concrete line of taking on
f5
right but i feel like the leaving
tension in the position is probably what
fabi feels is to his advantage yeah
because earlier in this game when he
went queen a4 he didn't just win a pawn
when he presumably knew he could have
with queen to e2 so i think he wants to
leave
more room for himself to press an
advantage rather than a forcing sequence
that may trade off a lot of pieces
okay
yeah that's very much congruent with his
style he embraces complex positions he
doesn't shy away from them
well right now he's uh
trying to work it out this is the
biggest game
of his career
one of the biggest
he played magnus carlsen for a world
championship yeah but that's in the past
okay so that's by your logic how does it
work like every then every game you play
you got to focus on the present because
the day is a gift
you're trying to
i'm trying to steer your way out of what
you just said
you're just going to pull jason bateman
on me actually that was the turtle
um
the uh
mr
oogway know this is a really big moment
regardless of if it's the single most
important game of his career it still is
a very very important one to fabiano
especially after yesterday's loss he
would love to rebound so uh yeah it's a
big moment for him
the clock's starting to worry me yeah
that's that's what i was gonna say too
so i mean
maybe i was wrong that it's the biggest
game of his career he did play for a
world championship title you know
no but obviously you know there is no
time like the present and this is his
opportunity to play again maybe for the
world championship title at stake right
uh a full point behind his opponent
with an opportunity to strike back um
well speaking of striking f5 played by
hikaru but the evaluation bar it's going
up to a6 now yeah it's going the wrong
way if you are swear white's pawn
nakamura white's pawn might be in a
couple of moves
yeah i think we're going to analyze that
one for sure
it's been a minute
since we went back to that game even if
all of the features are kind of what we
predicted a little bit right and that
roger put the king on h1
icaru avoided the queen trade by putting
the king on h8 right that was the key
so that you could play a five without
the queens being traded
but raj is not apologizing he's just
taking what he wants on the queen side
here he goes with the pawns and it's
costly king
costs a tempo yeah and that's really
important when you're trying to attack
because look what white was able to get
in return the king slides over the rook
comes to g1 that's a semi-open file and
the rook helps shield the king on h1 so
right now there are many different
options for rogello he can play bishop
to e3
and you don't actually necessarily want
to take on a7 sometimes you do want to
get the bishops off but the knight
coming into f4 is worrisome so you
probably would prefer that the bishop
captures you but even if the knight gets
f4 with that rook on g1 black is never
going to deliver a checkmate he made a
move by the way he made rook g2 which
was not to the computer's liking of the
the one practical thing you have to
say about hikaru's position is that
while obviously he's now going to be all
in right he did everything he could to
keep the queens on the board to try to
launch an attack
he's going to make roger earn it right
maybe rajab doesn't want to deal with
the pressure maybe he doesn't want to
deal with an all-out ikaro nakamura
kingside assault he's already maybe
played one inaccuracy when facing f5
and we all know that all hikaru needs is
a tiny window of opportunity anytime
he's got anything going against your
king
the game is not over so he came back and
gave a little bit of a of a squint that
we've seen before he's like now he's got
the hicaro head shake going that's the
car nakamura number six he doesn't like
what he sees for his opponent he found
that a little surprisingly car finds
your move surprising
that ain't good yeah most of the time
but i think we can understand jabba's
move
because he wants to move his bishop
whether it's the e3 or d2 remains to be
seen but then his a1 rook at some moment
can slide to g1 i'm not sure it should
because you want to have your rook
behind a pass pawn but having that
option is important also he's defended
the f2 pawn and the reason that's so
necessary is that if his queen that's
being or java's queen ventures out to c4
where offers that queen trait and puts
pressure on the c6 pawn yeah maybe there
are opportunities for black exactly as
you're showing to take on f2 before so
the rook on g2 is sort of pre-emptive
it's defending white's pawns
yeah
rook g2 hikaru is
about to move doesn't want to take a lot
of time which by the way we haven't
mentioned yet hikaru actually
speaking of time in the worst time
pressure of anybody in this round right
now he has 19 moves to make in only 23
minutes
and he looks over the clock and he
doesn't like that he just shook his head
and says yeah
i don't want to spend too much
on the clock here
yeah and i mean the big question for
black now i think is whether
and where to put the rook on a8 network
is not participating in the game
my instinct is to put it on the open
file that's always what you know is
instinctual for a human rook a to d8
but that move might be ineffective
because there are no infiltration
squares on the default that gives white
a temple what is white going to use that
tempo for
maybe to discharge the tension in the
center with e takes f5 and you can't
really take back with the queen
because the c6 pawn hangs that's a
pretty big deal and if the rook takes
back white plays bishop e3
and robert i know you'll cosign this
white only needs like two or three moves
to fully stabilize and when that happens
yeah
that's all i don't need highlighted i
completed your
we finish each other's sentences
yes is that another
he going to learn what is that from
and we feed him every day okay every
single day all right um i'm a lost cause
by the way don't give anyone yourself uh
the
the uh no you're right and obviously the
whole point is that if and when roger
can simplify the pressure nullify
hikaru's attack
it's just a matter of formalities at
that point the apon is going to rule the
day so hikaru with only 21 minutes 19
moves to make needs to make this thing
as messy as possible
to have any chance
it's that's weird it's like you have to
keep it messy
because you're probably worse if you
don't but the messier the position the
harder it is to handle with how much
time you have on the clock so karo has
an uphill battle here for sure and they
both know that rajabovs has a better
position
and if hikaru doesn't keep that pressure
up he knows he's going to lose the game
because of that a4 pawn so rajaba saw an
opportunity he seized it he stole that
pawn on the rook's file and after rook
to g2 the move he just played
um you know for hikara i think it's
natural for him to try to double on the
f-file because that file at some point
will get open so dania was saying i like
rooks and open files you would love to
have both of your rooks on the f-file so
i could see an argument you know after
which i was in rook g2 for hikaru to
play rook f6 try to get the other rook
to fade it feels a bit slow but you need
to create some kind of problem for white
oh man
um well
i don't see a lot of candidate moves
here for black that are concrete to try
to punch through so you mentioned
bringing the rook and maybe the rook can
come to e8 not d8 well the white works
on g2 it'd be just that oh sorry in the
live position scroll back up move too
far
we're okay e8
and then if i take on f5 you could make
the argument that your rook is now
better positioned to prepare yep e4 and
i want i want to go for this and be like
all in on like something i don't know
yeah e4 e4 e4 this is what let's go
would have been impossible the rogue
being on d8 it would have been hanging
yeah and e4 would have been unprotected
now it's
wild so white can't take one chance then
rook 88
he's shaking his head he's important he
doesn't have a clear answer right now
but it just feels wrong to play rook to
88 right because
after rook 88 you want white to take on
f5 but white seeing that your rook is
there trying to play e4 after an
experiment not going to take on it of
course you're not going to take there so
you'll just develop your bishop whether
it's to e3 i mean i like bishop e3 in
these positions and
yeah
the work on e8 you know you want the
open file not just a rook staring into
your own pawn now you'd basically have
to take because the bishop isn't even
protected anymore
and then happy guarding the f4 square
computer likes black though a lot of
these lines now i don't know why is it
because the double the pawns
queen h3 something like that yeah i mean
obviously there is
serious counter play here and there will
be as long as
black has play going on the king side
yep as long as the queens are on the
board and there's pressure hicaro has a
chance at least on the board but again
the big issue is now
he has a minute left for every move he
needs to make that is not going to be
easy evil
that is hikaru nakamura um
he looks very unhappy yeah
and he's taking five minutes another
five minutes on this move and every
minute as you just said is golden he's
gonna have he's gonna basically be
playing blitz
very shortly
and he wants a fanta don't you wanna
i think he wants a fanta that was a
fantastic yeah fanta yeah he isn't
having much fun to end this position
he's not having much font in this
position he doesn't wanna
he doesn't wanna he's trying to give
himself a little bit of energy a little
bit of a caffeine boost doesn't he have
that coffee i guess that coffee is cold
by now no he actually he is this
magician so one day he turned water into
coffee they turned coffee into fonza
yeah you never know he's magically he's
got a whole stack of drinks over there
right
and uh
ooh you put it on the table you put it
on the table that's a sponsorship
opportunity because he gets paid a lot
of money to do things like that i don't
think ponte is a sponsor so whatever
drink sponsor hikaru has they might be
texting his manager right now and saying
get that much out of here right i don't
wanna i don't i don't wanna fonta see i
don't wanna i don't wanna font to see
that
faunting see that okay
you know where i'm going with this let's
go back to the bird's eye view well
maybe to change uh to make that drink a
little bit less visible they should have
changed the font on the font on it
i don't commentate with you two anymore
this is a struggle uh all right we're
too funny knight to c4
on the on the board with dingley running
dude i'm just looking at that it feels
like dingley run is getting closer to
having some chances
that game with ferugia and report is an
absolute
mess
report has stolen a couple pawns but
it's going to have a king in the center
dealing with some dark square problems
for the rest of that game
yeah and then
carwana
down to 24 minutes still has not moved
it's a problem he knows he's better in
that spot
but he doesn't know how to convert on
the on the concrete opportunity
understandably so right it's
how to push that position forward
yeah i mean what would huge question
there's several different types of
difficulty in chess when people think of
a difficult move most people associate
that with a move that's hard to find
that's not the only type of difficulty
and there's also difficulty that stems
from a couple of candidate moves all of
them are easy to see
caruana sees the correct move it's
either bishop f1 bishop b1 or knight
takes f or bishop takes f5 the
difficulty consists in choosing between
several moves that all look tempting and
appealing yup
and
that's why he's spending so much time
but
gosh he's got to be making thinking
about moving in the next three minutes
at the maximum
yeah i mean he's uh got too many moves
to make to mess around
with what's at what's at stake here
right 17 to be exact with 22 and a half
minutes remaining on the clock yeah he's
almost any car territory it's not one of
those things where as you say as you're
saying he makes a move and then
everything clarifies and you can play
quickly the complexity is going to carry
forward even after his next move
lots of players coming by
checking out what's at stake there
could we check the frozen game really
quickly
we can in a second let's
do you want to wait for his move yeah
let's wait for his move and then we'll
head over to that game and get us all
cut up bobby leans back and lifts his
eyebrows and he's like uh
i don't know yeah he's got to be about
to make a move
so this was the farouza yeah in the
ferruccia game the interesting thing is
that he had that repetition he didn't go
for it yeah but that position is going
to remain messy for a very long time
yeah okay we'll
remind everybody where we were at it was
in this spot after queen f2
you can see in the live position what's
changed
that bishop came back to e6 and after
bishop d4 queen b4 and bishop c5
as
john you just pointed out there was the
potential for a repetition
who knows i mean
report might not have been taken and he
might have gone to a5 he wants to play
it so badly but farrugia doesn't want it
either and after rook c1 rook d8
the youngest player in the field is on
the clock he also has a lot of moves to
make with a lot of time we have time
pressure everywhere guys we are going to
have one of those moments in this in
this show later on where we literally
can't keep track of all of the drama and
i'm not saying that to hype even though
you know shamelessly that is my job the
reality is just for everyone tuning in
ferruccia has 16 moves to make in only
29 minutes hikaru has less than a minute
per move available to him
fabi is not that far ahead compared to
hikaru he's basically right there
other than the dingley renduta game
those three games are all going to come
down to very real time scrambles
and right now fruit is looking this
position because
he's out two pawns and his attack it's
not clear how it continues and if he
takes one of the pawns back he trades an
even more valuable piece off the board
because bishop takes a4 here just queen
to d2 and he's just struggling because
he needs to find something and training
the queens is not that something
yeah this is a good example of you sack
a pawn and if you panic and try to get
it back
this is exactly what your opponent wants
right yeah because you're already down
two pawns and just cutting that deficit
to one is not gonna do the trick
and you could realistically like lit i
mean you could lose more if this knight
takes like you could play f5 and protect
so this is this is very very tough for
ferruccia and report shout out to his
instincts right i mean
i think we have to provide
you know
self-reflection where when needed in
these shows we were all very excited
about perugia's position here and i
thought for good reason i think it was
but i guess what we didn't really come
back and properly say is that this whole
sacrifice on e5 followed by the fork on
d4 it wasn't it wasn't necessarily
optional for white to find bishop d2
guys that was actually apparently really
key for ferruccia to get proper
compensation
yeah
if arugula loses this game
and even if he draws this will have been
in retrospect the critical moment and
once you play a move as concrete as
knight takes c5
you're
making somewhat of a faustian bargain i
mean you know you have a huge attack but
in order to keep that attack going you
have to play accurately and if you play
inaccurately you risk being worse yep
and that's kind of what's going on here
yep he went to e3 instead
and rapport
starts gobbling up bonds even more so
really it was that it was that spot
right there where the
the find of bishop d2 was even i mean we
were analyzing it and we thought it was
a nice idea it looked good and it was
good and it also had the same ideas that
the bishop has in the game but it was
way more forcing and the big difference
everyone is that in this line after rook
c1
the queen gets herself in a lot more
trouble in this position
than reports queen is in in the game and
so
bishop e3
things start going backwards for ferugia
he may be he might be regretting that he
didn't uh take the perpetual
with the bishop it's a good lesson that
the threat is strong in the execution he
attacked the queen directly he should
have set up an even more powerful threat
it was a tough moment so it's hard to uh
you know blame other is it too much
there but now he's in a situation where
he's probably feeling like he might lose
this game right i'm looking at him i'm
looking at the board and look at the
clock and report compared to where he
was before out of the opening he was
much worse now he's up two full pawns
and white has one attacker the bishop on
c5
it's not clear how he's gonna increase
the pressure towards the black king and
that king at some point right couldn't
even go to d7 and walk its way to the
queen side it seems ridiculous manual
queenside castle how often do you say
that almost never and report it wouldn't
be reports first king d7 in the
tournament though that's true oh you
just dropped that mic like it was hot
almost went on to win that game the
crazy time on up that was his battle
with rijaba but uh
okay
all four games bringing it as usual
let's back this thing up to the bird's
eye view remind everybody where we stand
we got 40 000 viewers right now on
twitch
tens of thousands elsewhere on other
platforms different languages
this could be the most pivotal round of
the candidates so far in regards to not
just shaking up the leaderboard but
maybe multiple decisive results for
multiple players so
fabiano went for bishop takes f5
rather than the bishop of one line he
likes the concrete
variations that are about to be on the
board
and maybe likes those concrete
variations guys because of the time that
was also facing him feels like this is
the most straightforward thing to do but
all right
right now we're going to take our last
break before we do the time pressure
thing so don't go anywhere before we do
we're going to remind you that after the
candidates there is another big event
going on of a different a different type
of hall of fame uh not hall of fame
chess players but hall of fame uh nfl
players like larry fitzgerald amari
cooper pro bowler
kvon thibodeau
recent top 10 draft pick uh it's going
to be awesome tune in on july 9th and
10th if you're into celebrities and and
your heroes from other types of sports
and genres playing the game that we all
love then that event is for you go to
go.just.com blitzchamps there's a
hundred thousand dollars uh going to
charities for uh the different cherries
that those players represent we're super
pumped about it and i hope to see you
there july 9th and 10th
well if you're here then you're
appreciating the beautiful scenery of
palacio de santonia
don't go anywhere
there's some there's some amazing
artwork amazing statues this place is
awesome seriously it is gorgeous
gorgeous any room you're in here it
gives you a lot to look at not just
what's on the chessboard
don't go anywhere when we come back
round nine will continue here for the
2022 feed a candidates
this is gonna be a real-time breakdown
of danny wrenches games all time on
chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less actor than them in every stage
yeah man that that stains a little bit
okay do the more game review okay yeah
thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks i
gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best let's go to
uh tactics
mates
i'll probably need to work on these ones
yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do
that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against hats
rook there for rookie two
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
the fee day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition
they now head to madrid spain where
everything will be settled over the
board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger
jan napomnishi would love nothing more
than a second chance at the throne but
he has to get through seven other great
players in madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss ali reza farouja won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss
the u.s number one and third highest
rated player in the history of our game
is also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlsen
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
prix cycle grand master hikaru nakamura
is a former world number two a blitz and
bullet chess legend and the most popular
chess streamer in the world he was
joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grandmaster tamora
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christoph duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event
dude would ultimately defeat karjakin in
the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grand master dingley
rent
dingley ren takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 feed a rating
list
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess plays out together
[Music]
wanna play check us online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
we are back in madrid fabiano back at
the board
and he's trying to make a comeback right
now i'm trying to catch up with yonder
pomnishi for the lead here at the 2022
feed a candidates but
we're not so sure that he has enough
winning chances left guys as we look at
the line that
has appeared after the massive exchange
cleared on both f5 and e1 yan finds this
move knight d3 which
making it a little tricky to see how
karwana can continue and he doesn't have
a lot of time to figure it out
yeah i mean he invested
all this time
trying to choose between those three
candidate moves bishop f1 bishop takes
f5 or bishop b1 ultimately he chose the
most forcing line this is an incredibly
tempting line in view of robert's point
that
after
all of the pieces are traded and all of
the t's are crossed bishop takes b2
isn't really possible but i think that
fabiano might have seriously
underestimated this
uh incredible resource knight c5 to d3
because after rookie seven check the key
point is that the king moves up to f6
and you cannot take the bishop on d4 as
long as the king keeps contact
with the rook
and the knight is hanging here too
wow yeah that's
and the knight is threatening to take
the bishop with check
which would just
i mean black might have winning chances
if that kind of end game occurs and
black can pick up the b2 pawn at the
same time so this is
this is this is incredibly
incredibly critical it's it's really
interesting because his preparation got
him such a great position but jan
napomnishi who was on his own from the
very beginning
found every accurate move and
fabiano while obviously if he goes back
and doesn't get the win in this round
he'll see that maybe there were some
other
some other potential tries for a
knockout blow but it doesn't matter
because right now he's got to solve this
end game and figure out a way to keep
winning chances alive
yeah so rookie 7 check does not look
like the move that he should play and if
not that right his bishop on f4 you
mentioned danny in addition to rook on
e1 both under attack
and the b2 pawn that's definitely going
to be captured in the next couple moves
so i'm just trying to figure out you
play rook e2
that looks to save the b2 pawn but after
knight takes it forward g takes up f4
it's like your extra pawn isn't really
much of an extra pawn after all with
double isolated f pawns but there's a
very important detail here you have to
play rook f8 to death i think this is
the sort of the saving grace because if
you had moved your bishop
then either the rook would have gotten
to e7 or white heads b4
and the situation remains very
uncomfortable for black maybe he has g6
counter attacking the knight but i think
rook d8 just removes all doubt
instead of this
yeah
although even here rook d2 like bishop
f6 and just trying to calculate this
through because there's a knight d6
check at the end but your knight gets
trapped so
it goes even deeper than this because
wait no not king d5 first you play
bishop b6 and then white is b4 to save
the knight and whites up two pawns but
because those f pawns are doubled that
looks like black is gonna get one back
over there on the queen side and white
can't create a password but this isn't
that clear i mean we see the evaluation
by 0.3
and think about how far in advance you
have to correctly assess this position
yeah right jan needs to get here and be
like this is a thousand percent a draw
because otherwise he just loses right
well fabiano
trying to assess it in advance he only
has 13 minutes for 13 moves
this time control
the lack of increment
this is crazy right i mean these these
players are looking at at the clock and
with real fear
in their hearts this is like ah
i uh
i don't have any help coming here i mean
as jan walks around
circling the board like a vulture you
know i think he's getting excited i
think he's feeling nervous excitement
right now for maybe the first time in
the game because he knew he was worse
yet he's back against the wall he was
out prepared
white's pieces weren't more active and
all of a sudden the smoke has cleared he
clearly found a move that fabie either
underestimated or missed he's up 20
minutes on the clock he could not have
asked
for a better scenario after 27 moves
given how this game started
completely agree and especially if you
told him that hey you'd be worse but
your opponent would get some time
pressure he might he might just take
that gamble
knowing how fast he is and
uh knowing how difficult it can be to
manage these situations without any time
being added back to your clock so
uh
watch that move it's move 27 bobby has
taken five and a half minutes on this
particular move as we can see that clock
counting up
um
all right well
we looked at rookie two going for the
double pawns i don't know if there's any
other move besides rookie seven check
to really go for you could also play
rookie four which defends the bishop and
attacks the black bishop
another option another movie could see
yeah rookie four is actually quite an
interesting one because
if black takes on f4 then after
rook takes up f4 back there's all these
discover checks the bishop of course is
loose on d4 has to take the pawn on b2
and i guess this rook b4 i mean you're
very tempted to use a discover check but
rook b4 looks more accurate take on b7
and g7 will fall this is the type this
is the kind of engine you want right
because now you have an extra pawn
three on one so it's an extra two pawns
on the king side versus one extra pawn
for a black over there on the queen side
and maybe black should hold with
absolute best play yeah but absolute
best play is not that easy to get done
yeah that's what bobby might be looking
for so maybe rookie four
is a move that we could see of course
yon
does have other options besides taking a
four you could take on b2 right away
but if i'm bobby i'd also be happy about
this at least there's some chances here
right there's still a game this is not
just a foregone drawn
end game no i completely agree and to
this end i think fabi whatever he
chooses he needs to make sure that black
will not have winning chances yeah in
the line he chooses he's in too deep
he's got 11 minutes
so he shook his head too bobby yeah
bobby is unhappy with
his current situation he's
visibly a little nervous a little shaken
maybe even shaking his head about the
clock
staring him down
anytime you're in time pressure this is
cute
basically almost automatically turns
into a three result game
and you couldn't have asked for more yep
his preparation was spot-on
he had a 30-40 minute lead on the clock
jan looked nervous
and young responded well so we have to
give yon the credit as we get near move
40 when they get an extra 60 minutes
extra hour on the clock and the 30
second increment doesn't happen to the
final time patrol but for yon i mean to
survive that position not to make any
kind of fatal error and then to kind of
you know see more than fabiano in some
of these tricky positions no and if it
ultimately does prove a game that yawn
draws or
even crazy scenario wins i mean that
that will just tell you why it's his
candidates here right i mean because
this guy
has already escaped the worst of
fabiano's prep
and
while fabi's still a teeny bit better
unless he figures out a way
to uh
he's got he's got a swindle some sort of
dynamic difference where he can still
outplay yawn for a win here but this is
it's looking harder and harder to come
up with something i wonder how deep into
the variation of like that rookie 2 line
and it is hard for black to keep the b7
pawn
and maybe fabi got to this point and
thought that rookie 2 would be a huge
advantage because he saw that black
can't save b7 and if that's the case
then you have a clear extra pawn and the
extra pawn on the king side once that
knight takes an f4 it's doubled so that
doesn't feel very good but if you can
grab b7 you really are feeling great
about your winning chances because then
you have a pure two on one yep
less than 10 minutes now for 13 moves
guys this is real i mean this is a cute
seriously acute type pressure yep
wow
i feel like he has to play a move like
working too completely
quickly that's the thing it's like
you're obviously frustrated with the
situation and i
the one thing in his favor is
probably the moves that are about to be
played are going to be simpler than all
the time all the moves he had to find to
get here right we were just in a very
complex position a moment ago
so much tactics on the board is why he
burped up
all that he did on the clock but uh but
still i mean
not excited about not having increment
this is very very nerve-wracking and you
know i read an interesting point from uh
grandmaster jonathan rosen in one of his
books
that you know a lot of people think all
right well when you're in time pressure
like this you just imagine that it's a
three-minute game and then you've got
oodles of time you know it's a luxury to
have a minute it doesn't work like that
yep right because you can't just remove
the baggage of this game and you can't
just pretend that it's a blitz game it's
not and you've just spent a whole game
with plenty of time now you're faced
with a new set of challenges all of a
sudden you have to rely on your
intuition and that's incredibly hard
gaby though about to make a move i think
now what are part of his frustration i
mean he i'm sure he knows he's not worse
here he just knows that he's losing his
losing his winning chances
but i just had this feeling looking him
that part of his frustration robert is
that he knew he was much better earlier
maybe he even maybe he did see the 90
maybe he saw other lines but ultimately
went for what he did and now he's like
you can't do it as a professional you
have to be focused in the present but
you wonder if he's just frustrated and
kicking himself for sure because there
were like probably eight different
variations where he was like i can just
be better without giving yon such easy
play in return and right now he's
looking at this there aren't that many
pieces remaining so even if he can
remain upon up he feels like jan will
have good drawing chances but he just
has to go at this point and so the
reason why i like this move rookie 2 so
much is i just feel like even if you get
these double pawns you'll have a knight
versus bishop it's not that clear how
black secures the draw right
right now i mean this is the biggest
game in the tournament so far if jan
holds on for a draw or a win the
candidates is getting
closer to being a one horse race at this
point uh it's that's not totally true
but
only six and a half minutes for 13 moves
probably he's got to move here this is
by the way all four of the other games
are still in progress here in round nine
all of them have drama it looks it looks
like rajab's advantage is increasing
against nakamura
uh whoa what's going do you see that
what is going on that ferugia report
game we just had an eval bar slide down
after farouz's rook g1 see-sawing though
it went all the way up and before all
the way up and then all the way down
up and down and around that's what a
merry-go-round does it's circular and
ridiculous time pressure for such a
position 23 to 15 minutes for 12. 12
moves in this position are you serious
no seriously this time pressure
is is maybe even harder than what
bobby's about to face i don't see
richard surviving this though
okay but where's the where's the huge
advantage what just
was clearly before white's move as soon
as he made it the
eva bar went down so yeah but let's see
what it was so in this position
with rook to c1
oh rook e1
i guess the point is that if black plays
bishop e6 you don't have to move the
rook from f5 because
in the event of ef the rook opens up
you're you're
only hurting yourself here if you take
the rook so rook e1 bishop e6 but you
know why rookie one's kind of a hard
move to play even though it makes sense
aiming at the enemy king you put in a
loose back rank problems your background
problems your rook's on a loose square
so you
move like queen d2 at some point or
queen c3 something like that right could
be really annoying to me so i understand
why the rook went to g1 because alireza
feels that the pieces he has in the
attack namely the bishop on c5 the rook
on f5 and the queen on h4 they're enough
to deliver a checkmate apparently there
is some way to defend mission e6
dotnet's suggestion looks like a pretty
good move
but maybe there's also something else
available to
report
yeah this is really
important to point out just how scary
reports position is if the queen moves
rookie five comes in
uh in addition to things like rook f6
the knight can't move at all because we
got dark square problems
and i guess white is threatening to kick
that knight speaking of which and maybe
enter in at some point yeah e5 followed
by e6 is just a winning move
e6 busting things open
all right
what a wild game wild time pressure as
well for ali reza perugia but i don't
want to spend too much time here because
i feel like the game that has the most
at stake
is the game that uh that we should be
staying on and that
continues to be a game where fabiano
caruana
is just burning time on the clock he did
play rookie four
yawn immediately responded with bishop
takes b2 which was the best move
and caruana is right back in the think
tank here with
12 moves to make in less than five
minutes oh goodness and without the
increment this is a game where you could
end up losing on time yep so
yeah this is really not not fun and
bobby feeling the nerves right now
yeah now it's a flat out blitz game and
he didn't go for the for rookie two
which i think was relatively speaking
robert the safest option as you
indicated
now the position gets unbalanced he
plays bishop d6 no
e3 oh my wow anyone's game to win at
this point and given the time pressure
that bobby's under oh my bishop takes a
three is probably going to happen and
you see hikara over there yeah hikara
looking like what like what happened
here like i mean he i'm sure the last
time he looked at it because he's been
working on his own game he thought
fabiano's position was fantastic
now he's like what happened here and i'm
guessing that anyone who hasn't been
playing the game who doesn't have the
weight of the history of the game on
their shoulders looking this like okay
this is going to be a draw yeah but what
happened before this was very stressful
for the players and now bishop takes a3
for black bishop takes a7 for white
uh this is
not too much material remaining here the
the one thing though is that that b pawn
it can either be seen as a pass pawn
which would be good for black or an
isolated pawn it should be good for
white if you could target it and then
you'll start playing on the king side
where you have an extra pawn that's the
only way to potentially win but no
that's not realistic at this point
yeah and if
you do have winning chances but even if
you win these two for one depending on
the the pieces you have left if it's a
rook ending or a bishop ending it's
probably just a draw
um even the night ending you know with
with only three versus two so that's a
that's a really hard situation to
imagine bobby maintaining good winning
chances
yes this is definitely a a day that
could continue to have that smiling
yonda palm machine for all the
subscribers coming in because even if he
all he has to do is hold a draw a win
would be that would be the tournament
i'll just call it if he if he wins this
game is black
it's red rover red rover sent yonda
palmnashi right over to another world
championship match that's that show yeah
so hikaru is holding his breath yep the
trend of the game has been in blackstone
if you told me 15 moves ago that one
side is gonna have 29 minutes the other
four
in my wildest dreams i would have never
anticipated that it's fabi who has the
four minutes crazy
yeah again out of the opening everyone
if you go back as far as a position like
96 where fabi was up
almost almost an hour at least 50
minutes at one point on the clock
and better
yawn has found every accurate defensive
move here to get into an end game where
objectively
he had he had
moments where he could have been losing
but he kept finding active moves to
coordinate and come back and he's just
simplified out all of white's pressure
into the position that we now have the
key word simplified bishop takes f5 yeah
it's simplified yan's defensive task
whereas bringing the bishop back in
either direction f1 or b1 it left the
position much more complicated and even
though bishop b1 we saw this earlier the
bar went down it's very difficult for
black to find all the correct moves in
such a situation so i think you know a
retreat rather than a capture would have
maximized fabiano's winning chances and
he is going to regret that he didn't get
more from that opening
right now he just wants to maybe even
draw like i don't think he i don't think
he's thinking that way yet of course
bobby still wants to win but uh
he definitely doesn't want to lose
and
fans across the united states of america
are uh are hoping that fabiano caruana
can maybe still find a way to swindle
this one out for a victory
42 000 people on twitch
welcome in hit the follow button
here we go bishop takes eight three i
think bobby quickly yep captures a7 he
knows he needs to move in a hurry 11
moves to make in only four and a half
minutes
and i feel like fabi's body language
says he
knows that this game is going to be a
draw yeah the accurate play and
speaking back your play when you're only
four and a half minutes that's when you
make mistakes so if you're young this is
what magnus carlsen said when yon played
against the cardinal kimura be a shark
against ikaru yan had a terrible
position hikaru you know was pressing
outplaying him but then
the momentum shifted the trajectory of
the game was in jan's favor and said you
should keep playing so why shouldn't jan
keep playing yeah he has more time he is
an outside pawn and yes this game
in all likelihood will result in the
split point but for yonder palmicide it
doesn't feel like he's risking much of
the moment no for sure donya how did you
get yourself in the mindset of that
right how do you shift from
drawing the person chasing you with
black would have been
option a b and c coming in you would
have been thrilled with it right but now
now you got to get yourself in a killer
mindset and be a shark as magnus carlson
said listen i think you can have your
cake and eat it too i think what you
want to avoid if you yawn for instance
is to start playing really quickly
yourself
because that puts too many things to
chance you have to play a line that is
practical that keeps your position solid
but that keeps pieces on the board so
one thing that comes to my mind is is
rookie eight chase the bishop away and
then drag your bishop from a3 all the
way back to f5
defend all of your king side pawns and
try to push the beef on
that's a risk-free option that also
creates threats
let's see whether he
chooses that he has played rook a8 yep
that's such a nice idea from danya right
there you gain a tempo and actually free
up a square that you want your piece on
and that piece is very useful there you
would defend the g7
bishop
sorry the g7 pawn he'd be meaning yon
would be defending e7 and d6
i think you play bishop of eight right
now if you're yawn yeah and then for
fabi you start getting into this
moment where can you just like force a
draw yeah because
sometimes you keep playing because you
know inevitably it'll be a draw anyway
this game if you have the bishop going
to f8 and then that pawn going up to b5
all of a sudden this could be a
situation where yon is just like hey i
have a past pawn that's not an isolated
pawn yeah sure it is but it's a passer
yeah and it it's gonna be supported by
the bishop 1f8 that's a wonderful piece
if it reaches the b4 square it's sitting
pretty with defense speaking of forcing
lines it makes me start thinking about
crazy stuff like this right i know you
you don't want to play to lose but if
you found a way to get
all these pawns off you know would you
lose the rook and knight hang in there
maybe
maybe maybe not
you shouldn't but you could and it feels
kind of defeatist honestly
yeah sorry
but you could try to start maybe with
rookie 40 e3 to chase the knight away
and then if the knight moves back to b4
there's less of an imminent risk to
white's king then you can play bishop to
hg7 and eliminate all black spawns the
problem is that after rook a3 there is
the inter mezzo rook a2 check as fabi
drops now to three minutes on the clock
yeah rookie three rookie two check he's
under three minutes on the clock
he's visibly
visibly nervous as we see he's shifting
his position he's darting his eyes are
darting back and forth between the board
and the clock
ten nine moves to make
in three minutes
that line
i i know it's it's
so even if you give check first whatever
the point is if you go for this
and you win
enough the b pawn is key you have to the
b pawn has to fall this is a also a
recipe to lose i get it but a brook and
knight do not beat a rook yeah and now
it's a force draw because you have a
million checks right so actually keeping
the rook on aid is important so the
black king can hide back on the last
rank but he goes right back to e2
so he doesn't decide on it
oh
and that seems to be an admission
of just how badly things have gone and
should yan start pushing the beep on it
is better now you should start pushing
the beep ball
this is this is completely coming off
the rails
this is nuts
and that's the thing about this position
is jan now can push with zero risk yep
he could push his b pawn he could play
g6 just to kick that knight out of there
so there's none of this bishop takes g7
stuff available and
after pushing the knight back to likely
e3 then play b5
and that's a past pawn yep
yeah g6 93 b5
this is completely completely gotten
away from fabiano who at one point was
clearly better in a middle game and had
a
a big lead on the clock but yonder
palmer she has to get a ton of credit
his form here in this event his energy
has just been super high he's also
conserved energy at times we said we had
a stack coming into this round that he's
played
the least amount of moves of any of the
competitors meaning he has a lead and he
hasn't even had to work that hard to get
it
fabi has had two of the longest games in
the event
it took him took him seven hours to beat
her job off and you just you wonder how
much that storyline is is something we
will be referring back to because
bobby was better but
wasn't able to convert you wonder a
little bit of exhaustion kept catching
up to him before the next rest day
god will this be a painful rest day for
him if he loses oh it would be
yeah i mean it would be a painful rest
day for the entire field i mean if
bobby loses
that rest day comes and everyone's
thinking about vacation i mean i mean i
hate to just be real about it right but
it's like when a team is down 3-0 in an
nba series and they say all the
professional things like no i can come
back i mean like this is like young
would be two points up on the field
mm-hmm
yeah because ikari nakamura is not gonna
win it doesn't look like he's going to
win his game it would take a big swing
yeah but timur
you know as we've discussed fabby's game
has been taking
wagon loads of time okay and that game
is turning into a time stream i'm not we
don't have to look at it we're not going
to go there just yet but just reporting
on that fact so that game is sharpening
up a little bit as well i told you fans
uh about 20 minutes ago that this would
be one of those rounds where every game
is in a time scalable and we can't
choose so this go to chess.com events uh
use one of the direct links
go watch the games yourself we are not
going to be able to be on every board uh
in some of the critical moments because
not everyone has we've had rounds where
a couple games finish really early and
it's kind of easy for us to toggle keep
our eye on both but this is going to be
a very wild finish on that note let's
see the bird's eye view just so people
can really get the reality of what i'm
talking about here look at the top left
that bar is getting sky high so with
every single move it's going from a
winning position for alareza ferruga
back down near equality so that game is
just ridiculous at this point with that
king sitting on e8 and just we'll do
that with every board i'll let robert do
it for her job of knocking next so after
that quick little breakdown by robert
i'll do the the time control update
which is 10 moves to make in less than
10 minutes for borussia and report only
has 15 minutes so that's the time
pressure over there there are still 10
moves to make rojava and nakamura
wait really they still have 16 moves to
make i'm telling you two more that was
12 minutes 16 moves to make only 12
minutes for rachaba and when we started
java played excellent blitz came down
the stretch yesterday against farouja he
was making all the correct moves in time
trial even bring his king up into the
open so right now his position is just
so good that i'm not too worried about
him
even in the dingly renduta game they
haven't reached time control yet which
means five minutes for duda to make four
moves is also
that's really bad a bit nerve-wracking
that's that's it
are we counting right is is white up a
pawn with a nice outside passport bishop
f3 check is it is the problem there but
it's
it's definitely
a tough spot on the clock and then
finally the one that we just started
this whole little merry-go-round
adventure on carwana has two minutes and
counting
to make eight more moves with no
increment coming and as our team has
astutely noticed he keeps switching
poses you could just sense the anxiety
and he
and me yeah oh yeah
i'm in therapy for a reason buddy
there should be six there
all right bishop b6
okay
so we're gonna head back to that game
the one with the most at stake for the
standings donya your thoughts on how on
how uh yon can keep the most fighting
chances alive i think jana might have
missed a detail here so he can go rook
up to d6 and
now you have to pry the bishop away from
b6 if you want to push the pawn but now
white has the move knight e3 to c4 and
after rook c6 it looks like everything
hangs but white moves the rook up to e4
mind you not an easy line to go for with
no time on your clock but somehow it
appears that white has stabilized the
situation here
and i think if we go even one step
further like rook e6 here if you trade
the rooks on e6 this is where things
could start to get out of hand because
after king takes e6 that outside past
pawn is extremely valuable and we
already see the evaluation we're saying
that black is the favorite
i guess rook d4 instead of brook takes
e6 right it's important to keep the
rooks on the board that's a good point
yeah that's fabi's best drawing
and winning chances at this point is to
keep pieces on the board try to keep
this pawn
pinned down where it stands keeps frets
alive
he's got two minutes for six moves no
help coming
there is no increment
sudden death chess
well it will be the sudden death of his
tournament chances if he loses this game
but
with
nepo's body language i think jan he's
very happy just to get out of here with
the half point yeah i mean he is
going to try to find a win if it's
offered to him but the way fabiano is
defending now with the knight to c4 it
seems like jan's like let's just get out
of here i don't want any more stress i'm
done with today
yeah well you know that was a little bit
of the the upper lip grimace from yawn
that is a bit of a well
you know
all right
i mean i actually think he's gonna be
disappointed because had he played b5
instead of
d8 instead of routine i seriously
believe that black's winning chances
here were
very significant
at this point
i feel like you overcooked it a little
bit with that yeah well especially given
the time on the clock for fabi i'm with
you so whatever he missed and maybe that
was kind of the facial expression
he did kind of miss that white was
holding this down that might save
bobby's tournament chances and even if
that other position ultimately should
have been a draw you just need to
maximize the pressure that's how magnus
carlsen wins so many games is he never
lets his opponent go without the longest
possible struggle and so for yon in that
moment he could have played b5 and in
time uh tommy in fabi's time
nice one in fabi's time pressure he
could just say you know you figure it
out my passport is running board can you
stop it right
no you're right we always i mean again
there's the the eval bar which makes it
feel like even more complete information
and analysis but the reality is it's a
game they play the game for a reason
right and time is part of the game and
when you run out of it i mean that's
when blunders happened even if you
rarely ever do actually lose on the
clock so i'm with you i mean that's why
magnus wins games like that because you
just you have to be a shark you play b5
you sense it and your opponent might
even beat themselves so anyway we keep
talking about this guy magnus carlson
you know like he's pretty good at chess
or something you know
he matters
you know uh but yeah we're sure that uh
he's watching these tournament
it's good to be king right stress-free
eating some popcorn see whether the
players figure it out
all right knight to c4 has yawn thinking
he has 18 minutes for five moves so
plenty of time
let's head back to the bird's eye view
while he thinks about it make sure that
we see if anything i mean yeah the
ferruga report game is just
both the top left and the top right
those evo bars are approximately the
same and that's worse news for hikaru
nakamura because there's more that
position is much clearer you just have
outside past pawn that's going to start
running but look at that complexity
between version report and in a six
minutes six minutes yeah and a report
trying everything he can to complicate
the position that bishop on d6 is of
course a huge thorn
not just in his side i mean
just a bone in his throat but can furuja
actually put that bishop to use can he
get the queen off of the long diagonal
and invade into g7
that's why repo report played h5 i think
he wants to meet rook d one with h4 and
looks like russia plays e5 cementing
that bishop even further in the throat
of richard report look at the dark
squares around the king there e6 queen
g6 queen takes g6
really oh we gotta show that oh my gosh
we have to go to there let's go to that
board
e5 was a super strong move everyone
because it cuts off the queen's defense
and you say all right well obviously you
don't want to allow queen g7 so just
play g6 right well
puzzle rush time queen takes g6 oh i
guess
oh it's not mate
no that's made no it is made but there
there's apparently knight takes e5
and that opens up the d7 square for the
king oh my god
forget you computers all right fine so
just take it with the bishop then and
you're and it's also winning nope oh my
god
g4 gets the queens off the border you
got oh so
so it's not that simple yes it's a
between g5
okay it's a movie before bit by queen e3
for rouge's got to keep the queens on
the board to make sure that the mating
net lives on the legend of the mating
net oh it very much lives on black has
no moves
actually i don't see a single move for
black
this is
i don't know h4
well i don't know and i'm just looking
making sure john deposit has put
five-minute caruana back on the clock so
while uh reports king is in danger it's
caruana's time now down under two
minutes
one minute 50 seconds and
mean maybe
nepal's still trying to win well at
least what have you got to lose
right
you should
why don't i have a tough position for
white actually because even though you
figured everything out it's hard to find
a move okay he does find f4 that
seems like a good way to do it
but if the bishop moves the b-pawn runs
if the knight moves the bishop falls the
rook is stuck to guarding the knight
those are the types of factors when you
point out that every single piece is
stuck where bad things happen right
nothing bad is happening lucky for fabi
nepo doesn't have any pieces to attack
but
when every piece is relying on the
defense of another
that's usually a sign for a tactic to
occur and expose your opponent and one
way you can do that like to move knight
to b2
because now you're moving the defender
to the b6 bishop from knight takes b2 i
can take that bishop on b6 if i want and
now we have a bishop versus knight
scenario the outside past pawn does feel
quite strong i've moved my rook to b1
start pushing my pawns things like that
so
at the very least it makes fabi think
but he gets trades in that variation so
that makes a couple moves at least
happen quickly but the position after
knight b2
knight takes b2 rook takes p6 is it just
me or does it look a little bit better
for black it does bishop is better than
the knight you have the outside passer
yeah i think definitely should go for it
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
because what's funny actually if
if knight b2 takes and you take there i
was actually going to suggest that
white comes with the knight to c4 and
that could actually be what fabi wants a
little bit of chances so perhaps on on
knight b2 takes you could also just go
for the bishop on bishop action
given that
this will also be a pretty
straightforward position where only
black could win
i actually actually would not want to
play a position if i'm nepo giving bobby
chances like this well he went rookie
six so he decided to offer the rook
trade and we mentioned this before the
black king trying to run towards center
in fact there's no choice but to trade
rooks at this point
yeah now you have no more squares it's
unlike the line where we first saw this
where the rook could slide over
here there's a bishop on it if you like
it then you got to get a bishop on it or
in this case you don't like it you don't
like that square i just got that
this game is ending with king f3 and
then knight one check and then then you
have three ninety one and then the
king's gonna go to e3 knight c2 check
and just keep checking
yeah we have a perpetual part one
has happened he's played king f3
king of three if 91 check his played
yawn grabbing his water going to enjoy
this moment knows that
in his pocket
is the ability to maintain a full point
lead on fabiana caruana who if you're
just joining us 46 000 of you on twitch
had a massive advantage earlier in this
game it was never clear to be fair to
bobby like clear as far as the road to
take
but he will definitely be feeling some
frustrations at the opportunity loss to
strike back and even things on the
standings
yonder palmishid the most recent
challenger to magnus carlson's throne
looking in control
to get himself back in that spot
he is indeed looks like he's ready to
put that knight on e1 with check just
verifying
look at every single possible option as
a reply but the thing is the king needs
to say touching the rook on e4 for white
so as the knight keeps checking the king
can't go anywhere but on the f3 e3 or d3
squares and there's 91 check you called
it king e3 bobby
resigned in body language submitting to
his fate
that he missed an opportunity to even
thing up here now he's you can already
see in his head that's that's a
that's a look of a distraught faviano
who knows he missed his chances here
donya
two intensely frustrating games going to
the rest day yesterday a game that he
lost maybe blaming his opening choice
today he's going to be blaming him
blaming himself
for his choices in this early end game
after ideal preparation tomorrow is
going to be
a night of difficult sleep uh tonight i
suppose for fabi but they just agree to
the draw there it is without the
formalities of having to claim the
repetition and we have our first result
in the books here in round nine from
madrid
not the result that many fans in the
united states of america were hoping for
yonder pomnishi fans celebrate pumped
their fist he just got one step closer
to giving himself another opportunity at
the world chess championship title
and you know the players they're talking
about these are the
last two challengers to the world
championship and for fabiano it's a
missed opportunity for yon it's a huge
sigh of relief and his many fans out
there and he earned many more playing in
that world champion he was graceful in
defeat he gave interviews after every
single loss that he had which was the
tough event for him but yan he is in the
lead by a full point and as we look at
other
of the closest chasers hikaru nakamura
yeah the biggest chess streamer on the
twitch platform he's in huge trouble as
well
yeah and coming into this
round if there was anyone else who
maybe had an outside chance at catching
yon it was nakamura who beat caruana the
day before if you weren't here with us
on sunday shame on you but now
now unfortunately this has been just a
what a topsy-turvy you know trip around
here in madrid
nakamura who by the way has never lost
super java in a classical game
might be about to lose to him for the
first time when it matters most here at
the candidate six minutes though that's
the only thing icaru has to find a way
to complicate the game because rajab's
idea here is so simple he wants to play
i actually not convinced that he wants
to play a7 to haste lynn robert maybe
you can help me out the issue with that
is that the knight would be tied down at
the pawn and you might want to reserve
the services of the knight for
a move like knight takes c5 or knight e7
so maybe you should start by improving
the position of your rooks and then
think about going a7 but no question
that the position is objectively winning
and the problem is black needs to find a
move because as you're pointing out the
e5 pawn is under threat um you can go
rook d5 which simultaneously defends the
e5 pawn and attacks b5 but then white
just slides the rook over to b2 which
opens up another idea pawn to b6 trading
your pawn to open the rook's file then
you'll play a7
and rook to b8 yeah just playing e4 for
black to show how powerful that idea is
that robber is putting out because when
you have a pass pawn
reaches the end of the board you get a
queen and anything you can do to remove
your opponent's defense just makes that
job easier so
we don't we don't have a move yet for
hikaru as he scoots up he has eight
moves to make in only five and a half
minutes so we're talking about how he
needs to keep it complicated for her job
off
he
he might wish it was less complicated
for him in just a minute because he's
running out of time as well
yeah this is going to be a ridiculously
tall order for him to save this game
and here he goes
he was about to move was it a king move
to run the king over was it a night move
looked like it was his hand was
swiping left to right king side to
queen's side i'd probably try to bring
my knight over somehow um and he he's
not sure what to do here but one thing
that dania was touching upon is that if
you go a7 for white yeah and then just
try to move your rook from a1 thinking
oh i have my pawn protected i can try to
bring my rook into trade then black at
some point will likely have to sacrifice
the rook on d6 for the knight on c6 and
then take that a7 pawn so that's the one
thing you have to look out for if you
are
rejected including now like if you move
your rook away say white just moved the
rook to g1 something well let's make a
move for black here first let's say
sure knight e4 and if you're making like
rook
f1 or something yeah well that's just
really bad for many reasons
but he can't do it with the rook on c1
so it's like you really can't even force
it because every other move is so bad
that's
it's it's
very hard well let's play a7 then
and then black does something and if
white puts the rook on a non-useful
square there's ideas where you give okay
well that's even really bad because it
allows you i'm trying to find it if i
everybody squared there's no way we can
even show this instructive idea forget
it okay we're just gonna that's just how
bad a car is positioned and that's
actually that was a good point because
we're trying to come up with any
desperado that hikaru could make work
and it never works because
any potential move that white would make
to allow it is so bad yeah which i would
never consider exactly
that's why hikaru is now down to three
minutes and 30 seconds for the remaining
eight moves he has to play
and he's hesitated several times and
he's hesitated and then taken over a
minute
every time that he almost made a move he
has no idea what to do but this is your
bullet chest champion so if anybody can
make moves quickly it is hikar but he's
just trying to get that last hope
somewhere maybe bring the knight in
maybe bring that rook on d6 into active
territory but he just doesn't have a
move
no
well this is different than bullet right
you're a very good bullet player often
the highest rated bullet player on
chess.com did you know that
no thank you let me know
so but talk about the differences bullet
is is is a very different animal than
when you've been spending all this over
the board time you're in a completely
different mindset playing in a time
control like this eight moves maybe it
feels impossible in two and a half
minutes well i mean there's the
logistical consideration it's literally
harder to make moves over the board it
takes a little bit longer for everything
to register
uh there's the other consideration which
is that takara was lost to begin with
right the position isn't good the
position isn't good and it's incredibly
hard to complicate things ikaru and
bullet is a virtuoso at making things
complicated here everything is defended
or jaboff's plan is simple
and i just don't see hikaru pulling up
rook e2 to c2 here simple and i think
incredibly strong aiming at that c7 pawn
restricting the knight even further
yeah that's a really nice move because
you can move the knight first and then
charlie over 62 but why give black space
on the sixth rank so rook c2 is a really
nice move and by the way it looks like
aller raza faruga he's nearing his first
victory of the tournament as well all
players in time trouble but for ali reza
he's looking to take down virtual report
oh man
so much going on here in round nine
yeah oh wow that ferugia game is gonna
have quite the finish because if you
take i mean i was going to say this if
you take on e5 in that game oh
yeah if we can show this politics e5
queen f8 is a little bit of a check and
then the rook takes back and then
ends there
a little bit of a mate yeah can't take
it oh why not why not oh
wow
so perugia plays bishop takes c6
i'm sorry just gonna say you know who
this is great news for is fabiana
carwana because frugal still has to play
nepo yeah and once he gets that first
victory we talk about farouza yep he can
beat anybody in this field
yeah a farouza on fire is not the kind
of person you want to play when you're
protecting a tournament lead because
he's because one even more than faviano
he has nothing to lose right going to be
absolutely reckless uh with abandonment
there just going after nepo in that
battle so we have so many more dramatic
matchups ahead here despite the fact
that napomnishi
his lead seems insurmountable but it's
really not there's a lot of things that
could happen
um all right
curious if timur has made a move
yeah report doesn't know what to play
here because he doesn't have any good
moves uh rajab now down to four minutes
himself
and we saw how rajaba was the recipient
of an opponent's time trouble mistake
right dingley ren early in the
tournament he looked like he was well on
his way to
securing a victory and he made an error
but java pushes that pawn to a7
car brings that king over to g8 and rook
c2 looks so natural yes that's like a
fantastic move
hikaru said that he thought if rajab had
increment in round two in their battle
that he might have held that position
i don't know that hikara would hold this
one with increment it's a little bit of
a different dynamic but hikaru is
definitely wishing he had increment
right now no i don't think he is you
don't think so i think he's looking for
the game ending sooner rather than later
he is that lost right now well the time
scramble is not over i'm not i'm not
convinced at all that he car is going to
lose this game yeah i i agree with donya
on this i've seen him pull out things
like this this is uh
not a game that until rejava puts away
especially given that his time pressure
is not that much better than hikaru's
but his chances of winning the game have
just increased because rook c2 is an
incredibly important move that he's just
played and the knight from c6 is going
to step back you will have no way of
defending c7 because the rook is tied
down to a8 yeah knight before is a
pre-move
basically move unless you have rook d5
in which case 97 check might be a little
bit better
king of seven
raja's gonna remove the knight
and actually now every step they get
they are on move 34.
six moves to make two minutes for hikaru
three minutes for jabba
for a job
about to go to like what a job with a
hut i don't know but yeah
by the way let's not let's not downplay
how big this will be for java in his
career right he has not won a classical
chess game in three years never won a
classical chess game against ikaro
nakamura in their career and they played
a few times so this is this is a rajab
who's the most experienced player in the
field
looking to strike but no night before
yet yep he's taking too long in this
move he can't put himself in a position
where
hikaru can
hikaru can complicate anything
knight b4 is really really simple
yeah i'm trying to see
how black even
responds it's basically resignable after
night before
whatever whenever players are taking a
bunch of time on what we feel is the
obvious move it makes you go like
what's going on yeah what is going on
triple checking triple checking because
rajab he you know he hasn't scored a
single victory he's lost a bunch of
games he's knows he's winning he finds
it yeah before carlo immediately
remembers c5 was that the move
no way
you played something instantly
yeah i think it was just it looked like
c5 i thought with the camera and it was
c5 and nbc instantly an illegal move was
played a legal move
what a legal move okay
is real okay
okay for those who don't know i will
show you his pawn just moved like a
ninja
and went behind my pawn captured it as
if it had moved once this actually is on
fassant for those who don't know and if
you're watching on chess.com's platform
there's a little there's a little uh
info bubble that pops up to let people
know what on passant is jokes aside 1
30. robert scared me because the moment
was so big i was like a player is going
to obviously on facant is real it's not
magic
tell you tell your friends about um what
team morgan looks on time he needs to
move he's got a minute on the clock no
increment four moves to be made
and he carries responding instantly what
a defensive strategy by a car he wants
to put that knight on c8 so he's
blocking one pass pawn with his rook the
other passport with his knight and that
blockading knight does put pressure on
a7 and even if that costs hikaru a piece
if he can get rid of
both the c and the a pawns for his
knight that gives him good chances to
hold and he's made himself sits up
uh rajab has less than a minute for the
remaining three moves
thought c7 was more convincing but he
establishes the d5 square for his knight
yeah that's actually a really strong
idea that makes cecaro's life very very
difficult and the car likely will drop
that knight back to c8 just blockading
the pawn in advance attacking the a7
pawn and maybe rajab has to resort to
rook c2 to a2 to make sure he doesn't
lose the a7 pawn the good news for him
is the d5 pawn is defended by the knight
so if he has to use his rook on the a
file so be it but then
the knockout it's still a few moves away
carter plays knight c8 her job up with
53 seconds to respond does so very
quickly by the way we now have the
perugia versus report game
down low so that we have both of these
battles we don't again we told you i
said it we can't follow all of it you
can go to chess.com and choose your own
adventure anytime we're doing our best
to catch the dramatic moments in every
game as they happen
but forgive us
viewers
for uh for it's a chess sin to not
witness the best moment but we can't do
it we can't catch them all wow that game
in the bottom right side is also very
interesting yeah i mean reports holding
on by a thread but nakamura moves king
up to e6 i think
and does he want
rook a6 is coming and then knight d5 is
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah six is a
really nice movement there java plays
okay six hikaro responds
30 seconds for the final and 40th move
to get an hour on the clock rajab double
checks to make sure it's going to be
move 40.
looking at a score sheet helping this
one old guy to another hey raja give me
less stress in my life and there he goes
and knight d5 is played he has reached
time control
with the move knight to d5
and now he's just totally and completely
winning after king d6 what is the
fastest winning strategy
well that's what job i believe that's
what we saw it was 95.96 yeah the
moves came in instantly i mean knight b6
looks pretty uh yeah
oh yeah it just ends the game
immediately actually
all right well now that they've reached
time control we're probably going to see
a bit of a think i want to head over to
the ferugia report game we already have
it on the small board so now we've got
on the big board uh they
are also just making move 40 as we say
it with 10 seconds on the clock reports
just played queen to g5 and he's gonna
lose a piece yeah bishop takes e5 takes
advantage of the fact the king on f7 out
in the open that's been reports problem
all game after bishop takes e5 he's just
can't capture back he loses
time
that's a glitch
kidding so if you oh that was a mouse
slip not kidding about mouse slips they
are real um
yeah the point is the pawn is pinned
and uh
yeah
you're gonna win a piece
he might resign after bishop takes if i
think he's hoping for queen takes e5
which would be a lot less accurate
because then in the event of the queen
trade black has rook d2 you win the pawn
on a2 you can keep playing still lost
bishop takes c5 keeps the attack going
while preserving an extra piece yeah i
think as soon as bishop takes e5 is
played it's still void
yeah for sure insta resign
decisive results galore all over the
place
and can we just go back before white's
40th move you know bishop back to e2
like in this moment bishop takes e5 is
very tempting it still looks like a free
piece but what report had in store for
alireza was a rook to d5
and now both of your bishops on the
fifth rank are under attack and it looks
very challenging to figure out what to
do the best move and probably the only
move that allows white to be better is
bishop takes f6 but who wants to
calculate this when you're on your
waning seconds barely making time
control what's the idea if she takes up
six years bishop c4 shadow of the king
side
this king is just wide open here
rookie five queen b7
yeah unfortunately for report he's
sitting here having reached time control
but ali reza faruja is enjoying the
extra time he just got back on the clock
and uh
when he comes back to the board and
takes the piece report might just throw
in the towel speaking of throwing in the
towel
is young christophe duda going to have
to do that against dingley wren he could
be losing his second game in a row oh my
gosh he's
it's followed
where does that seven pawn go and now a6
is going to come and the pawn is
defended by the bishop
oh no i think it was the 40th move as i
look at the notation up there yeah
on the 40th oh
right here
young christophe duda had almost no time
but also you can see because he
literally played bishop takes e4 in like
a second
which is the most natural move in the
world wait you don't so if that's a
blunder
that means there's only one move that i
can see that you know doesn't lose the
bishop are you saying it's bishop h5
bishop okay but no one is finding that
move dude that looks the bishop was
basically trapped here yeah you could
have played bishop e2 because the idea
is crazy what's on bishop e2 the
russians take it and then rook c7 it's
the same idea kind of in the game the
rook will come down and the a-pawn runs
and okay
oh my god but the idea of bishop h5 is
prophylaxis against rook c7 it's it was
to meet that move with g5 yes when the
bishop defends the f7 bond i think
that's what you were saying oh my gosh
that's unfindable i mean especially with
no time on your [ __ ] judo was under
incredible time pressure bishop h5 is
the only way to defend the coming threat
because you can sacrifice this pawn
unleashing a bishop defense and then
take on e4 and the game is still unclear
you've got to be kidding me yeah and
i i think that the win wasn't earned
because of 40 blunder even though that's
what the evaluation bar says yes the win
was earned by just the pressure move
after move and unfortunately for yan
chest of duda i mean there are several
players in the event who haven't won a
game yet right perugia is about to win
his first game rajab looking like they
win his first game and dingley ren his
first game so that would leave duda as
the only player
here in madrid not to have won a game
we knew that his uh first candidates
could be a challenge just like it has
been for many of the younger players in
the field but
duda
it off really solidly you know the
players talk a lot about how the longer
this event goes the more of a grind it
is we've heard the more experienced
players in the event
talk about it
five minute car wanna dingley ran these
guys know the longer this event goes
it's just grueling the double round
robins are no joke and that's where
maybe you see some of the players who've
never played in an event with this much
at stake
this long of a time as great as the city
of madrid is at some point you start
missing home you start getting tired
right and
you know might be part of the part of
the thing we're seeing here with due to
struggling
because remember he started out so great
it feels like as the tournament has gone
on
especially after that first really big
loss he had
um
to uh to yawn upon machine that he
hasn't been the same player
all it takes is for one thing to get
into your head like you're saying one
thing
that's it boom boom boom every opponent
you're playing has the capacity to beat
you
and once something goes a little bit
wrong once you start as you said missing
home feeling sad
you can just get pummeled these types of
tournaments and we've read that on his
body language yep yeah during this game
earlier the eval bar said white was a
smidgen better but the way he was
looking grabbing his head he's been you
know struggling rajaba by the way he has
delivered the crusher knight b6 and i
think hikara might resign here well
we're going to take a very quick break
before that moment happens so we can be
back for it now that we have reached
time control in all games robert what
are you doing like july 29th through
august 9th what's on your schedule yeah
there's this event called the olympia in
chennai india i heard that a couple
times i'll be a coach in the u.s
coaching team usa no for those who don't
know
you know and love robert hess's chess
commentary he's also a sought after
chess coach and trainer he'll be leading
team usa as the coach in chennai for the
44th chess olympiad uh right as we say
that we might take a break i might just
pull the plug on that and say we're
gonna stay right here because we have
our first
uh decisive results uh
of the round in the books i think we're
gonna have several others
the only draw in this round will
probably go down as the the one game
that people were hoping was going to
have a decisive result in favor of the
american but ferugia gets his first win
in madrid his candidates debut
he's got a victory on the board guys
and hicaro
is i think going to follow right after
yeah
but what a win for early reza what a way
to win his first game oh and look at his
car he's not even looking at the board
and this isn't one of those i'm thinking
about the position let me stare at the
ceiling this is just you know heartbreak
for him because
while he says you know his
everyone talks about his first career
streaming now and all that i mean he
obviously cares he's given so much to
this event he prepared well in advance
he took time off from streaming he's
played a really good event at this point
he's been he's in third place coming to
this room and i think the last thing he
expected was to lose to the tail ender
and team over jeff who hasn't won a game
since 2019 and i think that's the worst
part is
you're playing somebody you kind of
expect to you know have a good chance
against but rajab played an excellent
game he took a pawn when it was offered
and he withstood any pressure that hikar
put on his king
and he's earning that full point
a hundred percent
well said and also you mentioned that
it's
not a game
that uh expected to lose because he's
playing the person one of the tail
enders in the tournament who hasn't won
a game in three years but rajab has also
never beaten hikaru in their career so i
think it was just uh but those who will
look deeply at this game you'll see that
java brought a great idea to the table
with this a4 approach that kind of
caught him car by surprise he stole the
pawn and this is a line that hicarro has
been known
to just go into fearlessly because he's
maybe maybe the world's leading expert
in this little a5 anti-berlin idea that
he likes to play as black so
uh so yeah um
and i guess we should show why hikaru
you know is looking the way he is and
why the game is probably about to end
because rojava put that knight on b6
which offers a trait of pieces and once
those knights are swapped on b6 the rook
threatens to come down to b8 to get rid
of the blockading piece and if the king
comes to c7 the way to stop rook v8 in
comes rook b7 you take on c6 rook v8
just wins because rook d8 rook takes
rook and the a pawn promotes and that's
an extra easily winning end game for
white
if you decide not to take c6 and go okay
b1 i think is simplest or this ah
just preparing rugby eight and that was
totally and there's a nice line at rook
d8
not forced of course but rook c7 check
oh sorry we're good i was like what
i would do the other order rook takes d8
first
and then rook takes it and rook b7 check
forcing
king takes c6 and then rogue b8 wins the
game one of many possibilities
yeah
but this is first knight to b6 was
the hammer being brought down as one of
you said because once this knight is
traded you lose the great blockading
setup that it has here
and uh white's rooks
will help that pawn finally crash
through
that's how endgames are won you develop
winning plans around the unstoppable
force that will be a new queen on the
board so
picaro head in hand that's not a that's
not a visual that many fans around the
world are going to be happy to see if
they're just tuning in or even if
they've been here for a while
the most popular
chess player maybe i mean he's he's you
know he's definitely the most popular
chess personality and content creator on
the planet he's known to fans so many
people on twitch might have gotten into
the chess
game
the chess game they got into the game
right
don't hate the player hate the game i'm
making references here but uh
not not not a fun sight to see for
recaro to maybe be losing his second
game here in madrid he's looking at a
score shoot by the way he he isn't
thinking about the current position he
already knows he's going to resign he's
looking at the scoresheet trying to
figure out
where did i go wrong how did i have so
few chances seemingly in an opening
in which i'm
unquestionably the leading expert i
think
the way you look at is why was the game
so one-sided right this was a game where
java i don't think ever had
not necessarily the result in doubt but
he never had a question of who was
leading the charge right and so java
he's looking at a car like all right you
know it's time but i think that's the
thing that bothers chess players the
most is like why was i just so out of
this game from such an early point and
it was her job of catching him off guard
in this opening yeah well you know
hikaru felt out of it trying to wake
himself up because he grabbed a fonta
earlier he doesn't want a fanta but he
did font he tried to wake himself up
note that rajava has put on his coat
speaking of the meme that has been
hikaru's coat when he thinks the game is
about to end rajaba
put on his coat he knows that this one
is imminent
a matter of technique as they would say
yeah i'm not sure what
you're stopping hikaru from resigning i
just think he's very upset yep he's
letting it settle in
and it's it's never an easy thing to
accept but he's going to only want one
thing it's not a fanta it's for the rest
day to end so he can come back
and play the next game with the white
pieces and try to recover with a win
let's go back to our bird's eye view
remind everybody of where we stand here
in round nine two games have finished
two games are still going
and uh
one of them being this game right here
which could be imminent
the ending and the other game being the
dingley wren yonkristov due to battle so
we've got
we've got duda in charge we have a java
i mean look at what java he just
he just wants to go he's literally
twiddling his thumbs yeah yeah he is uh
he's right but for hikaru
right you now fall
two full points behind the leader you
still have yet to play yan upon she
and
while it's unlikely if not you know
borderline impossible for him to win
first place we didn't talk about today
we've talked about many other rounds
if magnus carlsen doesn't play the world
championship the person who finished in
second place
might get a match against the winner of
the candidate so hikar still has quite a
lot to play for and that's definitely
the back of all these players minds even
if yon is running away with it they
can't catch up to him maybe they can
catch up to fabiano yeah
second place
second place matters you know what ricky
bobby you were wrong if you ain't first
you're last well not when it comes to
the candidates potentially because if
magnus carlsen holds true to what he
said and decides not to play for the
world chess championship not to defend
his world chess championship title
we could have a really interesting story
line of first and second place
finishers here from madrid playing for
the title
wait isn't this his first win in 35
games actually it's 37 to be exact it
was 29 games coming into the candidates
eight games have been played so
uh
the first win in 37 games you are
correct chad
um
all right well i think we are gonna
maybe throw a curveball here and
actually throw to a break here because
we've got icaru on the clock
we're gonna we're gonna quick quickly
get a reset and we might even be joined
by a guest a very special guest
potentially on the other side so you
don't want to go anywhere it's more of a
chess.coms coverage for round nine of
the feed a candidates here in madrid
when we return
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
[Music]
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
apparently this is the horse she rode in
on literally queen isabella herself on a
night a noble steed you know changed the
world forever it's why
everyone in madrid
knows the game of chess
they know that the candidates is here
they know that uh that this is
one of the capital cities of our great
game and it's all because of that lady
right there on that noble steed now
that's a night thank god for queen
isabella changing the rules right and
giving the queen her powers
i know that in the filming we're really
running with this but in my head it was
the queen of france so that begs the
question who is the chess.com historian
and can i fire them um
well you'd have to fire yourself i think
yeah that's a good point
that's uh call that's an out take i
believe they called him today i'll take
so mike's gonna say was the queen of
spain next time he knows yeah he knows
yeah we gotta find more about this lady
and find more about what the people know
here
[Music]
you guys excited for the candidates
hey can we talk for a second about this
here we go
to the plaza we go
which way is the plaza
[Music]
you guys play chess yeah yeah yeah
there you go
are you excited for the candidates yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you know
you don't know what it is
okay what is it we've watched the
queen's game oh you've watched the
queen's gambit me too okay you guys
actually play chess like on your phone
what are you playing chess.com yeah
you're about 1300 on leashes yeah so it
means you'd be like 900 on chess.com
actually yeah give me your username i'll
give you a diamond membership
not kidding he's going to be a contender
in like three years
he's up and coming so i'll give you a
premium membership and then you won't
have an excuse then you can use it i'll
go back to it yeah all right man oh
you're an am that's me man
he's like number one oh yeah the guy
that like beats yeah so this tournament
decides who plays magnus carlson
so the next challenger comes out of this
tournament all right guys enjoy thank
you so much so much
you guys are connected now yeah we're
buddies on we're going to send each
other some ticks do you think they
already talked and then we'll we'll
we'll talk about it is that your phone
buzzing but they are they are they
already yeah they're already hitting me
up for my digits okay yep maybe wearing
a pager wasn't the smartest idea to fit
in with them
[Music]
want to play chess online or join us at
the number one chess destination in the
world chess.com with thousands of people
playing at any moment you'll quickly
find a game with someone at your level
whether you're a beginner or a
grandmaster chess.com makes learning fun
and easy sharpen your need to take your
game to the next level signing up is
free and easy join chess.com today
and we are back here in madrid live in
studio with uh a very special guest ali
reza for ruja
gets his his first victory here at the
candidates tournament first of all just
you you fought so hard so many amazing
games but how does it feel a great a
great win today and uh what are your
thoughts on the game yes it feels very
nice because uh
it's been a long time i didn't win again
um
i had so many good good positions in
this tournament but yeah just
unfortunately i couldn't make it work
but today i'm happy because he's a very
strong player and he's in a very good
shape
yeah so this win
it counts yeah
every game every game counts here right
yesterday we were we were watching your
incredible fight and effort versus for
java it just felt like you were just
grinding and pushing so hard how much do
you feel that even though
that game didn't ultimately go the way
you wanted you didn't get the victory
yesterday how much do you feel like that
was important to just continue to like
get your form correct get yourself in
the best fighting shape so that you can
start earning these victories that all
your fans around the world want to start
seeing those victories come one after
another yeah normally i like this kind
of games because um it really shows how
strong your opponent is physically
mentally
yeah he showed very good uh
he showed that he's prepared for this
kind of games right um so
it was very impressive the way he was
defending until the end so
yeah in general i played many games like
this in this tournament actually but
yeah seven hours is first time yeah
seven hours is good go ahead robert
after a seven hour game did you wake up
today tired from yesterday's game or did
you feel refreshed just ready to go for
yes normally you're a little bit tired
um
yeah but in general
yeah even if you sleep for seven hours
you will get tired somewhere
so
yeah it was a bit tired but okay i'm
happy there's rest day tomorrow
well i first of all great to have you in
studio thank you for being here and
again congrats congrats on the win we'd
love to maybe maybe go over the game
quickly we'd also love to
ask you some other questions about how
you're feeling what the experience has
been like for you but um
if you don't mind let's you might just
well we'll keep an eye on dingley wren
young for subdued for the fans who want
to know and yes while we were at the
break many of you saw that hikaru
nakamura did resign against tame over
jabba who earns a big victory but you
mind taking us through quickly this game
with richard report yes all right great
so
the first thing was kind of a
interesting opening
when were you maybe
i was surprised from move one because
normally he plays sicilian all his life
so right
he played the most solid design in chess
so
and i i think he was expecting italian
maybe but i decided to go for roy lupus
right well you said he played the most
solid light in chess and then you had
the most crazy game ever yeah
yeah i was fortunate he didn't remember
the line
the theory exactly so if he plays
correctly i don't get this kind of
sharp positions but yeah we should until
here i think mike nose has a game
against iranian
at some point but he lost that game his
voice actually
so so when you say he messed up the
theory where where was he first
misstepping in your eyes
for instance 27 is i think inaccuracy
okay
it's very small inaccuracy but these
days this kind of things counts right so
he had a better way to play so i don't
get this f4 idea now after 27 i got the
time to push f4
we showed g4 when he won were you
surprised by that bishop g4 move
already i i was very happy after knight
c4 because it's not easy position
because if you touch the bishop on b6
then i have a four and his plan was to
keep the bishop on this
right in this diagram but
then i just been king each one
yeah
when we came to this board and we saw
the bishop on jeep we were you can see
all the highlights carried over right
all the things you're seeing are the
things you were talking about we were
really liking your position and what was
about to happen
after f4
and a4
you were you went for this really
aggressive idea of of taking everything
on e5 were you already kind of smelling
blood in the water here and and really
wanted to strike before he got his king
out of the center yes normally this kind
of things you should just play without
thinking but i think it was not the best
way actually maybe i had just
i should have gone knight e3 here and
just be better but yeah
yeah i decided just to go for it and see
what happens because it looked very
interesting so
it had us we were we were excited it
looked very interesting to us too and uh
in this position right here how much did
you feel the uh the compensation was
long term or you thought you had to be
really accurate as far as i said yes of
course i have to be accurate because if
he castles then it's uh
he's just better so yeah this bishop d2
i saw the move but yeah it was my first
idea actually but then i thought maybe
bishop three is better but yeah
appreciate it too it's nicer because i
have bishop c3 bishop before his queen
cannot go
out i think rook c1 here yeah
yeah but bishop v3 also interesting but
me i think i got worse at some point i
don't know bishop e3 takes
yeah queen f2 bishop v6 was a very nice
move
to just protect everything were you
maybe worried at this point that that it
wasn't worth the two pounds you
sacrificed yes i was very worried
because
i realized that he could even go long
castle and his king will be safe right
so
because first i thought he has to if he
doesn't go short castle then his king is
always weak but
yeah bishop d4 queen b4
yeah queen c3
did you think about repeating with
bishop d4 and things like that or you
always were playing for the win no
bishop d4 i didn't think about that
bishop d6 i was thinking but this was
not good yeah roxy one is only troy i
think yeah to continue the game rook d8
was a nice move
and yeah bishop b1 queen e5
queen h4
yes and here
it's a very difficult position over the
board i think yeah
you know we were we were saying that
despite the
despite whatever the computer says or
the evil right this is a a literal
thought in his side and
yeah it's he told me actually after the
game h6 i had to play with it's very
impressive that he saw h6
after the game and it's a very good move
oh so he told you that he knows he
missed this chance yes okay
what's the main idea mr black is going
to get g5 yes but i still think after
for instance h3 here it's very difficult
for him oh now rook d2 he says
that feels like such a computer thing to
do
i don't know that he saw that maybe he
saw this yes and then queen no but g5
always i was happy to get at least g5
right
because still he has some problems with
maybe with tactics he can solve what
knight h5 knight g3 yeah
okay
but it was a mess i mean you guys were
entertaining no matter what and then
after he missed this chance with bishop
to c4 you you kind of never looked back
from here
rook f5 coin b2 maybe rook ivan was more
accurate actually
but i was i didn't have much time and i
was afraid this rook is hanging at some
point right yeah that's exactly what we
were talking about during the games
just felt safer yes it was safer and
we should be 6 23. yeah queen g3 was
nice move yeah very nice 97.
at what point did you feel like the game
was over that you were winning already i
understood it's very difficult here for
him because my plan is very simple i
just should push e5 i'm mate and yeah
it's very difficult here i was confident
that
we've been seeing
74
yeah e5 didn't work that's for some
reason
right away yes because first i said this
he has to just resign but then he takes
and then queen g7 he has knight of eight
oh
wow
yeah no you don't have mate
you can't even take the rook yeah rook
d6 and also bishop f5 knight of fate
instead of queen g7 i couldn't find the
win
bishop f5 bishop f5 knight f8
ah queen f3
yeah i missed queen f3 because still
if queen g5 i thought first also is
spinning but then rook d6
yeah ed6 queen f6 only move
and then i don't win
somehow
queen is 396.
we were not calculating
just so you know this is impressive we
were just kind of going with the flow
but yes that's uh yeah but look funny is
better move yeah just to come back and
then it's very tough for him here
working one h5 and then once you had e5
we we came here we we got we got kind of
silly we were analyzing a game in real
time and after after g6 we started
thinking oh there'll be queen takes g6
but there's actually knight takes e5
and black is surviving
we were we were very excited that you
might checkmate you might checkmate him
in the middle of the board but this
bishop takes g6 thing but it doesn't
work because
he doesn't have to take so
in the game you didn't play that queen
g4 23.
yeah h4
yeah he's just lost here
there's the defense
well you uh you put it away cleanly we
uh we saw richard barely make time
control with 10 seconds
after queen g5 but knew that uh knew
that he would resign as he came back so
okay great win
and you've had some other great games in
the event but now that you've gotten
this victory
kind of behind you do you feel like this
is going to give you some momentum going
forward into the back half of your event
here
yes it's always nice to win a game
and it can change my tournament
situation but i'm not sure if you change
the whole tournament situation right
because
jan is very has a lot of points so i'm
not expecting anything i just want to
continue yeah to finish this turn on
you get on with the white pieces a
chance at revenge maybe though in a
couple rounds right yes i'm looking
forward to looking forward to the
revenge i love that and you know at this
point of course it's been a tough event
but you just won a game it was a really
crazy game do you think that you know
you get a rest day tomorrow you can take
day off first of all what are you gonna
do on your day off
normally i play tennis
tonight
yes
yes you play tennis with your brother or
yes that's my brother
that's great yeah who's your favorite
tennis player
um
now few actually
um all chorus is very good
so you just on the comment you made
before you before robert took that last
question made me think like like you
said you're focused on your chest just
playing the best you can at this point
do you feel like that's going to allow
you to even be a little more aggressive
maybe there's the the pressure you feel
you want revenge right against yawn and
are you do you feel like you're going to
be playing aggressive chess
in the back half here yeah i was playing
very aggressively in the
start of the tournament which was maybe
not the
correct thing to do but okay it's just
i play normally like this so
for instance i guess ianna you made a
lot of risk playing this night or right
so
um
yeah but in general i i will continue
playing the same it's very aggressive
already so yeah
and it determines 14 rounds it's very
long and it's also i guess the first
time you played such high level
opposition 14 games in a row yeah of
course the stakes are very high with the
world championship but how does it feel
to play such strong people you know
every single day yeah i didn't play 14
rounds tournament
before so it's from my first time and
yes it's it's it feels great actually
every day to come play against all these
very top players at their best
it's a very tough thing to do but i'm
really enjoying it
and
the fact that i got the chance to
qualify in this tournament was already
pretty good and
i have five another another
five games i will try to enjoy it so
yeah well talk about that because you
said i mean it's a tough tournament
you're enjoying enjoying the experience
but
what have you what have you learned
right your future is bright it's like a
meme farouza is the future right they
say and i don't i know that's come with
baby pressure at times but what have you
learned so far have you have you changed
anything about your approach to through
the first nine games and what would you
say that you're you've now taken with
you as we're going to start talking
about what you're going to take ahead
into your final five matches yes i i
learned a lot of things actually i have
to
go back home and again review all these
games to see
and get a lot more than what i know now
but i think
in general it feels uh
i understood that they are all very
motivated right um
even if some people said for instance
rajab was not motivated or serious but
he's playing seven hours games
he's played more moves than anybody else
in the tournament at this point yes so
everybody is very motivated everybody's
in their best i think
for instance fabiano and yond i think
they are in their best
so
um it's it's it's really amazing and
um
a lot to take from this tournament yeah
well let's let's talk about what you
might take into the the back half set of
matches i mean i you can't no revealing
any prep right prep stays for you we
don't want you to tell us what openings
you're going to play but
if there are a few games you have
circled right like in your hotel room
games we know you want revenge against
yonder palmishi uh you'll get another
game against hikaru a game that maybe
just barely got away from you you almost
had a victory there tell us about of the
five matches ahead which ones you're
most looking forward to
um
now i look forward to playing i think
because he's playing very good now yeah
and i really i always look forward to
playing against him and now he's that
he's in his best
is i'm really excited for this game yeah
okay yawn right got a circle so
all right well we have you in studio i
have to ask the big question because you
know everyone's talked about it
obviously it's our job to entertain the
world and that's what they think about
and one of the biggest storylines coming
in was magnus carlson's statement right
that he would play you if you won this
event and if you would play you in a
match and who knows whether that's true
or not and you've said many times that
you don't feel like that added any extra
pressure to you that you love chess and
that's what you're going to continue to
do but
now that you're here you're halfway
through there's been all kinds of
learnings how do you feel about what
this experience has been and was there
maybe some pressure in the back of your
mind that you didn't know about or did
those statements really you feel never
never get to you
no really not really because if you look
at my games it's really me that is
playing the games i think because it's
really my style and
i don't feel any pressure i think
because
that's probably a good thing that's a
that's a great thing i think we feel
pressure when magnus says things like
that for you but you know okay
it's amazing stuff well maybe now that
you've gotten this wind here and and
pressure's off a little bit we'll
continue to see ferruccio catch fire i'm
always thinking of like fighting for
rouge if russia catches fire
you know thinking of funny phrases there
but
um anyway man this is great and we're
super excited for you what a game it was
maybe we'll be having you in studio
again depending on how many victories
you start racking up here um
but i got nothing else
here comes some love from the fans ollie
with the hearts we got a lot of people
tuning in right now
we got
32 000 people
we love you ali reza they do um anyway
this is this has been great
i got nothing else i'm sorry i don't
have any more questions i'm running out
of questions but
absolute genius well-deserved win thank
you
you've been tired do you want it you
want me to give you a diamond membership
for your win
apparently you had three brilliant moves
according to our game review and you
know your analysis and computer's a
little different than our game review we
had three brilliant moves in this game
hopefully i don't get banned again
oh man
i'm gonna tell a story while we have ali
reza here so when ali reza was young
when elizabeth was young and nobody knew
who ellie rosa was i think you
[Laughter]
so we knew we knew of this kid before
anyone else did and because he was he
was racking up wins and
he basically reached like the auto band
level on our site we didn't know who he
was he wasn't even you weren't even a gm
yet you were like 11. i i am yes okay
and we we banned him we did a manual
review and we said no this is a this is
a human a very strong human but a human
and then i will say this without calling
out any other names one thing that ali
reza you know doesn't know is before
people knew how good ferrucci was going
to be i have had more i had more top
grand masters email me about this
account and say this person's cheating
and i would email them you you now have
played and beaten some of them in
tournaments
and i would say no guys relax he's clean
he's just a future star and here he is a
star of the future sitting sitting with
us in the candidates so that's you
brought it up so there you
anyway man we are very excited for you
thank you what a game and we hope we do
hope of course to have many more
conversations like this in the future
and
congratulations to you and your and your
family and uh thank you again
way to go enjoy the rest thank you thank
you
thank you all right all right
well there you go that was alireza for
ruja
one one of the the the men of the day
got a victory of course as we said there
was another decisive game here where
java also got his first victory
in more than three years but that was an
awesome interview
awesome kid
and uh
that was fun that was awesome dingley
wren's having fun by the way he might
get his first victory in the candidates
as well that would be the trifecta right
three different players trying to get
their first victory uh today and it's
what alerizar was saying right these
players even if they're out of
contention everybody came here to fight
and it was great to hear
from alareza you know that while
a lot of people assume that the pressure
would be insurmountable and that's the
coordination doesn't get it doesn't get
to him and he is having a tough end but
that first victory he still wants to
play and i love what he said just he
he's very happy to have the opportunity
yeah to play all these top players and
it's an opportunity to learn
and his response too when like i mean i
had to ask that question of course is
the biggest question we've all been
talking about right but his
response is very genuine and it's such a
such an empowering statement other young
players should really take note of that
like there was no excuses coming out of
that statement he was like no this is me
playing the games and i'm learning
lessons i made mistakes or not right but
it's nothing to do with statements that
magnus carlsen would make and i i really
like that and if i may point out from
from the side i really enjoyed that
interview that it was well conducted as
much as i hate complimenting you
uh so that was a lot of fun but the way
that he approached game review at one
point you asked him about early
conclusions that he could draw yeah and
his response was basically you know this
this and this but my main learning
experience is going to come when i come
back home and review the games and i
think this is a good lesson for
you know certain players of teenage
years who think that they have
everything figured out and that they
know everything after the game is played
you know if a 2800 needs to come back
home and reflect deeply on his games
you know that kind of modesty and and
humility i think is a big ingredient for
success and i mean specifically how it
relates to today's game he was like he
he had an inaccuracy in the opening and
danny and i were like we don't really
know what what the theory is and he said
that small mistake yeah that really is
consequential at this high level and so
uh you know those are the types of
mistakes and types of games where you
really have to dive deep at home because
just by looking at the evil by the
little swing that doesn't tell you why
the mistakes happen how you can improve
your thought process going in and
alireza is a phenomenal player he's
extremely humble and he's a tennis fan
so that makes me like him even more yeah
that was awesome and he said i like when
he said like little mistakes like but
you know these things matter like yeah
like
anyway he clearly
clearly uh and it's great to see him in
good spirits and uh who knows what that
does if he catches fire like we said
jana palmer she playing him you saw what
he said there he didn't he didn't even
do like the the sports thing was like
i'm gonna focus on the next game he's
like i'm looking we brought it up here
for those who don't know our studio he
saw it he's like well
the yondapan machine game is the one
that i want right he wants revenge and i
didn't want to harp on it but he also
lost to jan in the previous tournament
in the grand chess tour so he's lost two
games in a row in the last month to
yonder palmishi and so i think revenge
is on his mind because you're losing
once happened you still want to win
losing twice in a row can't be three
speaking of losing twice in a row yeah
unfortunately as we look at
an awesome player another star of the
future get used to seeing a very happy
young christophe duda because right now
that might be uh
the saddest young christophe we've seen
in the event
he's been in console well the last two
games yeah it honestly hurts to see
players like this because the amount of
energy that's expended at the board over
hours and hours and hours of play yeah
and then to just you know there's no one
to blame but yourself it's what alareza
was saying right when you play chess
it's your responsibility the entire game
is up to you and so for duda he's
probably just like kicking himself
two days in a row this is awful you know
the rest days tomorrow that sounds great
except for the fact that i'm at the
bottom of the standings determines not
going my way it's a huge stage and there
are never any guarantees that you make
it back to the candidates of course yan
chistop duda is strong enough to any
time an event happens
yanchez stop dude it belongs at the top
but there's no guarantee you make it
back other players who are higher rated
than yanchezira lavon ironian wesley so
shakur and mama jarov anish giri they're
not playing here they didn't qualify so
you look at this tournament and you
don't want to put too much pressure on
yourself as alireza was saying but
there's never any guarantee that you
make it back oops
it's so true in fact
so many times people ask us you know
or maybe don't follow the chess worlds
closely uh
not that they don't know that the
players in this event you know would be
maybe good matches for magnus carlsen
but they ask questions like well who
would who would you rank as people you'd
want to see in a match and as i go
through around the world sometimes i
realize the players who i maybe would
love to see in a world championship
match aren't even in the candidates
right because of how grueling and
complicated at times the system is and
and how unlucky you can get
and uh one more point this how many
candidate sermons has maximum qualified
for
zero actually yes he played in one
because we're java dropped out yeah oh
yeah that's why you thought you were
going to catch me and i actually knew
the answer and i don't mean that to no
it's true to say anything about maxine
we're friends and he's an amazing player
but that just goes to show how difficult
it is maxine vachelagrav was above 2800
right yep he has been at the top of the
chess world for a very long time but the
path to qualification is just that
difficult that daunting of a task so for
a player like yan chistop i mean
he's very young he's exceptional but i
guess part of it is like well this is my
one shot i want to make the most of it
and it's really getting out of hand yeah
i mean the last thing i'd say is that uh
and again not not to keep tacking on but
let's not forget that jan
schistov beat magnus the world cup so i
think that he seriously thought
uh that he that he has a chance against
magnus in a potential match and you know
he's beaten him before he knew he can do
it again and to see your chances dash
like this in the span of two days
it's it's inexpressibly painful yep
assuming he loses this one which i think
is
maybe not a totally bygone conclusion or
is it just hopeless well i guess we
could
dive into the is that what we do
analyze those options i guess we could
do it
mm-hmm and um there's a pawn that can be
captured right you can take that pawn on
f3 but i think
dingleren's point is after the trade
then when white plays the move a7 over
here
it feels like you can't keep this king
boxed in forever and the bishop will
first leave maybe to c4 then this king
can start running up the board and
i feel like there's a way to try to
trade the bishops in the long diagonal
so that you can end up promoting and the
black king being cut off is really
important
yeah and if you ever don't have two
defenders on the a8 square
then rook c8 check comes followed by a
queen
so
black's pieces are are tied down as as
powerful as they are on these squares
they're tied down which is why you can't
really stop these things bishop will
come here the king will start to enter
and then you'll have other problems so
taking f3 is not ideal probably bishop
d5 is the move that
i would play to keep the pieces on the
board
now there's this bishop c4 resource with
a white thing played up three
or one of the reasons he played f3 now
after bishop takes before rook takes c4
amazingly there's no way to win the pawn
on e6 without dropping the knight
because if you play 92 check white
simply shifts the king probably tap one
yeah you don't want to give that point
yeah okay you're just testing my
tactical tactical vision well i wasn't
even sure at first but then after taking
with check you can't attack the knight
because the knight gets to go to a
protected square of a check or king e3
that's a good point otherwise
anyway but you're right king of one
simple that is trapped easy does it
and white goes on to win
yep
yeah i think it's so
what else can you do
you can take with the bishop because
then if you take with the knight
yeah i think things are gonna should
likely do that mate
so if you take with the bishop actually
white has to find another move besides
bishop besides taking the bishop and
it's why f3 is played to begin with
bishop c4 now rook a1 would be a
checkmating idea if that pawn were back
on f2
so by playing f3 you jettison the pawn
so your king has an escape route and now
e6 is going to fall a7 is still a
possibility and the bishop one f3 is
under attack to begin with
so judah ultimately decides he is just
going to take the pawn on f3 with the
knight
dingley run immediately follow suit
after bishop takes f3
likely a7 you could also maybe
maybe play bishop c4 first actually i
like that yeah
attack the rook in the pawn first thing
a7 also winning of course too but this
this may be even better
and if you try rogue g2 check and rook
takes h2 the point being
ultimately trying to give up the bishop
for the apon and trying to get to the f
pawn
because if a7 then i thought maybe rook
f4 rook h4
ah because if you get another pawn you
can give up your bishop no problem can
the evolvers
laughing at me because of this move and
then here
but then g5
there's going to be some sort of trick
rook takes f4
there's uh bishop takes e6 check and if
king f8 is it rook f7
yeah you trade oh because you win the
bishop on f3 yeah and if you try to play
g4 so you keep your bishop in place i
played bishop h5 then i take on g4 next
move and then i pre-move bishop f3 i
just get my pre-movement you play bishop
h5 whatever i do i can also play king h8
instead of king f8
in this position
of work f7 oh still yeah still work f7
yeah once the rooks come off it's just
it's a very constructive idea yeah yeah
that shows you in an end game it's not
how many past pawns you have here black
has two white has one it's who gets a
queen first in white's pawn of course
miles ahead and that race to the finish
line
so uh
we're in spain kilometers ahead right
i'm sorry kilometers ahead
in fact i was running on the treadmill
the other day and i was very confused
about what was going on with man i'm
running fast i was
of course it was also an espanol and i
was trying to bounce around to different
settings and before you know it
it's not a treadmill it's a tread
kilometer i got lost
in the interface
but you you made it through i made it
through you survived the treadmill in
the spanish gym
i sure did
shout out to the hotel gym by the way
it's pretty good
um
all right thinking
i think that uh we'll see a little bit
of thinking here for a while so we're
gonna take a quick break
when we come back there is still one
game that we are going to see through to
the finish line of course as dingley
wren tries to get his a pawn across the
finish line and take this one home so
don't go anywhere we will be back with
more of our continued coverage for round
nine of the 2022 feeding candidates from
madrid
do you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
i was told by the locals of a chess
school and there's people out there we
should go we should go while they're
opening the door for us let's go let's
go school of chess don't cost nothing
judging traffic
a game as old as chess itself
and half as dangerous
this is the most dangerous part of our
career
game on gotta give the people what they
want
game one keep going don't stop
so we tell them that chess education
gives you better life decisions as we
get hit by a car crossing the road in a
non-crosswalk
at 5 20.
5 20. what's home we got
starts
dude did you just stay and crash of all
the places we could film in spain the
fact there's going to be a class and
we're here
we can film other stuff but we got to
stay for that yeah i agree people say
crashing weddings is fun we're crushing
a school
if the chess is not taking place
check it out flamenco dancing huh you
think of what i'm thinking you want to
be my part are there partners in
flamenco we're not even graffiti a
building we're like trying to help local
kids and yet somehow i see this going
poorly
being at the public courts and like
federer comes
but we are walking quickly i heard the
word
and i was like no security mike leave me
not yeah
the police knob but we gotta go
you know they obviously kind of knew
that we were
you know we kind of knew we were a big
deal they opened up their arms and so
this is why when we were kids our dad
told us to say open sesame
yeah which gets you into the building
but if you say open ahadres you do not
get into you don't get in the village no
no it's open sesame you gotta remember
that
dad was right i play a lot of it yes i
love it you could have gotten us into
the building you play on chess.com yes
of course do you know who that is
no
you don't need to no you just need to
use the app he's the face of chess.com
do you have a diamond membership no
that's like the paid membership yeah no
i'll give it to you
seriously yeah for now you get a
peccatina there you go
so just
next time you're on the site just send a
message to support and say i met danny
in spain
say i met danny and danny said he would
i could get a diamond membership okay
all right i love your work okay i love
your work thank you bye-bye so it's
funny danny we were sold a bill of goods
they flew us here to do real work yeah
and i realized our entire job is just to
go around getting out of the stickers
honestly let's oh well there you go i
can't even do that well
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
[Music]
did you know you can watch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
just how old is civilization in madrid
that was a good question actually from
chat oh you were asking rhetorically
well chat asked
if only we had some history majors in
the room yeah but
yeah chad asked how old civilization was
and i i thought we're going to ignore
because none of us know right none of us
know i mean i don't know
how old civilization is in madrid i know
it's old
because i said it in the video
second half of the ninth century
according to wikipedia
thank you for looking at huh now we
gotta use something by
you know professor at a second grade
school like yale
wikipedia is not reliable
well that's new information it depends
on how old the people watching are if
their kids don't use wikipedia right for
adults it works yeah exactly
uh all right well
we've had quite the day we've had a lot
of fun we had a great interview with all
the reservoirs if you missed it you're
gonna want to check that thing out i'm
sure the team is already working on
putting it into its own vaude which is a
video on demand for those who don't
speak french
almost as old
as a man named hess that's right
uh can't spell chess without hess
uh but um yeah was that one of those
jokes or they just call me old uh chat
said it i didn't say it no i i i read it
yeah well i mean where's my shaman when
you need him
in my shyamalan movie
that i haven't seen because i stopped
watching his movies a long time don't
watch that movie
i only watch m day showing milan
oh jesus oh gosh come on
you don't always have to force them when
they're bad
[Laughter]
all right well sometimes you have to
force yourself to focus on a bad
position what a transition if you're
young christoph duda you got no choice
when it comes to both this game and the
one before it
and uh
again it's one of those things that as
the legacy builds for different players
in their career and they look back you
know who we're looking at a player who
as you said robert he may not get into
the candidates again it's
you think he will but he'll definitely
be playing in top level tournaments for
years to come we'll be seeing him on
camera and you know you remember moments
like this you remember times where they
you know they learned they grew whatever
the struggles were that you know put you
off form sometimes it's just that you're
playing the best players in the world
which is what you're doing at the
candidates you know with tons of
motivation as alireza said right
but at the same time um
[Music]
it hurts for all the many many fans in
poland to see
no wait no that was not the movie the
move what no it was with the b5 okay ggt
error yeah that was because that was so
obviously the wrong one you had bishop
takes you for a draw
i think for some people it would be
tempting well the thing is like because
it had a deflection idea of a8 i thought
for a second what what but we just show
it we should show it actually there's a
there's a reason why for a brief second
because the point is as i pointed out
earlier both of these pieces have to eye
the a8 square otherwise we have a queen
so as bad as this move is there is this
crazy point that you can't take with the
rook because you take and distract the
bishop and then get a queen
and if you take with the bishop
i have this check
and then i can actually get a queen
and and you actually win the exchange
but the point is even this is no good
because now black is actually holding
down the exchange in an end game despite
the fact that you won the rook quote
unquote uh but okay so that's why for a
second right i was like wait did you
play bishop c4 just blunder but no
instead he played bishop to b5
super instructive though right because
deflection tactic is one that people
should know about yeah and many of you
would be tempted saying i have a rook my
opponent is a bishop in just one pawn i
have more material i should win that
game but the problem is there are not
enough pawns remaining so the bishop can
defend the pawns along with the king and
there's no way for white to
win so i think that what ding is looking
for is how do i get my bishop to
challenge the opposing bishop that's one
idea the other idea is rook takes b5 is
obviously a threat here but it wouldn't
be a threat if in response to rook takes
b5 you could take the black bishop so
rook d7 like kind of following right
black's bishop is definitely a viable
option because how is that bishop going
to escape it will move off of its
current square remaining on the h1a
diagonal but then the e6 pawn becomes a
quick target i go bishop c4 so i change
the diagonal of my bishop but the thing
is black can actually try to take on b5
and go for a fortress construction rook
takes e5 and and now rook takes d5 and
i've been trying to figure out
i'm pretty sure this is winning but this
might be practically speaking jan's best
chance
oh wow how easy is this to win is the
question
i guess queen b7 check
yeah this is one of those positions
where it's very easy like i did to
assume it would just be a win but then
you have to go
a step further and i think the problem
for
for black
is this e6 one's gonna fall and then
very likely i can end up trying to
sacrifice my queen yeah you're rooking a
pawn at some point yes yeah so we're
going to get this position king g7
probably okay well whatever i'm just
trying to show the
constructive point that
this is not so easy to break down and if
i guess the reason black wants to put
the rook into 5 five she didn't want h5
right so
so actually here you play king g7
because the rook on the fifth rank
prevents any shenanigans at the pawns
white has to now defend the f pawn and
then maybe advance the king and robert
already called the idea that at some
point you might have a point where the
queen can sacrifice itself
and go into a winning king upon ending
to break down the blockade but it's it's
not simple right you shouldn't just take
for granted that that's an easy win it's
definitely winning but ding i think is
spending a little bit of time just
making totally sure of that yeah because
you can imagine how upset someone would
be if they just i got a queen you only
have a rook in one pond and then you
realize that there is a fortress
configuration which does happen with
this kind of pawn structure and the rook
so uh ding he's about to grab a piece he
could also just bring his bishop back if
he doesn't want to deal with those
calculations right he could just bring
his bishop yeah he does he went rook d7
you know what's crazy if he wins this
game then all three decisive games will
have come from people who are winning
their first game of the tournament yeah
yeah
which is
we we said that this would not be uh
you know
a a
boring back half of this event right
these players want to win
dingley wren wants his mojo back
right
he really does you can keep your money
and your mojo
and i'll get your baby
it's awesome powers
oh okay that's i thought it might have
been
i was going to continue with it and i
realized i probably shouldn't have no
other references that's as far as you go
referencing that particular character
[Laughter]
oh gosh but so what's not to say about
all these players getting their first
victory
is that means that yon napomnishi pogba
karwana despite the fact that they can't
play each other anymore
that they have to be
on the lookout alareza sat here and told
us he's like oh i'm really
really anticipating a fun game against
yonder palmishi and while that should
make fabulous car want happy because it
makes him feel like he's a chance those
same players are going to challenge him
right nobody is giving anybody a free
point here so
as we see jan chisholm even him right he
is
going to in all likelihood lose this
game he'll be at the bottom of the
standings but in any round he can beat
any player as we've been discussing
playing spoiler right not exactly the
way we use that term sometimes in other
sports because these players also have a
lot to play for outside of just an
individual season difference between
chess in some ways and and
traditional mainstream sports a lot of
people follow is there's a start and an
end to the emotional rollercoaster that
is a season right you always start fresh
they always say every every baseball
team comes to spring training with a new
hope right you love the baseball
reference but it doesn't matter the
sport you know what i'm saying right and
and when it ends even if it didn't go
all the way to what you wanted to
winning a super bowl or an nba
championship
sons
there's no but it really is important
for chess players there's always
something they're playing for because of
the career they're building their elo
ranking matters not just for their
individual standing it's not a vanity
number directly affects your livelihood
and your invites to the top tournaments
yeah right you're obviously trying to
constantly work through
the the strengths and weaknesses in your
game to be on form for the next
opportunity right and these days there's
so much cash money just in the game
online and offline that these guys have
a lot to play for and i think that
that's
you know sometimes you could argue that
the global storyline to chess
you know except for the world
championship doesn't have enough
climactic moments right because you can
lose your way but for the individual
players and their opportunity to play in
big events they're not going to roll
over just because things aren't going
their way because the season never ends
yeah they need those rating points
because most chess turbans for better or
for worse likely for worse are round
robins
that means that there is a finite number
of invitations and if you start dropping
your rating and other players are higher
rated they are more likely to invite the
players with the bigger number yep as
they're elo yep
so no one wants to go into a complete
freefall here right and especially when
you've been struggling to find your form
maybe as a guy like dingley wren isn't
quite as
high-ranking as he once was
like we said he wants his mojo back and
now he's found the plan you can tell how
quickly he played that move king of one
and i'll just highlight this real quick
for everyone because the bishop and rook
said it a few times share the
responsibility of gatekeeping the a8
square that means they can't keep
everything else on the board at the same
time right and for example the white
king being cut off it's only a matter of
time
before the king gets in a spot where
black has to choose either keep an eye
on the a pawn
or keep an eye on the king he'll
obviously keep an eye on the a-pawn and
that's when the white king can start
coming forward at some point and that's
why it is as what we say inevitable at
this point
right mr anderson inevitable and uh the
computer would agree that's why it gives
a plus five advantage so
yeah that's understanding it because the
engine and can be short-sighted in such
positions yeah like in reality the game
is just
plus five plus eight
you know i would rather reason in terms
of like it's over black has zero counter
play black has to shuffle his rook among
the a file and white just gets his king
to the right spot trades bishops and
wins yeah
all right well as white shuffles as king
we're going to shuffle our way over to
an interview as dina bellankaya caught
up with the tournament leader yon
napomnishi let's get his thoughts
feelings and all the things he had to
say after holding serve if you will
against the man chasing him here at the
2022 feed a candidates
jan
congratulations on such an important uh
opening preparation storm safe
when did you realize you were um
calming things down
i think after 93 uh okay actually after
he took on five because i thought it's
like bishop f1 on bishop c2 but both was
very promising for it and
i mean at first i just didn't see this
idea like that the bishop can just
retreat from d3 i thought okay bishop f5
and then okay on this line if 93 and
it's a draw
but once we came to this position i
realized that okay
he is not obliged to take on f5 and this
appears to be very suspicious so i mean
okay but
uh what i did was
as it seemed to me more or less only
moves after after i played this 96
because i ran into queen e4 which is
extremely unpleasant and i believe if
not queen a4 it's like maybe slightly
worse for black but it can just
stabilize like knight c7 i don't know
bishop f6 g6 something like this he has
a very solid position
but yes and i also couldn't recall any
of my prep because surely i have some
but yeah i just decided to play you know
on my own
which
uh
i think was not the optimal way
now having played fabi
will your sleep be better approaching
the five next
rounds uh i hope so but uh
i mean in general attention is uh
you know it never goes away until the
last round so it's
it's still extremely tense
right and once again congratulations and
uh good luck
thank you
interesting stuff there yonda pomnishi
did see
the move that either fabiano didn't we
don't know we don't we haven't seen an
interview with fabi yet
but either way as this game plays out we
got to talk about that interview guys
because again if if john saw bobby's
idea
for bishop of one and just said that
that was
a tough position for him it continues to
come back to like
where did that game slip for fabi i mean
there was a moment where i legitimately
thought he was about to win and bring
this thing to a tie what what what what
do you think bobby miscalculated there
we're looking at each other quitting
yeah i don't know how else to ask the
question you know what it's just like
what happened right john knew it was
trouble and bobby lost the threat
somewhere question is a completely
legitimate one and what surprises me if
fabi had played very quickly right if he
had grabbed on f5 because he thought the
position was simple that would be one
thing but he took over the course of two
moves something like 35 or 40 minutes
yeah so it really surprises me the
level of his miscalculation it wasn't
some move nine moves into a line it was
a findable move knight d3 that he
clearly overlooked or
seriously underestimated so
fabi i think is going to be really
really disappointed in the fact that he
took all this time and yet didn't seem
to be able to find
a relatively straightforward reputation
in a position which
you know he converts more times than not
and jan was completely transparent he
said that i forgot my opening i'm sure i
have a file on this line can remember it
queen a4 came as a bit of a surprise to
me because otherwise i was okay and then
he knew he was worse he would have
played bishop f1 and i don't know what
it is that fabi didn't see i mean
there's a lot to calculate in those
variations as we're discussing live but
for
fabiano i mean that was the moment that
was a moment where he really could have
put the test to yonda pamashi
and jan as we just saw in the interview
he was like my position was bad
i don't know what i was gonna
do mom's spaghetti
he missed his moment right i mean
seriously it might have been his one
shot to get back in this event he missed
it that being fabiano caruana
and uh of course as we've said there's
so many matchups coming up we'll
actually bring up yonder ponies
head-to-heads remaining as we've watched
dingley run try to convert on his
advantage against young christoph duda
but you know you're relying on other
players yeah
you look at that game where he's black
against faruja we interviewed the young
man who got his first victory today
that's certainly one that could be scary
for yon
but if if unfortunately duda continues
to struggle the the last the last game
may not be
one that necessarily makes yon scared so
getting white in the other games okay
report
that's a wild card right you never know
what you're going to get there um but
your thoughts on now that he has a full
point lead
that he can he take kind of a safe
approach and take this one home that's
exactly what i was wondering and the big
question to me is the next game against
timur
because
you know timur isn't i don't even want
to call him like the underdog or the
dark horse in this term like he's 27.50
for goodness sake he just beat ikaru
um and that might make it more tempting
for jan to play in the same vein that he
did against ding i don't think he's
going to be quite as drawish in his
approach
but with a full point lead
um and fabby struggling
uh in the last two games i think it
you know i think he'll definitely
consider the option
of playing ultra solid chess robert but
or do you feel like he'll try to
basically end the tournament here and
now so he doesn't have to worry about
performing on demand in the last couple
of games well i think the reason he
didn't really play
a game if we want to be honest against
dingley red is dingley wren is the
number two or number three player in the
world depending on what the current
ratings are so he says all right that's
a really tough opponent let's just
conserve energy for today's game against
faviano imagine if yon played a six hour
game yesterday against england they drew
anyway right and then he had to fend off
that preparation today he might have
been exhausted and unable to do so so as
i look at the remaining pairings i'm
circling round 11 against ali reza who
we just had in the studio who by his own
admission is hungry to beat
yonda pamishi he gets the black piece
against alireza so with round 11 being a
big question mark i think you need to
press against hijab maybe play in the
style that rijaba did today against
ikaru we never really felt like timor
was at risk of losing and he was playing
for two results from a very early stage
so i do not think you just
forced the draw i think you need to try
to put pressure on timor who probably is
in pretty decent spirits after today's
win but has struggled throughout this
event yeah
the only thing i would add to that is at
the same time he's never beaten her job
off they've never played you know they
haven't played a lot of games
um
only five in total
including a draw from earlier in this
event so if it was four coming in
but
he'll have white i agree totally he'll
he'll push
the question is how hard
and uh
and we'll see i i like your point danny
because if he gets that w
you're you're putting a nail in the
coffin right not necessarily of course
you still have to you know the games are
there for a reason
but that would be uh that would be a
monster way to bring it home so
yeah and i just had very quickly that
it's human nature to get more nervous as
the tournament progresses and moves
toward the finish line you can't leave
yourself with the situation or you don't
want to leave yourself
with a situation with your black guns
dude in the last round somebody's
trailing you by half a point and you
basically have to draw
to put it in the bag you want to have a
one and a half point lead especially
given the fact that he's already got a
one point lead right so
while his nerves are still not totally
shot it would make sense to try to put
pressure especially the white pieces in
hindsight seeing the draw would still
run i mean there's an experience factor
paying off here for yonder palm machine
just the more we talked about it we you
know we give him a little bit of
surprise we were surprised a little bit
of criticism of wow i didn't press at
all but in hindsight as you're
describing robert you're like um well
maybe he didn't want to press against
ding in particular right um but he will
press and others and that experience
yonder palmer she has also playing in
his third candidates
uh
he understands it's a marathon not a
sprint and he's got his eye on the prize
yeah and he's got three whites in the
remaining five games and fabiano caruana
who is the person chasing him right he
doesn't have the same luxury because he
had white in today's game he's gonna
have three blacks down the stretch i'm
pretty sure so for
you know that's the thing about jan
right now he's focused on his own
match-ups and he controls his destiny
but he's also probably keeping an eye on
which games is fabiano going to press
you see upcoming look at that next game
blackens duda yan also has that same
pairing in the last round but right now
dude is about to lose his second
consecutive game he's in miserable
spirits and that's a game if you're
fobbing under carwana you say i don't
care that i move second i have a three
wins zero losses against him he is in
last place here he's not playing his
best chess you need to target him yeah
no it makes sense and obviously if bobby
starts winning that changes the
storyline right you've got uh now you're
feeling the pressure every draw you get
they get a half a point closer
so yeah all right well
these head-to-heads will be the talk of
the town
uh especially if it remains
a situation where only fabiano caruana
can reasonably catch yonder pawn machine
if that should change of course you know
we'll uh we'll be talking about others
getting involved in the mix but all
right
not much has changed for duda we see him
kind of head in hand here dealing with
the plan we talked about
let's analyze a little bit just to show
everybody what is coming
down why this is so tough so let's say
black just sits i'm gonna play black and
set and one of you gets to play white
and beat me
good luck
chilly alternate moves yeah let's do it
okay go ahead you start we're analyzing
here let's bring up the analysis board
so we can show what these guys are going
to do
let's go king b1
okay
the funny thing is okay i think i
actually can go king c2
and
okay so you're gonna go to that end game
yeah yeah i think we we determined that
it should be a win okay
i'm just gonna sit tight for now just so
we can see it kind of play out and see
what white's threats are all right i'll
put my bishop on d3 i don't even want
you to be able to you know yeah if black
had given a check on e4 in the previous
move i still would have had bishop d3
okay now i'm going to play king c3
yep
and
king b4
and the point is i can't slow you down
yeah i'm gonna go probably bishop b5
first
yeah and look at white's pawns by the
way f4 and h4 there's no way for black
to play g5 even if you put upon h6
without losing a pawn yeah there's no
way to play e5 because your bishop's
hanging but even if it weren't hanging
you'd lose the pawn there so white's
pawns are actually perfectly placed
and if i sit tight
progress is just
well already bishop c4 i think ends the
game on the spot iu so at some point
you're going to get a situation where
like every rook move is going to allow a
bishop trade
well so i guess we have a really clear
plan we've established is the king
coming forward is not just
not just for the idea that i think was
also interesting which is running over
here sure right creating meeting net i
guess the simplest path is that the
moment you touch down on c4 boom goes
the dynamite
you put the bishop on the square force
the trade and then you're in an easily
winning game because of the threat of
pushing the pawn so now we've
established that it's
super important for black to keep the
king from doing that so bishop e4 is a
move to try here to try to keep you
locked in yeah just rook c7 because you
also have rook c2 check it's kind of an
idea because the king still wouldn't be
able to go to b1 because he discovered
checks so rook c7 just takes away your
only idea so king g8 for example bishop
c4 or what that looks really good oh and
then you're going after these six points
yeah i'm just gonna take e6 too many
weaknesses if i could say pass right
here you're still threatening bishop c4
yes so if the bishop moves off of d5 not
guarding e6 that's the problem is the
bishop is always threatening to come to
c4 so so again back to life game
we're establishing the pattern right if
if the bishop ever leaves d5 without
some sort of forcing threat this bishop
is coming to c4 and as we've seen
already hits the rook hits the pawn and
the game is is too much
if you eventually are forced to let the
king out of its first rank cage it's
only a matter of time before explosive
things happen on c4
we'll see how many of these things i can
fit in i've already i've got two so far
boom goes the dynamite explosive things
on c4 do you did you know that video or
did you say that because i said i do i
saw that video when it first came out oh
all right i forgot who was the idea
behind the video back with brontosaurus
who was the what the idea behind the
video what do you mean the idea behind
the video i was giving danny credit for
something he didn't do oh
okay
uh what was the name of the broadcaster
i still remember that it was a young kid
some like colleagues brian collins okay
there you go shout out i just i i was
just looking forward to the dynamite for
those who don't know what we're
referencing in chat
by the way chad if you've got questions
this is a good time to get some face
time with these three people right here
throw your questions to us and we might
have some answers a little little q a as
we help take this one home we've talked
a lot about what we know we're going to
see in the final head-to-head matchups
between yonder palmishi and the guy
trying to catch him
and fabiano carwana
and of course we will
we'll break down what we're going to see
in tomorrow sorry not tomorrow we got a
rest day right um what we're going to
see
on wednesday when play resumes here on
june 30th june 29th
in madrid but
but now's your chat
well actually we've also got an
interview
let's do that so we this is i've been
waiting for this so thank you team for
crushing it so we've seen yon napomneshi
we heard his thoughts
on the uh the battle versus fabiano
caruana and what he thought the american
could have done to keep the pressure
let's get fabi's own thoughts on his
game and the chances that he missed
i assume you might be a little
disappointed after today's game but yet
so you showed an amazing preparation do
you already know where
you didn't uh push enough
no i don't know um
i i figure knight d6 is a rather dubious
move
although it's very natural as well and
i had many options after that i thought
queen a4 was a good choice
um it wasn't my first instinct to play
queen a4 it looks rather unusual
uh but i couldn't find an advantage with
or a clear advantage with other ways and
i thought queen a4 is super dangerous
for him
and the end game i thought should be
very good for white um
i guess that
bishop takes a 5 maybe
is a mistake bishop c2 was was other
option i was considering
and um
[Music]
i just missed one detail which is after
knight d3
rookie 7 king of 6 when i saw his
position i thought i could play bishop
g5 and i missed that the knight is
hanging
and after knight d3 it just looks like a
draw um
yeah i guess bishop c2 but i wasn't sure
if it's how much of an advantage it is
it looked very promising but it's also
very very sharp it could be that
one small inaccuracy or is uh is enough
to lose advantage or
um or that you know there's like only
one path to an advantage
according to the computer the only
inaccuracy was not to play bishop f1
which
was supposed to be giving you some
advantage still and uh other than that
seemed like all your moves were perfect
yeah so that's just kind of bad luck i
guess
yeah well it it sometimes happens that
it looks very dangerous and it doesn't
really amount to much
um
like i think knight d3 is the only
drawing move if he
takes on b2 bishop d6 i think it rook c8
rookie 7 it just looked like a win
and yeah it's uh
it's by one move basically that black
draws but yeah i guess it's enough
you mentioned it was a matter of lack
in general how much the importance of
lack is in chess as a sport in your
opinion
um i mean luck balances out but it's
good to get luck at the right moments
you know
in one tournament you can be lucky in
another you can be unlucky i just these
things happen i've had both
both things where you know
everything just works in your favor and
sometimes it doesn't work in your favor
here i can't say i've been unlucky or
unlucky it's just you know i've had
some ups and downs
i also had some moments which i can say
were quite lucky and some moments which
maybe luck wasn't entirely on my side
um but yeah it's also still the
tournament has
many games to go before i draw any
conclusions
five more rounds to go
you mentioned before the tournament here
only first place matters um has the
teacher has the situation changed or is
it still
the only importance
no it's the same situation um
yeah i still have to fight for first
place it's a
point deficit
which is uh is quite a lot with five
rounds ago but it's not insurmountable
thank you so much fabi good luck in the
following games
interesting stuff there there
it was interesting robert and we were
obviously all three of us were looking
at each other during the interview there
was
a little bit of a disconnect there
clearly showing that
bobby actually didn't not only did he
not see bishop of one he didn't even
really realize the position that dino
was referring to that he when he missed
bishop of one so it tells you he's
probably looking at it now and realizing
what a big chance that was
yeah and it's not the first time he's
missed a chance against janna palmashi
yeah because we have recency bias or
we're gonna look at this game but what
about the round two game when fabinho
had the black pieces it wasn't clear
right but he had an advantage i'm sure
both players knew it at the time and
they talked about in the post-game
interviews so for fabiano if he looks
back on the tournament and he's not in
first place he's going to be like i had
two great positions against the guy who
ended up winning and i didn't convert
either of them yeah
he didn't see your bishop b1 idea either
which we know is even more obscure but
it tells you that fabi you know he said
he knew knight d6 was probably dubious
but
in hindsight it's a weird thing to say
that
despite yawn being worse
he actually had the better feel for the
position it seemed in the critical
moments
yeah i mean
you know fabi did a great job of playing
queen a4 when as by his own admission it
wasn't his
first instinct but it was interesting he
said that he thought it was the only way
to earn an advantage whereas queenie two
not to nitpick but queenie two also
yielded
uh a big advantage so there were a
couple of moments in the game where it
seems like fabby did
misjudge the position or misevaluated
and then of course a very tragic
miscalculation at the end where he
thought the knight was saying i mean
that just tells you what it comes down
to how minuscule
the details that these games the very
top level come down to and that's what
makes them so incredibly fascinating to
watch
i want to i want to come back to that
though robert because we've talked about
this before where sometimes you get out
prepared okay sometimes you get up
prepared and you made a really bad
choice and you get blown off the board
it happens right but
sometimes you get up prepared and that
puts you into a think tank you have to
struggle fall behind by an hour on the
clock but in the process of working your
way through the weeds right the dark
forest that is you know you're worse and
you're out prepared in the end when your
opponent missed the opportunity
it actually left you with maybe a better
understanding of what was going on in
the position than your opponent right
and
we talked about that practical factor
where sometimes you come with a prepared
but because you were playing with
everything you know you had at home
you never actually got
into the weeds where you needed to and i
feel like the more i now that i see both
those interviews it's exactly the story
i'm taking away from that yon young got
out booked and tricked and he was worse
but he actually knew what was going on
in in those critical moments where fabi
didn't quite have a feel for the tactics
i would say it depends on how long
fabiano has been sitting on that
preparation for because if he just
cooked it up last night then he didn't
have the time to dive in and then it
would seem that jan just
understood the dynamics a little bit
better yeah but if father's been sitting
on that prep for a long time and then
decide use it when you prepare a line
you don't just memorize a string of
moves right so uh to give credit to
fabiano you know when you you like dive
in because sometimes their preparation
doesn't actually give you an advantage
according to the engine which means that
you have to to test it out you have to
play over the board with your seconds
trying to work through the tactics work
through the consequences of certain
choices and so i think that something
apparently wasn't right in terms of well
let me try this it's less of a mark
against fabiano but more of a credit to
the fact that yon
because he didn't like he had to work to
figure it out right and that maybe made
him a little more on edge in those
critical tactical moments well he
definitely had to be on edge i just
i just don't really know how to
i mean we give jan a lot of credit for
surviving that game because many players
wouldn't they would have just toppled
over and it would have been done with uh
but i i just think that yon his
calculation function was better today i
don't think he understands necessarily
the positions better i think that just
he was really sharp today and he had a
very short day yesterday so he came in
well rested he got a rough position he
was able to survive it while calculating
his opponent's best moves and that's the
sign not just of a great player but a
great player who's in fantastic form
when they're met with something that
they weren't expecting and they know
they're worse and they're still finding
their opponent's best moves which means
he probably had some response in store
that would have left him hanging in the
game versus just collapsing yeah johnny
your thoughts on
that convo to win a tournament like the
candidates it's not enough just to show
one skill and if you look through nepo's
game so far not saying the tournament is
over it's far from over
but he's demonstrated
incredible skill in a variety of
different areas he's had crushing games
he's had good opening preparation and
astute opening choices
and now he's also had
an amazing defensive task against as
robert said a player who's super well
prepared he goes down on the clock all
of the conditions pointed to adversity
and
he demonstrated just filigree precision
and just an unwavering determination to
not lose the game they talk about in
basketball and other sports knowing how
to win you can also draw a parallel with
that and you can point to the skill of
just refusing to lose yeah i know that
sounds like a cliche and everything but
the top athletes they do that they're
down by 20 you watch them take a time
out and say i'm not losing this game and
i think jan kind of decided that for
himself that he's going to invest every
ounce of his energy he did
and he managed to outplay fabi from a
really really bad position
yeah well said interesting stuff
well
and that's a rook on a8
[Laughter]
hello camera on a8
um
can we get a queen can we get a i don't
know what we're looking at over there
but we're looking up we're backing up
we're looking at something okay we're
moving around oh there's there they know
which camera is on tv not sure they do
there we go
i guess they knew the a8 square is what
this game comes down to but oh i see oh
they're coming there we go i get it now
they were they were showing us the phone
oh
really five head
what you two didn't understand what our
producers were doing i had no idea
i had no idea i had no idea
no i i literally did not even connect
the dots
i didn't connect the dots
okay are you disappointed i'm very
disappointed not indeed i've been
commenting for nine days in a row okay
no you haven't done rest days
nine rounds over 11 days
12 if you include the opening ceremony
which was exhausting for me i was
dancing my heart out flamenco style nice
no excuses would make up for the fact
that you two just i did i just i just
gapped it i was like a8 there's a rook
and actually that's kind of cool that's
got it coming down to aa and we've got a
uh
nifty little
coincidence there with the design
the official feed a design of the we
call them uh what do we call brand
boards when you put all the logos up
everyone loves a good brand board
something very sad in this position well
everything's kind of sad wait i think i
know what you're gonna say yeah the e5
doesn't work
which is just you know your only try
hey there's a question okay i don't know
about this username but
i i don't
i don't like straws straws are a waste
uh bad for the environment i avoid
straws wherever and all possible
although i do have kids so because of
that i appreciate the value of a good
sippy cup and a child proof ability to
spill
and if that comes with a reusable straw
then i am all in
on straws
this is great keep them coming
um thank you chad sorry let's show this
line yeah
e5
hey the end game magician dingley wren
right
just subscribe
at the same time
all right e5 go ahead take it
and after rook takes e5 there's bishop
c6
which may look like a problem with a
rook c5 check yeah but you just move
your king anywhere and after bishop
takes c6 rook takes e6 the worst part
for black is after you take this rook a
it equals queen with check and also
check to the rook because this is the
exact type of position where black could
have a fortress if this rook were over
an f7 you can just shake hands the game
would be yeah that's good to show if
white doesn't take it i wonder i was
just going to say are we going to get a
table-based draw and that shows you so
obviously that's not the case as robert
said you get a queen with sorry you get
a queen with check and that's winning
but that shows you if you didn't if you
didn't take it
don't take the rook although apparently
you're still winning on that move there
must be some check that follows that
keeps the rook trapped but if you make a
bad move with the queen it is a
table-based jaw after the rook can come
over here and protect everybody this is
a fortress queen cannot break down the
rook and pawns so yeah right so if you
as your bishop c6 in this variation here
if you take it on c6 and they aha i'm
gonna stop your pawn after rook takes c6
rook a5 allows rook ca check and we get
a queen and we're up a rook we win and
if rook to e8 after the capture you've
worked b6 to be and this is i think
for people who are really new to the
game who haven't seen end games before
when you're trying to promote a pawn
against an enemy rook that's what you
need to do is put your rook on the
square that the pawn protects and that
way you cut off the rook from the
promotion square
roof to
v8
no way to stop
a new queen either way
yeah that's why pawn's capturing
diagonally is such a genius rule yeah
because it adds this entire new wrinkle
to the
game an element
every element of chess that uh adds all
those different dynamics what makes it
the unsolvable puzzle that is
the game of kings
question for me is donya actually not
seen frozen
no i have not
there's no random movie do you know what
the movie frozen is no
is it a musical
well actually the answer to that
question is yes it became a musical it
did become i've heard it's a disney
movie you know let it go
i've only seen maybe three or four
disney movies i've seen mulan
i've seen the live video in the original
one
the live action you just call it aladdin
it's aladdin a lot yeah i'm aladdin yeah
i'm on thin ice here yeah aladdin mulan
and i think that's it but the live
action one the recent one or the one no
the old one the animated robin williams
can you stay for dinner can he stay
forever no the one which i'll make a man
out of you and all those famous songs
yeah oh man
so dania hasn't seen frozen
that's right do you like our job i like
it
i'm not gonna answer this question
right that's a minefield okay it depends
the moment we all love our jobs i mean
seriously the man who holds my job in
his hands sitting next to me so i don't
hold my your job in my hands
don't look at me i think we all love our
jobs uh i would argue that the job of a
chess commentator is
maybe the hardest job in sports
broadcasting
i said it it doesn't mean it's the job
with the biggest upside or whatever but
i can unpack that statement if you want
how do you think you do it for to play
in this tournament well the only peril
that i can possibly draw is the us
championship
which i played in this past october i
think i scored
minus two i also think it was
significantly weaker than the candidates
i don't think i'd lose all my games
you wouldn't lose all your games i think
that i would
try if i had played in this tournament
my expectation for myself would probably
be like
minus two or minus three would be a very
decent result
um
but yeah i would kill for such an
opportunity obviously
but i get put through the meat grinder
no question about it
what are your favorite candidates
moments you have witnessed wow there's
many actually got history um
the last round 2013 the drama of that
obviously magnus carlson lost his last
game and ultimately sort of
backdoored his way into winning the
event regardless
when kromnic also went down um that was
an incredible incredible finish drama
that might just be the best canon moment
ever yeah it was just amazing can you
say that again which one match 2013
candidates when magnus lost in the last
week we lost the last round but
chucky
came through and beat the crowd i
remember watching that as a fan and just
being like everybody wanted magnus to
take on vichy magnus was the
the rising star at the time right and he
was the number one player in the world
for two years already right and kramnik
who had obviously lost the title to
vichy anand was this close to getting
another chance at the rematch and
uh
both magnus and kron mc going down
allowed magnus they didn't have tie
breakers then so magnus won on tie
breaks that was that was a crazy one
for danny how do you think you'd do if
you were to play in this tournament
is that a question that
how would i do i mean
if i
drew
one of my games
you'd be running around madrid it would
turn off in your hands
i'd be going i'd be streaking through
the gymnasium you could bring your green
hat okay i would be
going nutty no i mean okay but if you're
if you're prepared for months and months
and you play the white pieces you hope
you can get a few draws but the reality
is like
i'm not in the league of these players i
i don't know that any of us are but i am
on the lowest league
here so thank you for the question
and the troll the trollish attitude that
comes with that so
but uh we i love my job i want to go
back to that chess commentating is hard
just because of the pure i mean again
compare this to the length of any sports
broadcast
we are going on
you know seven and a half hours eight
hours at times we had a ten and a half
hour broadcast for game six of the world
championship if you had to bet what
would you guess nippo's final score and
this event will be that's a good
question
are there
i'm sure you can bet on this question
they have their mouse the ready as soon
as you say a number they're merely
clicking
let's see he has five games remaining
so drawing every game would get him two
and a half points more he would finish
at eight and a half
um there's a nine
oh sorry he went in today with six
you're right i'm sorry so he would
finish at nine
um
if you drew all his games if he drew all
his games which
i don't know at this point if fabiano
starts getting wins and that pressure i
mean that's a really good question i
mean because we're kind of predicting
what we think is going to happen in the
event by predicting history all right
that's that's that's question is really
there's a question that i refuse to
answer and i wish our production team
didn't put on screen why because it like
puts us in an uncomfortable spot where
like now we'd say oh yawn's going to
lose a game and then it's like
based on what we're just like
speculating but we're predicting results
if you look at his results that's why i
don't like predictions in general yeah
yeah yeah i mean uh singing
is okay yeah over a course of five games
because then if we say oh he's gonna go
three out of five who's he gonna beat
and then we had to pick somebody but
it's like because the strengths are so
close even when you're in really good
form you have no basis on which to
predict a particular result i think
none at all it's not like inside
information
no no then what's his final score going
to be
i think his final score will be nine and
how is he going to get there all draws
all draws okay see that's the safe
answer that's the realistic issue no but
that's also a safe answer right you if
you said minus or plus something then
you have to pick who's pushed back i
think there's a high likelihood that he
plays at least one decisive game i don't
know against whom or win or lose
but i think that's the realistic thing
even if he wins or loses one game
is that he gets nine and he wins the
tournament
that's the most
likely result
an even score
i mean right now obviously we want drama
i'm not rooting for or against yon but i
think that predicting a 50 result
given given what we've seen is probably
the strategy he'll take
by the way we saw that last question
which was
dude looked at that extra score she's
like i don't think i'll be needing that
we saw the last question which is how do
we think the cameraman would do in the
tournament depends on which camera man
we do have some strong cameraman's
[Laughter]
gear holding a camera
what's that we do have uh i think i
think our camera operator today is about
a 2100 chess player
so
it
makes me feel like maybe i would do
better than the cameraman at the very
least
man dude i looked at the scoresheet what
move are we on no he does need it right
one more move
there's one other thing about chess
commentary which is that you know we get
some breaks but we don't have like
commercials every you know
25 minutes as during a sports game
yeah so
also it's just you know it's a it's a
job right now that you know obviously is
maybe maybe going to continue to grow
we're hoping to as as maybe chess events
and the uh
you know
their reach
and influence continues to to go to
higher higher platforms that's obviously
part of chess.com's goals and of course
a lot of other chess companies websites
organizations trying to do the same so
but the thing is like it's there's so
many other reasons i could add to it
like
people doing hours of commentary are not
doing just play-by-play they like and
adding context but then also eight hours
of it and then also doing the post-game
interviews like usually mike breen
doesn't also interview the coaches after
the game or the players after the game
right like that's something that right
now the our world and what we're doing
here is very young i mean chess
broadcasting
as a visual product let alone the
product that we're watching on screen
might be very different within a few
years there's also complete information
in chess right there's nothing to hide
there's no
you know surprises in the same way if
players make a move that we don't expect
sure but in basketball when a team
scores you're like okay that team scored
the other team's gonna try to score back
you can't map it out and chess we can
explain here's how we got to this
position here's why this all happened
here's what's going on now our
assessment here's what we think should
happen and then we continue exploring
all these variations and so with all
that information in front of us it
requires us to talk a lot yeah in a way
that if you're watching a basketball
game they'll explain this pick and roll
i mean we love basketball no no offense
to mike green bang sorry i love
basketball and i really respect uh
the best commentators i wouldn't say all
of them but right
you know there's a lot of great ones out
there but the point is that they don't
have to be on edge every single to
explain things and i mean we could also
not explain things
that that works for me right no but it's
true right and uh and also because chess
is hard to understand but we want it to
be relatable
everything you just said robert is not
only complete information but it's also
something we feel like we need to do to
make it understood right we're so it's
it's just a it's an exhausting process
yeah i mean i have the last name i do
you know you're you're born into this
you have no choice in the matter no and
you got to make it understandable to
newer players but also engaging for like
a gm who's going to be watching the
coverage
so the range of people that you have to
appeal to is super super vast
and you know i i really struggled with
when i first started coming and it's
always a journey like sometimes i say
something and i'm like yeah i you know
thinking back somebody who's maybe newer
to the game had no chance of
understanding what i just said and
you know that keeps the feedback loop
going
but sometimes the body language makes it
very clear how the game is going to end
if you've never seen a chessboard yeah
and it's kings and keep going five
bishops he said that king was on g1
it went around
to the on the first rank
and then now it's going up
the first file
no
ah that's all i'm gonna say on the
matter is that to the think or the hope
or both
don just not a fan of fisher random no
i'm not at all why i love fishing road
me too i don't like it what's funny is a
lot of players are very split on this
okay well i mean i can talk about this
for a long time but the long and the
short of it is
there's two things i point out first is
i feel like chess itself is still
an incredibly rich game
and i feel like it is overdoing it to
change the game so drastically like i
feel like if you really really wanted
variants of chess you could make more
organic changes such as like no castling
chess is interesting but i'm still not
not even a big fan of that
and the second thing i'd say is that i
think there's an inherent maybe i'm
being a gatekeeper like i'm being too
old-fashioned i feel like there's a
certain amount of chest beauty that
inherently stems from the arrangement of
the pieces that produces tactics and
openings that lend the game
the sort of aesthetic appeal that it has
and when i play fisher random i always
find that i'm just less into
the tactics
that arise i feel like less beautiful
ideas arise
when you
randomly shuffle the starting position
of the pieces i'm not saying it doesn't
have a place to exist yep we have a
civilization by the way but i don't like
it
that's a good question what is fisher
random someone give that guy a link in
chat uh so that he can see exactly what
don you just went on a rant about it's
also referred to as chess 960 on
chess.com
uh i think robert would have some
counter arguments as to the pros
official random but we're not going to
get into it right now we don't need to
we have a victory for dingley wren uh
john kristoff resigns because as we said
the king
the king made a journey let's uh remind
the path of that didn't stop believing
danny didn't stop believing no matter
what and uh eventually the king arrived
away at the final destination which was
we're gonna we're gonna eventually kick
this rook and as we kept saying at some
point you will see this diagonal
uh dingle smile unguardable and and the
a8 queen will arrive so yeah ding was
smiling he was happy and
i keep saying this now round after round
after his loss to yon napomshi it felt
like ding not just was capable of
getting a victory but almost like he'd
earned one if you look across the games
and looked at his advantages yep like i
don't remember him being in trouble
since then but i do remember him on the
edge of a win and now he finally gets
his first one so he knows that he's far
behind in the standings he's two points
behind yon napomishi but you know he
loves chess he wants to play good chess
he does interviews even when he's
disappointed with his results i know
everybody loves dingley wren but about
the chess itself he has been playing
high quality chess but not scoring the
results that would indicate that yeah i
agree with everything you just said it's
exciting and we've every interview we
have with him we just go who doesn't
love daily wren and by the way
look at where he sits in the standings
again he's you know
like everyone else
chasing chasing not just john upon
richie but probably under caruana but
okay like what a huge win that was
for the top player from china
and uh
his candidates chances are not gone at
this time and he also gets gets another
crack at fabiana carwana he doesn't get
another crack at yondu palmishi
but okay three of the people
ahead of him
he still has to play two of them so he
has some chances to shake up the
standings
well jan has a big fat x on his
background yeah every single player yeah
wants to either beat him the players who
don't play him want him to lose
i mean every
shake-up of the tournament standings
starts with beyond to bonnie she losing
so
that's what everybody is going to try to
achieve and for players like ding and
hikaru they're obviously not thinking
about first place right now and hikaru's
thinking about recovering from today's
game fabi is thinking about
rediscovering his form there's going to
be a lot of
you know mental recovering and
strategizing that's going to happen on
this rest day it comes at a good time
three players got their first win at the
candidates today uh we just saw one of
them wrap up the victory versus young
christophe duda when we have a second
we'll get results up let's get up we
should recap the full results that were
round nine today because we had three of
four decisive games and those three wins
came to players who hadn't struck yet
there you go it's hard to say which one
is the most memorable right ollie rosa
ferrugia the rising star
gets his first victory in the candidates
tournament for fans wanting to see that
young man arrive he's finding his form
where javoff gets his first victory in
three bleeping years
37 classical games later
and dingley wren the number one player
from china who at one point might have
been magnus carlson's most feared
opponent
gets a dub so
i don't know i mean i know i just stole
the thunder but those are some pretty
pretty big things to happen here well we
heard in some interviews players talk
about luck and being unlucky i would say
the player who's left the most on the
table is dingley wren he's at four and a
half and a nine even score he's tied
with the cardinals
not just that game right they're just
the game against rapport like he's had
multiple moments and it just feels like
overall he's played great chess we can't
forget his draw against ikaru hikara had
really great preparation and dingley ran
every single move played accurately to
the point where at a certain moment
we're like that deep on run through
maybe he can even win this game so
dingley wren we are seeing some of the
form from him but not on the scoreboard
yeah makes sense and we often suffer
from recency bias but also the kind of
bias that comes from somebody's start of
the tournament when we think of ding we
think oh he lost that very bad first
game to yan
but that's just one game and the rest of
the tournament has been great today was
just an incredibly classy
masterful positional effort
yeah
well said
well those were the results from round
nine we will have a rest day but round
10 is coming up on wednesday the 29th we
should probably preview what those
match-ups will be remind everybody of
what's in store after the rest day and
there you have it
the fighting chest is going to continue
we had three or four decisive results
today maybe not all of them felt like
the most impactful on the standings but
if it was already over we wouldn't be
playing more games so there are still
five rounds left including round ten
and uh
i'm gonna let each of you circle your
favorite match up coming out of the rest
day
all right you're putting me on the spot
first i am really excited for nakamura
i'm gonna say i i think for sure i'm
taking the low hanging fruit here we've
only played once before yep the battle
of two generations hikaru just lost
today he's going to be angry he's going
to be motivated and ferrucci is going to
be motivated but for a different reason
because he got his first win of the
tournament so i think it's going to be a
really interesting fighting game i'm
excited for that one and it's a great
matchup of youth versus experience yeah
nakamura much has been said about his
absence from over-the-board classical
play we know that he's been playing
countless games online he's playing
title tuesday tomorrow and he always
knew what he said yeah he's definitely
playing tomorrow for your loss today oh
he's playing both of them he's also a
former number two player in the world
but
it's hard for me to say what my you know
number one match-up is i'm circling that
due to caruana match up because fabiano
despite letting an advantage slip today
he's been playing excellent chess
throughout the tournament duda has not i
mean he started off totally fine he was
even making all these draws looking like
he could be a contender but in the last
bunch of rounds he's lost three games
and he just hasn't looked like himself
and it's not just on the chess board
we've seen his mannerisms you've seen
his reactions
we often use the expression just happy
to be here he does not seem happy to be
in madrid right now yeah
i i don't i i like those two matchups as
well as far as the ones i'm super
excited about anytime report gets the
white pieces we turn our head and then
upon machine getting white will he push
will he try to put this thing away in
some ways uh getting a victory against
taymor rajab so much to talk about of
course on wednesday
and you don't want to miss it though
because we we've highlighted this
nakamura version match and we actually
we have a hikaru interview
that he just gave to dina bell and kaya
from uh downstairs after he finished his
his uh his tough loss to tame over java
i think we're going to throw that
interview up make sure that the fans
catch that before they disappear
so uh
are we are we going to the cargo
interview or not i'll break the fourth
wall
okay okay so we're getting it ready it
will be on in just a second so sorry a
little confusion there for the team
uh but there's other people involved in
the broadcasters yeah we're not just
doing i'm not just magically asking for
things and it's appearing there's a
whole group of people working super hard
you said it was ready on the
teleprompter so that one's on you guys
break the fourth wall so
uh we've got uh
anyway we have a nakamura interview
coming here in just a moment which is
always great when hikaro gives his time
after a tough loss we'll see what his
thoughts were here in just a little bit
so picaro streaming title tuesday
tomorrow by the way while we're enjoying
the rest day here in madrid that's the
chest you can be watching on hikaru's
channel just so you know
um
what are your plans for the rest today
my plans
um experiment i'm either gonna go to
sleep or i'm gonna put myself to sleep
i'm gonna i'm gonna enjoy
a little bit of rest
on the rest day um i don't have any
plans maybe i'll go to the prado museum
i highly recommend it'll be my last
chance really you should definitely go
yeah
yeah i'm proud of the i'm proud of the
fact that i've already been there once
but i think i might go again oh my gosh
all right on the note of that bad pun
it's time to see hikaru nakamura's
interview with dina bella kaya after the
tough game he had today
tough game today uh thanks for joining
anyway uh seemed like bishop g4 was your
first inaccuracy was there something you
mis-evaluated
no i mean probably
i just had the wrong mindset i was
trying to create something um try try to
catch fabiano i guess probably it wasn't
wasn't great i mean i think
i never had enough counter play for the
pawn that i gave up
maybe timor was a little bit imprecise
in the middle but i thought when he
found this idea with queen g4 and rookie
two it's very unpleasant
suspected computer could find a way to
hold it but i
was low on time and it was just probably
too difficult so yeah it's tough but
that's life
and uh in the opening you played 96 uh
did you
somehow expect uh three times repetition
or would you still refuse
no i mean i didn't expect that one
actually the the thing is i mean just my
whole evaluation was off because i spent
a lot of time looking at this bishop
takes f3 move and i i was sure the team
would actually play bishop b7 knight g4
and that is actually a draw um
and then he just took and he took on a5
and for some reason i just assumed
there's a lot of counter play but again
i mean obviously uh i'll still look at
it with a computer but to me it didn't
didn't seem like there was ever enough
so i tried to create something and
probably i mean if if i wanted to create
something i should have played a
different opening and then then you see
what happens but again at this point the
tournament everyone's trying to catch up
i mean richard also tried to be creative
and got absolutely crushed so that's
just how it goes
did you have a chance to see what was
happening in uh fabio versus jan's game
today no not really but i mean i think
at the end of the day uh there are of
course these what-if scenarios i mean
many people are saying that magnus isn't
going to play but i think all of us at
least assume that magnus will play one
when all said and done so really first
place is the only prize perhaps that
matters um
so i think that that played quite a bit
uh in quite quite a role in the game
today i mean again
uh i saw the position it looked like
fabiano had something but it was never
never conclusive to me at least when i
was passing the board so yeah it's uh
very bad i think for the tournament in
general because you know i lost richard
lost and now suddenly it's like it
literally is a
two-player tournament to the finish
yeah
interesting stuff there uh
your thoughts on what he said he tried
to create chances and maybe in hindsight
shouldn't have should have gone for that
he's never afraid to share his thoughts
and he said that i thought i i assumed
he was the word i assume
if i remember correctly that he would
have play over there on the king's side
right but this is why we say you need to
calculate and you know you could tell he
was regretful about this decision making
because he never was able to drum up
much of anything and as he said maybe
the engines can hold it but it was just
such an unpleasant position with that
outside pass pawn for hijab so
i think he just nods his head and says
yeah timor played a nice game he didn't
really give me chances and that was that
he said he's trying to catch fabiano
right and
no matter what
people might be speculating about magnus
carlsen obviously the candidates as a
winner go home kind of a thing
traditionally so
how hard is it to not let that just
continue to affect right you
because it could become a slippery slope
where you're already thinking about that
if you keep making decisions then you
build yourself into a hole yeah and and
i can assure you that the players are
trying their hardest to put
that out of their mind i mean cross the
bridge first you know come in first come
in second play well in the tournament
and then start thinking about whether
magnus is going to play you but i think
hikaru might be
you know unhappy with himself as he
revealed in the interview with his
opening choice because he played decided
to play something he's very comfortable
with
everybody can understand why he chose
the berlin it is perhaps the line he's
most comfortable with but it was also an
opening to muraj above expected and as
robert pointed out several times
throughout the game
managed to steer the position
into a direction into a position that he
was fully comfortable with and when the
strength of the players is so close as
it is this tournament that becomes one
of the most important things not just
the objective evaluation but how
comfortable you are with the position
and its ideas timor did that and his
technique while not perfect was
excellent on balance it was a pretty
one-sided game
well
i think i think that was pretty much it
i mean it was awesome that we got that
interview up again
my guys here robert hess and daniel
niradisky give them a follow either on a
twitch channel or on twitter
and uh we'll uh we'll of course be
enjoying the rest day hopefully all of
you will as well no matter what chess
you decide to tune into as everyone has
candidates withdrawals everything will
be back on wednesday so relax a little
bit
but uh this has been a lot of fun
there's still a lot more at stake
and uh
i think we're gonna let everyone have
this uh
amira skripchenko rejoins us
on wednesday so everyone be ready for
that
and uh i think we have a highlights
video to take it out
tomorrow's title tuesday is there also a
women's speeches championship tomorrow's
the women's speeches championship match
as well
as title tuesday so tune in obviously
you've been coming here every day so
you'll know there'll be some chess on
you should come in and check it out
enjoy this highlights video of what the
last few days gave us and for those here
in the city enjoy madrid be safe and we
will be back with all of you on
wednesday june 29th for around 10 of the
2022 feed a candidate's tournament
great stuff
we can't wait for these games to begin
and so on miss amigos
the next challenger to the world
championship of chess must come through
madrid
[Music]
after 95 check is king h4 and the
checkmate is forced on king g7 knight to
eight
what happened
[Music]
gotta tell the orbiter tell the
arbitrary time to go to the bathroom
um
he was just having a lot of tea there
that means you know it's over when carl
grabs his code it means he knows he's
out of here everybody this has been this
has been a lot of fun um and we have
much more ahead
miss amigos
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you